python is one of the most widely used
programming languages today this easily
readable english-like language has lured
many developers and has proven to be the
most rewarding contribution to
technology
hi guys welcome to the complete python
tutorial by simply learn in this video
we will be covering some of the most
important topics related to python now
let's have a look at them first we have
anjali and richard to take you through
the installation process behind python
followed by a tutorial on jupiter
notebook a very warm welcome to all our
viewers i'm anjali from simply learn and
today i'll be showing you how you can
install python on your windows system
it's a pretty straightforward method so
let's begin the first thing you do is
open your browser and search python
go to the very first link
and this is the official python page so
if you scroll down here
you can see the most latest version of
python which as of today is 3.7.1
and we will be installing the most
latest version so go to downloads right
at the top and since we are installing
on windows click on windows
so here you have the various python
releases for windows as you can see here
3.7.1 has a web-based installer there's
an executable installer embedded so on
now we want the executable installer and
since my machine is a 64-bit one i'll go
for this so of course you need to select
the file that is suited for your system
so click here
and the setup file is getting downloaded
so once that's done we'll open it
and this is your setup page so now we
need to install it but before that click
add python 3.7 to path so what this does
is it ensures that you can access python
from the command line by just entering
its name rather than the entire path
where it's stored so this really does
make things simpler and once you have
ticked that click on install now
go for yes
and the installation process has begun
and with that our installation process
complete
so before we wind up let's just test if
everything is working fine so go to your
search
and type in python
so as you can see here python 3.7 which
is the latest version is installed and
then we also have the idle for python
which is the integrated development
environment so let's test this out first
now this is not the typical place where
you program but you can have one line
command here so to test this out i'll
just have a print command
[Music]
and enter
so hello world is printed this is
working fine
now there's also a command line
interpreter for python which is python
3.764 bit that opens your command line
this works the same as our idle of
course it's simpler to write there it's
more convenient and aesthetic
let's test the command line out too
[Music]
and that's working perfectly fine
now the command line and the idle for
python are great places to start
with python coding but when you move on
to actual program you'd want to offer
say jupiter notebook or pie charm which
we will cover later in our videos for
now that is all so i hope everything was
clear and you were successfully able to
install python welcome to simply learn
that's www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead let's go ahead
and take a look at the jupiter notebook
for doing your python programming in so
we're going to cover the basics of the
jupiter notebook i'm showing you how it
works and what it looks like let's go
ahead and start with the install if you
go to jupiter.org that's j-u-p-y-t-e-r
dot r g you can click on the install
button and then you can run the
prerequisites python and downloads here
and you can see the setup on this and
you'll see the very first thing they
suggest is that you install jupiter
using the anaconda so we have jupiter
notebook and then we have the anaconda
setup and that's www.anaconda.com
you just go up to the downloads once
you're under the downloads you'll see in
the anaconda that they have it set for
version 3.7 or 2.7 i generally work in
the newer version although i did have to
reset my anaconda to 3.6 for working
with google's tensorflow which you can
do very easily in anaconda this way i
remember the first time someone showed
me jupiter notebook and anaconda i was
so excited because of all the cool
things you could do with it so this is
your install here you can download it
open and run that i happen to be under
the windows setup it works on apple
works on linux what's nice about
anaconda
with just the cool things you can do the
first one was jupiter notebook someone
showed me um the jupiter notebook and
you'll see this let me just flip back on
over here for the jupiter symbol and
then anaconda creates environments so it
makes it very easy to create a python 37
environment with the different modules
installed so if you're working with a
referenced google tensorflow a little
troubles with that need to go to
python36 you can easily do that you can
create an environment for python36 and
that's all through the anaconda so once
you've installed this there's a couple
ways to get to your jupyter notebook so
you'll go ahead and just download and
run the anaconda install and then in
this case i go into my windows and i
actually have anaconda 64-bit and we can
go to anaconda oh there's jupiter
notebook you can directly access it that
way you can do the anaconda prompt i can
do jupiter
notebook well actually i'm going to go
back and do this the way i like to do it
but let me just show you what this looks
like when i hit enter on here it opens
up a browser window and i now am in
jupyter notebook where i can create new
projects and go in here and create a new
file running and we'll look at that in
just a minute on what that means but
let's go back a step i'm going to go
ahead and close out of this and we'll
open up my anaconda and when i run my
anaconda it'll start up here in just a
second this is the same by the way they
have a shortcut icon but it's the same
thing as going down here to see where we
anaconda navigator so i'm running out of
the anaconda navigator which i just love
i just adore the anaconda navigator and
the anaconda navigator comes up with all
kinds of cool tools you'll see over here
i have applications on and it says base
root what you find out is if you click
on environments on the left hand side
base root is the one that that defaults
to but i also have my data science i
have my stock poll i have another one is
called node gpu because i was working
with some gpu setup you can create as
many environments as you want i can go
down here and create a new environment i
can tell it what i want in the
environment which version of python you
can click on one of the environments and
clone it at the very end of environments
this little triangle if you click on
there you can open a terminal window you
can open it in different ways the
terminal window then allows you to use
usually like if you're used to python
use pip install you can use pip or conda
install conda does the same thing as the
pip except it looks for all the
dependencies so if i'm in a rush i use
conda if i am working in this and i need
to be tracking exactly what i install on
here then i use the pip when you're in
an environment don't mix and match the
two stick with condor or stick with pip
because you can run into problems with
imports and reliance and stuff like that
so we'll go ahead and go under data
science because that's what i enjoy
doing data science and so when i go back
to my home menu you'll see my data
science opens up and i have my jupiter
notebook first thing and there's a lot
of tools you can open up uh rstudio from
in here i've never really used spider
that much but spider is another python
editor there's a jupiter lab vs coding
so there's a lot of steps in here
there's even stuff you can add in mostly
i use
jupyter notebook and then occasionally i
use rstudio so i try to wrap everything
in here the first time you open jupyter
notebook you'll have this little install
because it doesn't automatically install
the jupiter notebook underneath this
environment until you're ready for it
and then we go ahead and just launch it
and it's going to open it up in whatever
my default browser is this is going to
go underneath my chrome browser and open
that
and once it's in the browser i'm now in
jupyter notebook just like we did the
other way so we did two different ways
to get in here this is i've set this to
my data science setup you'll see down
here i have folders it's actually on my
d drive i pointed this to my d drives
because where i keep everything and i
can go under simply learn and you can
see we have different tutorials and
different things we've done in here over
the years actually over the last year
since this is a fairly new computer this
is over the last couple months i think
my oldest one here yeah oh i do have
something from five months ago but that
was brought up brought it in from
earlier so it's about two months old my
computer and i want you to notice that
the extension on these is i p y in b and
this is important because when you
create new python file to run in here
it's going to create what they call an
iron python file so in here you'll see i
p y n b we'll just go ahead and zoom in
so you can see that a little better
there's our i p y and b and we'll go up
here to uh on the upper right and you
can upload data and all kinds of things
in here but we're going to start with
just creating a new notebook so i'm
going to click on here and i'm going to
click this one we're going to work in
python 3 so i'm going to click on python
3 and by default if you installed three
seven it's gonna be running three seven
i have to actually set this to three six
i went back and changed the environment
to make sure it's running three six in
here and we're now actually running
python script so we can just go right in
here and type in print
and everybody does this the hello
world and then i can go up here and
click on the big run button and it's
going to run it and it's going to print
hello world and just like any notebook i
can go up here to view a toggle header
so now my header is on this is untitled
number four we can click on here and
change this to call this jupyter
notebook basics and then i'll hit rename
and so now you can see jupyter notebook
basics and if i hit the little save
disks it's now saved my hard drive so i
can go back and open this up at any time
if we go back to this window jupyter
notebooks basics right there it is so
and it's running so these are the files
i got up and going and it's got an open
kernel now kernel it opens up a kernel
to execute the program in and when we're
looking at this it's important to know
that it's only setting up one kernel so
everything in your jupyter notebook is
going to work great except for
multi-process
even multi-threading works fine in
jupyter notebook but if you get into
multi-processing you'll start seeing
some problems because it's only opening
up one kernel to run it in here and if
we go under a kernel you can see how we
can restart it sure you want to restart
it so any variables that were saved
let's do this
b or let's just call it hello hello
equals
hello
simply learn hello simply learn we'll
just print b over here or hello
so if i run this hello is now stored but
if i go up to kernel and i interrupt if
i restart the kernel hello is no longer
stored so if i print hello and i run it
down here it's going to give me an error
because it's not stored or if i come up
here and i hit run it's now stored on
here and i hit run on this cell it's
also it still continues in memory so it
continues down there as long as it's not
interrupted and this brings up another
interesting point is we run each cell
one at a time so when i hit the run
button it doesn't go through all the
cells unless i want it to and it's so
easy to click on the run button when
you're doing a lot of editing but there
is shortcuts to that i can also do shift
enter and that's the same as hitting the
run button so it's running this first
cell which is labeled number four we
have our output from that cell and then
we can go down here and run the second
cell and there's our output from that
cell so it's literally running one
section at a time and when we go up to
kernel we can interrupt the kernel if
you have a long run you can just stop it
which terminates the program completely
we did the restart which resets the
kernel i always use restart and clear
output which then clears all your
outputs on here so you know that those
aren't saved anymore you can go to
restart and run all so restart and run
all will start from the top cell it'll
run it then i'll go to the next cell and
run it and it goes all the way down you
can also do the same thing under cell
you can do run cells so it's going to
run the top cell and go down run cells
and select below you can see how that
just runs the first cell and then moves
down to the next cell then you can do
run cells and insert below run all run
all above run all below pretty self
so you have a lot of choices to run the
most common is either to click on the
run arrow or hit the shift enter to run
your code and one of the really great
things about this is once you start
playing with it it's so visual i click
on the cell and i'm editing that cell i
come down here and click on the next
cell i'm editing that cell whether i'm
deleting it or whatever i'm doing on
here so you can see it's pretty
straightforward as far as the setup and
these are the most basic editings you
can do of course is just to put your
code in and because it's such an easy
input it's so easy just to keep
scrolling down and adding new cells in
so that you can go back up and execute
different portions of your program let's
go ahead and do an input and we'll set
up
there we go let's add a space on there
just so it looks nice and then we'll put
uh print
hi
common name and let's go ahead and run
this and a couple things to note is
there's an asterisk appears here on the
left so this piece of code is running
right now and the enter comes in in line
and so i can go ahead and type in my
name richard hit enter it says hi
richard see our little quick short
program on there this inline editing and
output mix is great for doing
presentations the first time i did this
we were doing a data science predicting
when the huge blowers on the sewage
plant go out these huge aerators and
when they go out they cost a lot of
money to replace and so we were trying
to come up with the code that would look
at the different wobbling so they could
replace the pieces instead of having to
replace a whole aerator so they could
replace the bushing instead of having to
go in there and replace the whole fan
unit the fan unit runs about five to ten
thousand dollars the bushing is an hour
worth of labor and runs about ten
dollars you know between five and ten
thousand dollars versus ten dollars is
huge so if you could predict when it
starts to wobble too much and
something's going wrong but they did it
visually so we could actually see the
plots on here and stuff like that and
the output so we'll show that in just a
minute what it looks like to put a plot
on here but just for a quick rehash and
print let's see hope we see you in class
soon when you run the cells they run top
to bottom and it only runs one cell at a
time so whatever cell i click on that's
the cell that's running and you can see
the asterisk appears it shows i'm
running and once we type in our name it
actually prints whatever the output is
down below in this case enter your name
richard enter and it won't print hope to
see you in class soon until i click on
this cell and run it and then you'll see
hope to see you in class soon so you
have a lot of control you can work on
one piece of code maybe you're loading
your variables up and then you can start
executing the code based on those
variables but you do have to remember if
the problem is in the cell above you got
to fix that you can't just keep working
on the cell below and expect it not to
change the answer another important
thing to notice this is a title
you know use your comments to comment
something else but in jupyter notebook i
can come in here to the cell and i can
change the cell type to markdown and you
can see in markdown it changes the
colors and everything and when i run it
you know i end up with this is a title
this is a bigger title so i can create
nice titles in here if i'm working with
a project and i'm actually doing a demo
i'm actually doing some kind of
production i'm showing the graphs and
i've generated the graphs already in my
jupyter notebook instead of going back
out putting that into a presentation i
can just open up the notebook scroll
down add my titles in and i'm ready to
go so you can see right here it's very
useful to be able to put to tag a box as
in this case markdown for our cell and
then i mentioned to you that we can also
do our plots in here so let's go ahead
and plot import map plot library as plt
very commonly used that way i will do a
plot let's just keep it
simple one two
three four and we'll just keep it as a
straight line so we'll do one two three
four comma one two three four x y
coordinates and this is x and y if you
want to call it that because your first
set of coordinates and your second set
for the matplot library and we'll simply
show this
plt.show and when we do shift enter or
hit the run button typo there i forgot
to put in the pi plot since that's what
we're using matplot library.pipeplot is
plt and when i run that we're doing a
nice straight line so it's going to go
ahead and do the figure size it does a
basic figure size 640 by 480 with one
axis and you can see it displays it
right in line so we can do a lot of work
with this as far as any of your pi your
matplot library is going to come in in
line and you'll see a nice display here
again just a diagonal straight line
we're displaying and if i wanted to i
could do something let's do this and
just change this double click on it to
edit it below is a graph of a diagonal
line and so we have our title below is a
graph of a diagonal line and then we
have our nice plot of a diagonal line
and i can even break this up and let's
do this
insert
cell below so now i've added a cell
below this one i'm going to put let's do
take our plot show and i'm going to put
it down two cells i'm going to do this
one as a markup and we'll do cell type
or mark down i call the markup and we'll
say welcome to
my
simple graph and so when i run this it
makes a nice markup and then i run this
cell and we get a nice plot show
so we have a plot plot and i run it and
you can see welcome to my simple graph
so everything's nice and orderly this is
kind of nice because once you set this
up you can see how you can create a nice
presentation while working on your
project you don't have to even get out
of your project to generate the
information you want to show to the
shareholders and if it takes too long
let's say we're running this script you
know what let's just kind of overload it
here we'll do a lot of plotting i'm
going to run it and it happened too fast
if your kernel gets stuck you can always
interrupt the kernel you can restart it
or interrupt it
usually you restart it because it's
loaded data in there and you want to
reload the data but if i restart it here
remember we did that before whatever i
had that ran up here where i said hello
up to hello simply learn that's gone i
have to rerun this cell to reload that
data into the variable hello and of
course i can do run
cells and selected below or run cells
and just run all i can run on it goes
all the way to the bottom so it's not a
big deal if you forget but you can
easily run all the cells i do want to
point out one thing since we did a run
all still doing some plotting in here
and coming down for whatever reason if
you go to the top you'll see up here in
the tab there's an hourglass that means
this kernel is running we'll go ahead
and interrupt this kernel and i'll take
it a moment to interrupt the kernel and
stop it and you'll see that shut down in
just a minute another there's so many
cool things you can do with jupiter i
get so excited and it's so simple
there's not like a huge number of hidden
commands on the page although certainly
you can there's all kinds of back-end
stuff you can do one of the things you
can do in here is i can go up to file
and if you go under file you'll see down
here download as and i can download it
as a notebook which it automatically
saves as i can download it as a python
dot pi file so it would remove the
non-python stuff in there and you just
have your regular python file and i can
also download it as an html there's also
the js slice rest markdown but i love
the html my goodness i click on here and
the machine i'm going to go ahead and
open it and it opens up in my browser
and i can actually take this code and
just put it onto a web page so now i
have my html code of what i just did you
know that's a lot of that's pretty cool
you can flip that over so quick and easy
so we've covered a lot of stuff we've
covered that it runs in a single cell
we've covered going through the kernel
interrupt restart restart clear output
restart run all we've discussed
cells where you can run the cells below
run the cells above run all most common
we covered cell type we've gone under
file and we've seen where you can go
ahead and download as a different
version there's a lot of other things in
here but those are the main ones you can
save and create a checkpoint you can
rename it we clicked up here to rename
but if you're under view let's say i
don't want the header on i can still
just go under file and rename so if i
don't want to see the header and i want
that extra screen space which i like i
can toggle that on and off i can toggle
the toolbar off put that back on with
all the shortcuts and to wrap it up one
more reference let me just close these
out if you do a jupiter notebook
repositories on git and i just go to
trending notebook repositories on the
github you'll see all kinds of stuff on
here that you can go practice with you
can pull what somebody else is working
on they have practical ai deep learning
tf2 course tensorflow examples that's
the google tensorflow i mentioned
earlier which is a neural network
handsome machine learning i don't know
what any of these actually are other
than by the name but you can see they
have a lot of stuff that's published on
github which helps you get started you
find something you're interested in you
do a search on github and you'll find
that jupyter notebook on there gets you
some hands-on and then just regular
coding how do you become a good python
programmer you write python code that's
the basics so thank you for joining us
today we covered anaconda and jupiter
notebooks now that that's done we have
richard and anjali to teach you about
python variables numbers data structures
like arrays and lists conditional
statements functions objects classes
threading and scripting i'm anjali from
simply learn and today i'll be taking
you through one of the most basic topics
in python variables so here's a very
simple statement x equal to hundred a
variable's definition is basically an
entity of a program that holds a value
so in this case x would be our variable
and hundred would be the value it holds
to better visualize this statement let's
consider a box now if this box holds a
value say hundred then the name we give
to this box which in our case is x would
be the variable name and hundred that is
a content within the box or within the
variable would be the value of the
variable now this is the basics of what
a variable is as we'll go through the
various topics today you'll have a
better understanding of why we use
variables and how to use them so let's
move on to the next topic which is the
various data types of variables before
we move on to this let me explain to you
what data types are if you have dealt
with other programming languages before
you probably already know what data type
is but just in case you haven't data
type is basically the type of value that
you assign to the variable so in our
previous example where we said x equal
to 100 in layman terms 100 is a number
so the data type would be number but
when we come to programming languages
there are two types of numbers there are
integers and there are floats integers
are basically numbers without decimal
point floats are numbers with decimal
point other than this a very common data
type that we have in python and other
languages is string so string is any
word in technical terms we call them a
collection of characters python also has
a few of its own data types as we will
see so let's move on so i'll move on to
my jupiter notebook so the first data
type that we'll be looking at is integer
as you saw in our previous example x
equal to 100 is an apt example for this
let me run this statement as you can see
there's no error that means this
assignment is proper
now we'll check the type of this
variable so type and within bracket you
enter x
run this
and as you can see the type is int so
int is the short for integer any number
without a decimal point comes to end in
python
now this is not the only way you can
assign values to variables you can also
assign values to variables
while simultaneously performing
arithmetic operations on them
so 654 into 6734
enter
now let's check out the type of this
variable which would be int again
now if you print the value of this
variable
you'll see that the value x stores is
the product of these two numbers so now
let's move on to the next data type
which is float
x equal to 3.14 as you can see this is a
number with a decimal point
if you run this there won't be any
errors so this is a proper assignment
statement you print x
and the value is printed
now you print the type of x
run and it's float
we'll move on to our next data type
which is strings so string is any word
it's a collection of characters
so x equal to and within quotes
so i'll type simply learn
and run
so no error
print x
and the value of x is printed which is
simply learn so guys whenever you're
assigning strings to a variable it's
important that you do them within quotes
now you can do them within single or
double quotes i'll show you how it's
done within single quotes
[Music]
and the exact same output so it does not
matter whether you use single or double
quotes
now let's check out the type of this
variable type x
and str which is a short form for string
so now that we had a look at integers
floats and strings let's move on to some
of the data types specific to python the
first one we look at is list
so a list is basically a collection of
values so far we assigned a single value
to a variable with lists we can assign
multiple values
and this is how it's done
so give the variable name equal to
open square brackets and within this you
type your values so 14
run this no error
now let's print x
and see what this results in
as you see when you print x all the
values you stored within it is visible
now let's check out the type of x
and the type is list now with list since
there are multiple values stored within
a variable you might be wondering how
you can extract a single value so this
is simple each value in a list has an
index so you always start with zero this
is the zeroth position first position
second position so if you want to
extract 14 then you type
print
x
0 and that will display
14. if you want to print the last value
print x two because we start from zero
so this is one and this is two
so that should print nine
great now we'll change the values which
are stored within the list so if i say x
2 which right now is 9 but i want to
change this to 67
so that is a simple statement how you
can do so
and run
now let's see what x holds so when you
just type x you're printing every value
within x and when you give a particular
number within the square brackets with x
you're printing the value at that
particular location so print of x run
and as you can see here guys previously
x held 14 67 9 now it holds 14 67 and 67
again because we changed x of 2 to 67 so
now that we are done with list we'll
move on to another data type in python
this is called tuple
so with tuple 2 it's about the same
thing you can store multiple values in a
single variable
the syntax for doing so though is
slightly different with tuples
so instead of square brackets you now
have round brackets and within that you
type in your values so i'll just put
four
eight six
and let's print x
so all the values within x is printed
now let's check the type of x
and the type gives double so you might
be wondering what is the difference
between
list and tuple now the core difference
between list and tuple is that tuples
are immutable
so what i mean here is that
in case of tuples 2 you access each
value within it in the same way you do
with list so if i want to access the
value 8 in x right now i'll just give x
within square brackets 1
[Music]
print this
and it outputs 8
but now
if i want to change this value
so the way of doing that as we saw with
list is x of 1
and the value i want to change it to so
let's say 5
and i run this
we get an error so you cannot change the
values in case of tuples once you have
stored the value within the variable for
a tuple
it remains that way right in the end and
in technical terms this means that
tuples are immutable
while lists for which you can change the
values they are mutable
so now we have something slightly
different when we deal with files we
need a variable which points to a
particular file so in general these are
called file pointers
the advantage of having file pointers is
that when you need to perform various
operations on a file instead of
providing the file's entire path name or
the file's name every time we can just
assign it to a particular variable and
use the variable instead so this is
exactly the advantage variables have
with all other values too but the syntax
for doing so with files is slightly
different so i give x equal to open and
within brackets
open quotes enter your file name so i
want to open
say a file called variable
underscore com
and this is
ipy and b so it's my python notebook
and the mode i'd like to open it in so r
let me run this no error so it's fine
this kind of an assignment is completely
legit now we check the type of x
so as you see here the type for x is
underscore io.text io
wrapper
so in python this is the particular type
assigned to this variable
but in general terms you can refer to
them as file pointers
now suppose you want to assign values to
multiple variables what you can do here
is instead of having statements like x
equal to 5
enter y equal to 10
and
z equal to
instead of having three such statements
delete
open bracket x y
z within bracket
equal to
5 10 7
and this works exactly the same
so now if you print
[Music]
x y and c
you'll see that they have been assigned
their respective values
of course the number of variables and
the number of values on either side
should match so if you put x equal to y
so if you give x comma y equal to
this would result in an error because
you have only two variables
on your left hand side while you have
three values on your right hand side
now suppose you want to assign the same
value to multiple variables in that case
you can do
now suppose you want to assign a value
to multiple variables say x equal to 1
y equal to 1
is equal to 1. a short form to this as
you saw previously would be x comma y
comma z
equal to 1 comma 1 comma 1
but then again you'll have to type the
same value 3 times instead what we can
do is x equal to y equal to z equal to 1
and this would work perfectly fine so if
i print the value of x y and z now
they all have the value 1 stored within
them
so we have covered the various data
types in python and how you can assign
values to a variable in multiple ways
we'll next move on to the various rules
for naming the variables
now there are certain rules that you
must follow while naming the variables
we'll go through each of these rules and
simultaneously i'll also demonstrate to
you in our notebook the validity of each
variable so our first rule is variable
name must begin with an alphabet or an
underscore so let's move on to a
notebook so abc equal to 100 this should
be valid because it starts with an
alphabet at the same time underscore abc
would also be valid
so if the variable starts with an
alphabet or an underscore it's a valid
name for the variable but if we say 3a
equal to 10
this would result in an error of course
because the variable name starts with
the number and this is invalid same way
we cannot start the variable name with
the special character other than
underscore so if i say add the rate abc
this would also result in an error
as you see the error is invalid syntax
because that is the invalid syntax for a
variable name
let's now look at the second rule for
naming variables the first character can
be followed by alphabets numbers or
underscore so our first character must
be an alphabet or an underscore and
after this first character we can have
alphabet we can have numbers or we can
have underscore so back to our notebook
by the second rule a hundred
should be valid as it is
and if we put
underscore which is a valid starting
character
a 984 so our first character is followed
by a letter
three digits and then another underscore
this should also be valid because at the
end of the day it only consists of
numbers letters and an underscore
however if a variable name is a 9967
few digits and then a dollar sign
would this work
well no this would result in an error
invalid syntax because as already
mentioned for variable names the only
special character you can use is
underscore what about x y z
hyphen 2 again this would be invalid
because it includes a special character
that is not underscore can't assign to
operator
let's have a look at our third rule
variable names are case sensitive
so what case sensitive means is that
small letters and capital letters are
treated differently so let's move back
to a notebook and say i assign
a value 100 to a variable a hundred
small a
and i assign another value 200
to a different variable capital a
hundred
so as you see here guys between these
two variables the only difference is
that the first variable has a small a
and the second variable has a capital a
let me just execute this
if i print the value of a hundred
and capital a hundred
you'll see that both these variables are
recognized as completely different
variables they have the individual
values
so now that we establish that variables
are case sensitive we can also say that
python itself is a case sensitive
language
now our final rule is that reserved
words cannot be used as variable names
now if you have gone through any other
languages like c c plus plus java you
know this is a common rule among all of
them you cannot use words which have
special meaning to the language as
variable names so some of these words
are break class try you have other words
such as continue while which is a loop
or if which is a statement a conditional
statement so let's go back to our
notebook and see how assigning values to
these reserved words can result in
errors so if i give break
equal to 10
that would be an error
similarly class equal to 5 would result
in an error
try equal to 100 would also result in an
error because these words break class
try have special meaning to python and
with that we cover the various rules for
naming variables the next thing we'll
check out is the arithmetic operations
that you can perform on these variables
once you have stored integer values in
them also perform various arithmetic
operations with variables that store
integer or float values so let's have a
look at some of these operations that we
can perform we'll start with
initializing two variables so x equal to
and y equal to 10 and now we'll perform
our operations with these two variables
so first let's check out how addition
works
result equal to x plus y so result is a
new variable and it should store the
value of x plus y let's print this out
and as you see x plus y equal to 30 so
now result stores 30. similarly we can
perform subtraction
we'll print this out too
so 20 minus 10 is 10
we can also perform multiplication
we use asterisks for the multiplication
sign
so 20 to 10 that's 200 next we'll check
out division
so as you can see here in case of
division the result is not an integer
but rather a float if you want your
result in integer what you can do is
instead of putting just one slash you
can apply two slashes so x slash slash y
and print the result
and there you go now you have the
resultant integer so in this particular
case since 10 completely divides 20 the
requirement of the double slash is not
very visible
but if we do division for numbers that
do not divide each other completely for
example if we have result equal to
2 by
and we print the result we get 0.66 and
so on
but if we give double slash here
and run this we get the result as zero
so in a lot of cases the result from
double slash makes way more sense than
from single slash
so this is an extra benefit you have
with python which is not present in many
other languages
we also have the modulus operator here
which gives the remainder rather than
the quotient so if i say x mod y
it'll give me the remainder of the
division from x by y
and the remainder is 0 because 10
completely divides 20.
on the other hand if you do want to see
the remainder you can give numbers such
as 3 by 3 mod 2
and then print the result
and as you see the remainder of this
operation would be 1.
now so far we saw arithmetic operations
with integers all these operations can
also be performed with floating point
numbers so if your x value is 3.14
and your y value is 5.7
let's just perform one operation using
the new values of x and y to see what it
looks like
so let's say result equal to x by y
print result
and there's your quotient so arithmetic
operations work both with integers and
floating point numbers next let's check
out some of the operations you can
perform on string variables
as i mentioned earlier strings are
basically a collection of characters so
let's look at a few string operations
first we'll initialize a string variable
so var
equal to simply learn
and we'll perform all our operations on
this var variable now the first thing
we'll do with this string variable is
we'll see how we can extract each
character and string so just like in
case of list and tuples every character
in your string has an index and it
always starts with zero so the first
character is at location zero second at
one third at two and so on so if you
want to extract the first character of
your string which is s in our case
we just do
var or 0
and as you see s is printed similarly if
you want to extract the fifth character
of our string we'll put var
of four so if you want to extract n
character your index for it would be n
minus one because we start our index
from zero
and that prints l so as you can see here
s is 0 and then we have 1 2 3 4 and that
is l
so now that we learned how to extract a
single character let's see how we can
extract multiple characters from the
string suppose i want to extract the
first three characters
in that case i would say bad off the
first three so my starting character
would be at zero
so if i want to extract the first three
characters of my string what i'm
basically saying is that i want to
extract the character at the zeroth
first and second position then i'd say
print off var of starting from the
zeroth location up to the third location
we say 3 and not 2 because the last
index is always excluded so if i put 2
here instead of 3 then only the 0th and
the first character would be printed so
i want my first three characters to be
printed so var of 0 to 3
and i'll run this and as you see the
first three characters have been printed
capital s followed by i m
now if you want to start from your first
character
you can also just ignore the zero so you
can say var of
colon three
that is we are not typing the zero in
this case it's automatically understood
that you start extracting from the first
character when you miss out the zero so
you run this and as you see it's the
same result now if you want to print the
character starting from the fifth
location until the end of the string
you can go with print of where of fifth
character so five and up to the end in
this case you do not need to mention the
last index you can just leave it blank
and it's automatically understood that
you're printing till the very last
character of your string
and as you see from your fifth index to
the very last character has been printed
now suppose you give var of 0 to 20 and
it's pretty obvious that you do not have
20 characters in this particular string
so you do not have 20 indexes so what do
you think would happen if i do 0 to 20
well the entire string is printed so
although we have only 11 characters in
our string and we have given the ending
index as 20 this does not result in an
error just our entire string gets
printed now if you want to find out the
length of your string without actually
having to count it manually you can use
the function len of var
length is an inbuilt function in python
now run the command and as you can see
we have 11 characters in our string and
today we look at what numbers in python
are so i'll be using jupiter notebook to
explain all the concepts and numbers so
let's move on to this now the first
thing we look at is the different type
of numbers python supports so first and
foremost we have our most common type of
number which is int
so here i have a variable num which is
equal to the value 5. now if i check the
type of this variable num and i run this
as you can see here num is type int so
int is basically any whole number that
is it does not have a decimal point also
now the thing with numbers in python is
it can be of any length so this
can also be stored in a variable num and
it's stored as an integer itself so the
only restriction you have with size when
it comes to python and integers is the
limitation of your system's memory now
let's look at the second type of number
that python supports and that is when we
have floating points or decimal points
so if i have a value 5.4 which i store
in num variable and then
i'll check the type of my variable num
and as you see here this is a flow type
variable because now it stores a decimal
value now just like integers floats can
also be of any size now here's something
new you probably remember complex
numbers that is complex numbers have two
parts there's the real part and there's
the imaginary part now python also
supports these so if i have num equal to
2 plus 5 js so the j represents the
complex part now often when you write
instead of j you use i it's basically
the same
and i'll check the type of num now and
as you see here it's complex now you can
also view the real and the imaginary
parts of your variable num separately
and for that i just need to type on num
dot real which displays the real path
that is 2.0 so as you notice here the
real part although we entered it as a
int that is just 2 once we print this
out that is a complex numbers
automatically stored in python in
floating points so once you printed out
the real part it's 2.0 and not two so
now it's float and in the similar manner
i can also print out the imaginary part
and there you go so both the real and
the imaginary part for a complex number
in python is stored in floating points
irrespective of whether you enter it as
an ind or a float now numbers can also
be negative so you can have num equal to
minus 5 6 7 point
so on and if i just print this out
so a variable can also hold a negative
value not just positive now when you
think about numbers the obvious thing
are the mathematical operations or the
arithmetic operations that can be
performed on these numbers so python 2
supports a number of these operations so
to demonstrate this i'll create two
variables in which i'll store two
integer values say num1 which has value
10 and num2 which holds 2. now the first
and the most basic arithmetic operation
is of course addition so num1 plus num2
and that's how simple it is to use your
arithmetic operations in python just
like you write them the exact same thing
you need to type them out so 10 plus 2
is of course 12
similarly we have num1 minus num2 10
minus 2 which is 8 there's
multiplication 10 into 2 which is 20
division 10 by 2 which is 5.0 now as you
see so far since num1 and num2 were
holding into values our results were
also int that is for addition
subtraction and multiplication but now
when we did division our result is in
decimal points so division always in
python gives out decimal values or
floating point values this is because if
we had divided 10 by 3 the answer
wouldn't be a whole number there would
be some value after the decimal point
now python gives importance to these
numbers unlike many other languages so
that have minimum accuracy lost now say
you did not want the answer to be in
floating points so although 10 by 3
actually does give 3.333 and so on you
want the result to be just three that is
you want to focus only on the whole
number part in that case you can have
division with two slashes so when you
put two slashes here the result is an
int value now suppose you want to raise
10 to the power of 2 that is you want to
raise num 1 to the power of num2 in that
case we just use two asterisk symbols so
num1 star star num2 and as you know 10
to the power of 2 is 100 so in case of
division we saw how to get just the
integer value or get the floating value
now what if you do not want the quotient
at all you want the remainder of the
division in that case you can use the
modulus operator so you have print off
num1 mod num2 and that gives 0 because
10 is completely divisible by 2 the
quotient is 5 but the remainder is 0. so
if i use this operator for 10 by 3
that's 10 mod 3 now we'll have a
remainder which is 1 so that's because 3
into 3 is 9 and you have a remainder of
1. so the next thing we look at is
conversions now if i say x equal to 192
as we saw earlier this would mean that x
is of type int but if i just enclose
this 192 value within quotes it makes it
a string so now although essentially
what we are storing is a number 192
because it's enclosed in quotes
it's seen as a string so now x stores a
string value if i check the value of x
the type of x you see it's of type str
which is a short for string now often
when you take input from the user it's
always in a string format so python
irrespective of what the value that is
entered by the user always stores it in
a string format and now if you need this
to be of integer type floating point
complex or any other type you need to
explicitly convert this so that is what
we look at over here now initially we
have stored a string 192 in x but we
want to use this as a number and not a
string so then we need to convert it to
integer type for that we use the int
method you say it and you just pass the
variable within the brackets so when you
do that as you can see here the value
printed out is an integer but now it
just printed out x as an integer x still
holds a string value so to change this
we say x equal to int of x now x is
converted to an integer type and then
stored back into x and now if i check
the type of x
as you can see here it's now an in-type
variable now we can also convert this to
float so if i say x float of x it's
converted to float and now if i print
out the value of x you see it's
192.0 so what we did here is initially
we stored 192 as a string into x we
checked the type of x and it was str
that is its trick then we converted x to
an integer type and stored it back into
x so now x is in type after that we
converted extra float value and stored
it back into x and that changed the
value from 192 which was a string to
192.0 which is now a float now you can
also change this to a complex number so
i say x equal to complex of x
and then print out x so as you see here
192 which was our value stored in x is
the real part and since we didn't have
any imaginary part previously so j's
magnitude is just 0. now there's also a
function to create complex numbers it's
called complex
just that and within brackets you can
pass your real and imaginary part so
suppose i want my real part to be 2 and
my imaginary part to be 6 so i just pass
that as parameters to my complex
function and i'll print out whatever
this function returns and as you see
here it returned a complex number which
was created from the two numbers we
passed to complex let's now explore some
inbuilt functions that work with numbers
so the first one we'll see is absolute
which returns the absolute value of a
number that is whether your number is
negative or positive the return value is
always positive so if i have a variable
say x which is equal to minus 7.5 and i
print out the absolute value of x so the
function name is apps and within the
braces i pass x so as you see although x
held a negative number the value
returned by the abs function would
always be positive next we'll check out
the exp of function that is the exponent
function now the exponent function takes
a single parameter and it returns that
parameter as the power to e that is e
raised to the power of the parameter
that you pass to exp now before we use
the exp function we need to import the
math library because exp is present
within the math library so if i say x
equal to 10 and i want to print out e
raised to the power of 10. so math dot
exp and you pass x let me run this and
that is the value of e raised to the
power of x now if you're wondering what
the value of e is python holds e as a
constant so if i say math dot e you can
see the value of e here similarly python
also has pi stored as a constant which
is 3.14 and so on now let's check out
another function within the math library
which is the square root function so you
pass some value to this function and it
returns the square root of that value so
i'll print out math dot sqrt of 9 and
that returns 3.0 so it prints out a
floating point number not an integer
type so even if i pass 6 which is not a
square number still returns a pretty
accurate value now we have another
function now this is not within the math
library it's present by default and this
is the max function so if you have a
large number of values you can pass all
these values to the max function and
will return the maximum out of all of
them so let me just pass a few random
values
and run this and it returns the largest
of the numbers passed just like max we
also have min which returns the minimum
of the values passed and the minimum is
one obviously so numbers have very basic
concepts and we have covered most of the
important ones here today you'll be
learning what lists in python are so
we'll start with the basic definition of
what a list is we'll then see how you
can create the list we then have
accessing of the elements in the list
the various operations that can be done
on the list and then methods and build
in functions specifically for lists and
finally we'll have a short exercise
using some of the concepts that we
learned today so what are lists a list
is a collection of data and this data
could be of any data type in fact a list
could hold data of different data types
as we can see in our example down here
we have a list named x and x holds 1 89
the single letter a
the string hey another number zero and
the capital letter b now another
important factor with lists are it
indices every element in the list has a
position and this position is called an
index the first position in a list is
always 0 so 1 is at index 0 89 at index
1 a at index 2 and so on so this means
that the position of your last element
would be the length of your list minus
one so now that you know what a list is
let's move on to how you can create a
list
so this is my jupiter notebook and we'll
start by creating the most basic list
which is an integer list so my list name
would be num and then open square
brackets and within this just put in
your numbers separated by commas
so that is my first list
run this
and there seems to be no error let's now
print this list out just to see what it
looks like
and as you can see the elements that we
inserted in this list are printed which
are 1 2 3 and 4.
next let's create a list with just
single characters
so my list name is letter and the syntax
is exactly the same you open square
brackets and now that we have letters
inside which are characters you type
these within quotes
let's print this too
and once again after the run you can see
the letters that we inserted into our
list letter
next let's create a list of strings
so i'll name my list stg
open square braces and again strings
should always be written within double
or single quotes
and that's my list of strings
i'll print this too
great so now we have created a list of
only integers only letters and only
strings
now as i mentioned before list can
contain a combination of different data
types so let's try that out
i'll name my list mix because it's going
to be a mix of number strings
two numbers and then i'll follow this up
with
a few strings
and let's run it
so that works perfectly fine
now lists have another format
if you have worked with any other
programming language previously you
would have come across the term matrix
so usually in other programming
languages matrix are associated with
arrays so they are basically 2d arrays
in case of pythons matrix can also be of
list so you can have a list containing
two or more lists
so let's do that
i'll name my list
matt as in short for matrix
open square braces and since the
elements of this list are also list put
these two in square braces so our first
list
would be 1 comma 2
and then comma because our second list
is basically the second element of our
list mat
and our second list would be
a b
and that's how you create a list
containing list so our parent list is
mat
and this contains two lists the first
list is one comma two and the second
list is a comma b so let's print this
out
and there you go so we also created a
list containing list so these are the
different type of lists you can create
next we'll move on to how you can access
the elements within this list
so there's no point of creating a list
if you cannot access each individual
element within the list now here to
understand how to access the elements of
the list we'll be using the list mix
that we created previously so before we
start i'll just print out mix
so you can have an idea of what is
inside
so we have five elements within mix the
first two are numbers or integers one
comma six and that's followed up by
three strings simply learn get certified
we previously saw that every element in
the list has an index position so the
simplest way of accessing an individual
element in the list is by following the
list name with square braces and within
the square braces mention the index
number of the particular element so if i
want to access the element get my index
would be 0 1
2 3
so mix of 3
and i'll run this
we got our element get now in a similar
way you can also use negative indices to
access the elements so when you put a
negative sign the indices are basically
counted from the back of the list now if
i want to access the same word get but
all i know about this word position is
that it's a second last word in the list
i also do not know the length of the
list in this case i can just say
mix of minus 2
so 2 as in it's the second last element
and the minus signifies that you count
from the end of the list and not from
the beginning so i'll run this and
extract it get
now as you probably would have noticed
in case of indices when counted from the
front of the list it starts with 0. on
the other hand when you count the
indices from the end of the list it
starts with minus 1 and not 0. so now we
saw how you can access a single element
from the front of the list and from the
back of the list now what if you want to
access a range of elements
say i want to extract the first three
elements of the list mix in that case i
could just type mix again square braces
and within here i'll put colons followed
by three
so ideally there would be a number on
either side of the colon but in this
case we are taking from the beginning of
the list
so if the digit before the colon is
supposed to be zero you can just leave
it blank and automatically it's
interpreted as zero also we know that
our third element would be at the index
position two but here we have written
index position 3 this is because our
last index positions always excluded so
if you give 2 instead of 3
then the only elements that would be
extracted would be the ones at zeroth
and first position
since we want the element at the second
position to we give the ending index as
three so let's print this
and we received our first three elements
of the list mix which are 1 6 and the
word simply learn now what if we want to
extract all the elements from a certain
position of the list say our third index
position of the list up till the end of
the list
in that case again we have mix square
braces and we have the same colons as we
used previously but now since we want
our starting index to be 3
we enter 3
and the element at the third index would
be included
but now we want to extract all elements
till the end of the list
so you can just leave the last position
blank when you do this it's
automatically interpreted that you're
taking all the elements up till the end
of the list let's run this and we
received get and certified
now i want to extract the word simply
learn
and get from our list mix in this case
what would be the parameters within our
square braces so simply learn is at the
index location 2 and get is at the index
location 3
so our starting index would be 2 but as
we already mentioned previously if i put
3 as my ending index i would not receive
the element at the index position 3.
therefore i'll put my ending index as 4
and run this
and there you go we received our two
words simply learn and get
now here's something slightly more fun
so what if i want to extract every
second element of my list in that case i
put two double colons followed by two
because i want every second element of
my list and run this
so as you see here 1 has been printed
which is followed by 6 in our list mix
but 6 is skipped and then we have simply
learn again the word get is kept and we
have certified
now there's one more thing you can do
with list indices
you can print them in the reverse order
so to do that
just two colons
and minus one
let's print that
and as you can see your list mix is
printed in the reverse order
so now if we go back to line 16
these two double colons are basically
positions for your indices so suppose
you want the second element from the
first index and not the zeroth index you
can write one here and if you want every
second element from the first index up
to say the fifth index you can put five
here but in our case we do not have a
fifth index
so i'll just leave it at this you can
obviously try that out in fact we'll be
using a variation of this in our
exercise later on so now that we saw how
you can access the various elements of
the list let's look at the various
operations you can perform on the list
suppose you want to create a list of a
hundred zeros if we go by the
traditional methods we literally have to
type in a hundred zeros separated by
commas within the square braces and this
gets very tedious so a short way of
doing this is type in
that one element that you want repeated
multiple times within your list and
outside the square braces
follow it up with asterisks
digit and the number of times you want
this element to be repeated
so 0 into 100
and let me print this
[Music]
and as you see a hundred zeroes exist
within our list c now we can also create
a new list concatenating two or more
lists so let's create a list
concatenating the two lists that we
previously created
letter and sdj
so i'll just print these lists out first
[Music]
that's our list letter
and that's our list stg now we'll create
a new list called con a short form for
concat
and how do you concatenate two lists
well you just add an addition sign
between them so letter plus sdg and
that's all it takes to join tourists
let's print out kong
and there you go so the first four
elements in our list con is from the
list letter and the last four elements
is from the list stg
now there's another operation with list
called unpacking
so here you basically give a string as
an argument to this function list and
that unpacks each element of the string
as a separate element in the list
so i'll show you this with an example
if i name a list var
and list off within the brackets i enter
the string
i say hey there
and now i'll print var
so as you can see every letter of this
string hey there has become a single
element in the list var
now let's check out another operation on
list using the list num that we created
previously so once again i'll just print
num out so we can recall what was within
it we had the four numbers one two three
four
now suppose i want the first element of
my list num which is one to be in a
variable 1 and i want the rest of the
elements to be stored in another list
called say others how do i do this
i can just put 1 which is my first
variable a comma
and then star
other equal to num
so what happens here is that the star
signifies that every element that has
not been put into the previous variable
or variables is put
into this list other so let's print out
the variable 1
and the list other separately
and see what they contain
and as expected 1 contains the value 1
which is the first element of our list
num
and the following elements of our list
which are 2 3 and 4 are stored in the
list other let's now look at a few
methods specific to list so for the
following few examples we'll be using
the list that we created previously
called num
i'll print the list out first so num has
the element 1 2 3 and 4. now the first
method that we'll be using is the append
method and the syntax for that is the
list name which is num dot append
followed by bracket and within these
brackets you basically insert the
element that you want to add to the end
of your list so suppose i want my list
to be one two three four six all i do is
enter six here and that should ideally
add six to the end of your list now so
now let's print out num
and there you go so previously our list
contained the numbers one two three four
and after we executed the num dot append
method six was added to the end now what
if we do not want to add a single
element to the end of the list but an
entire other list so in this case we can
use the method extend the syntax for
this is num dot extend
and within the brackets you'll enter the
name of the list you want to add to your
previous list so here i want to add the
list stg that we created previously to
the end of my list num now before i
execute this command
let me just print out sdg so we know
what's in there so within sdg i have get
certified get ahead i'll just delete
this
cell and now i'll run the command so
let's print out num
and as you see num previously had one
two three four six from here and then we
added get certified get ahead to the end
of this list now now these kind of
additions only take place at the end of
the list what if we want to insert an
element somewhere in between the list
for this we use the method insert
and the syntax is your list name num dot
insert
and within brackets you first enter the
position or the index at which you want
to enter the new element so i want to
insert the string simply learn
just before get so this is my fifth
position so my first parameter here
would be 5 followed by the element i
want to enter which is a string simply
learn so i'll type it within quotes
and let me run that
let's now see what num looks like
and as you see here we have one two
three four six and then we have the new
element that we just inserted simply
learn followed by the elements which
were previously in our sdg list alone
now there's another method you might
come across regularly which is the
remove method so this method as the name
suggests removes a element it basically
removes the first occurrence of that
particular element so the syntax for
this is num dot remove
and within the brackets you enter the
element that you want to remove so i'll
remove the element simply learn and run
let's now see what num holds
so as you can see simply learn has been
removed now if there were two
occurrences of simply learn one here and
maybe one after a head only this word
would be removed and not the one later
on because removes only the first
occurrence of that particular word or
that particular
element okay so now let's create a new
list say bad one
and we'll just insert
a few letters in here
now imagine you receive a list like this
where there are few elements but in a
jumbled order you want to sort out this
list one simple method
sort is all you need to do
vad or sort off run it
and now
let's print out what var1 holds
so all your elements in var1 are now
sorted python also provides a few
built-in functions that can be used with
lists so we'll have a look at the most
basic ones so before we begin let's
create a list
x and i'll fill my list with just
integers
so that's my list and we'll use this
list throughout all of built-in
functions
now the most basic built-in function and
the most commonly used is len
what len does is it tells you the length
of your list
so len of x
and the length is 6. our next built-in
function that we'll try out is min
min gives you basically the minimum of
all the elements that's present in your
list so min of x
and the minimum element in our list is
4. similarly we also have max which
gives you the maximum of the elements
present in the list max of x
which is 90. now we also have a function
sum which basically gives you the sum of
all the elements present in your list so
sum of x and that's 189
now in python we do not have a function
which gives you the average but it's
very simple to calculate this we do so
using the sum function so you find the
sum and then you divide that by the
length of the list so sum of x
by len of x
would give you the average of x
so with that we covered the basic
built-in functions for python lists we
also cover the methods in list a few
operations in list we saw how we can
access the various elements in list
today we look into what tuples in python
are so let's begin what are tuples a
tuple is a collection of immutable
heterogeneous python objects so if you
have gone through a previous video on
lists you would have noticed that even
list is a collection of heterogeneous
python objects the only difference
between tuple and list here so the extra
term that comes in case of tuples are
that they're immutable so over here we
have a tuple that's x and within x we'll
store various elements 1 89 a single
letter a which is a string also a word
which is again a string in python hey o
and b so as you can see this tuple here
may not be necessarily completely filled
with integers completely filled with
floats or strings it can be a mixture of
all of these data elements so that is
one advantage we have when it comes to
tuples and lists as compared to arrays
because with arrays you can have only
one data type elements within it now we
look at indices so every element in a
tuple takes up a position and this
position is what we refer to as an index
in plural that's indices so tuple's
positioning or the indices for tuples
and list strings also in case of python
and most other programming languages
starts with zero so your element one is
at the zeroth position your element 89
is at the first position and so on where
b is at the fifth position so in a way
you can say that the length of your
tuple x is six but then the last index
of your tuple x is 5 because it starts
from 0 onwards so now that we have a
basic idea of what a tuple is let's
begin with creating tuples creating
tuples
now the first thing that we are going to
do is we will create an empty tuple so
say my empty tuple's name is emp all you
have to do to create an empty tuple is
give these curved brackets with no
elements inside so this is a lot like
list but in case of lists we had square
brackets in this case we have curved
brackets so that's the only difference
now if i print the type of emp you'll
see it's of class tuple i can also print
out just emp
and since emp is an empty tuple there's
no element within it but then of course
the brackets are still printed because
that's a list because that is the basic
characteristic of a tuple so even if
it's empty these brackets would still be
existing so we saw how to create empty
tuples but how often do we actually use
empty tuples so let's put some elements
into our tuple so let's start with
creating a tuple with just one element
so say my tuple's name is city and i'll
have one element pune if you're creating
a tuple with one element if you're not
putting the bracket it's completely
valid as long as you have a comma after
that particular element so with this
kind of a syntax you can create a tuple
so i'll create a tuple say city and i'll
just have one element within this which
is pune now if you're not putting this
element within these curved brackets
that's very characteristic to tuples
it's completely okay while creating a
tuple as long as you have a comma after
your element so although you have no
element after this comma that one single
comma is important so let me run this
and just type of city as you see city
has been stored as a tuple now in the
most standard way of creating tuples
you'll say city and within brackets
you'll pass your element also print out
city after that and the same syntax can
be used and then you can also combine
these both although that's completely
unnecessary effort but it's possible it
does not result in an error so you have
your brackets and the comma works just
fine now i want to add more elements to
city because clearly pune is not the
only city we know so pune bangalore
these are some of the cities
in india if you're from another country
and wondering so after this demo you not
only know tuples you also know a few
cities in another country so i have four
elements in this tuple and this is how
you create it all the elements separated
by commas and within brackets print out
city now i can do the same thing without
the brackets too just the commas
indicate that this is a tuple now those
are the various ways you can create a
tuple of course all these ways do not
come handy usually you use this method
to create a tuple with n number of
elements and when it comes to one
element you usually go for this just put
one element within the brackets this is
also used sometimes now another thing we
saw while learning what a topolous or
looking at the definition of a tuple is
the word immutable so we said lists are
mutable which means that they can be
changed and tuples are immutable as in
they cannot be changed so here we'll see
a small example as to what the
difference between tuples and lists are
when it comes to the execution of these
both so say i have a list list one and
that has elements one two three four and
then i have a tuple say tuple one which
has the same elements one two three and
four now with list one i'll use this
method that you probably have
encountered before called append so i
say list dot append of five so what this
function does is it adds five at the end
of this list which is list one now we'll
print out list one run this code and as
you can see here five has been
concatenated to our list one now let's
try the very same thing in tuple so
tuple one dot append five and i'll run
this and see you get an error here so
the tuple object has no attribute append
in fact it has none of the functions
which you usually use with lists because
these functions aim at changing the
original list and not giving back a new
list in tuple's case you cannot change
the original list once your tuple is set
that is how it's going to be as long as
it exists so that is the main difference
between lists and tuples list is mutable
whereas tuple is immutable and other
than that of course you must have
noticed the syntactic difference which
is lists are with square brackets and
tuples may or may not use parenthesis or
the curve brackets so every time you
print out a tuple or you view a tuple
it's always got those brackets but as
you saw while creating a tuple sometimes
a comma is enough so now let's access
these elements in a tuple if you want to
print out the entire tuple we already
saw just put it in a print statement put
the tuple list put the tuple name in a
print statement and you'll have your
tuple printed now if you want to access
some particular element of the tuple say
i want to take out bang lock so in that
case we use the indices as we saw
earlier indices start from zero and
bangalore is therefore at the first
position so i have to just say city and
within square brackets one so this
particular line or the syntax is exactly
the same as you would use for a list or
string just run that and here we go we
have bangalore now we can also extract
elements from the end of the string just
like we did in case of list so if i do
not know the length of the string now
suppose i want to access the very last
element of my tuple but i have no clue
as to what the length of my tuple is in
that case what index do i use well i can
just go with -1 now every time you give
this minus sign it starts accessing
elements from the end of the tuple so
minus 1 means the first element from the
end of the tuple which is mumbai and
that's what we got as our output now
although lists are immutable there are a
number of operations you can still
perform on them for example the very
first thing we look at is concatenation
so i already have my tuple city we'll
just print it out once again here to see
what it consists of now we'll create
another tuple say num and this will have
the elements one two three four now sure
i can't modify tuples but i can
definitely concatenate these two so how
do you do that extremely simple city
plus num the plus sign works perfectly
fine for concatenation so i will print
this out and we have an error here that
is because we have not compiled our num
list first so our num list is not
existing right now i ran my line 19 now
i can run the next line we have one
complete list which has all the elements
of city followed by the element of num
now you can also nest tuples that is you
can have one tuple within another tuple
so so far we have a tuple city and num
now i will create another tuple so first
now we already have our tuple city and
num what i'll do is i'll create a new
list say nest so this is going to be a
list so we have our brackets here so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a tuple within another tuple so
we have a new tuple i'll call it nest
and since this is a tuple the basic
syntax i'll have the brackets now what
will be the elements within this the
elements would be my other two tuples
which are city and num so i put in both
my elements here and
let's see what nest contains now so nest
is a tuple which itself contains of
other tuples which are city and num so
that is how you nest tuples extremely
simple isn't it now here's something
else
say i want to create a tuple rep which
has an element python but that element
is repeated five times so what you would
generally go for is type out python five
times but thank god for python there's a
much simpler way of doing this type in
python once and multiply this five times
let's print out rep now and as you see
here python exists within this tuple
five times one two three four five now
maybe this is not how you want to create
your tuple you want your tuple to just
have that one element python initially
but later on while printing you decide
you know what i want python to be
printed 10 times within this tuple not a
problem put your tuple name here and
then go for it into 10 and as you see
here the tuple has now 10 elements
within it so guys remember when you're
putting the statement here it's not
actually modifying the tuple it's just
printing it this way so if i say rep
once again and i run this this tuple
just has one element so next we look at
slicing in tuples
so we created our tuple num previously
i'll just print that out once again so
it has the elements 1 2 3 4. now suppose
i want all the elements from 2 up to the
end of this tuple to be printed in that
case what i do is i go for slicing where
i will mention my beginning and my end
index so my beginning index starting
from 2 is of course 1 and my end index
is basically the position 4 is at or to
the end of this tuple now when i want
all the elements up to the end i do not
need to mention my end index it's by
default taken so so if i just say num of
1 up till black run this your tuple
sliced it gives out the elements at the
first second and third position
considering 0th is our first position of
curse now you can also print this num
tuple in reverse using these indices so
you say num i leave my start and end
index empty give two colons and then in
the end i have minus one so when you put
this minus one here so it basically
prints out the reverse of your tuple
let's check that out and as you see your
last element is now your first element
and your first element is now your last
element if you have any doubt regarding
how slicing works please check out our
video on python list over there we have
a detailed description on how slicing is
and there will be no confusion since in
case of slicing at least tuples and
lists are exactly similar
so let's look at the string that i have
here simply learn now i want every
letter of the string simply learn to be
an element of a tuple how do i do this
well pass the string as a tuple so write
tuple off and within this you have your
string which is again within quotes
right we'll run this command and as you
see here every character is now a
separate element in a tuple so this
procedure is called unpacking now i'll
just print out my num tuple once again
so we can see what's in it okay so i
want to put these elements which are
inside a tuple into various variables
now in this case i know that my tuple
has four elements so i can have four
variables a b c d and i'll put this
equal to num run this and then i'll
print out
a b c and d so every element of the
tuple has gone into one of these
variables the first element went into a
second element into b and so on now what
if we had no clue how many elements are
there in num in that case i could say a
i want my first element to go into my
first variable a no matter what and i
want my last element to go into this
variable c no matter what now all the
elements in between i'm not very
concerned about where they go so in that
case i can have another variable b but
this variable will be a list so the star
indicates that b is a list and then this
is equal to num we print out a b and c
so you see what happens here is my first
element went into a and my second
element went into c because these were
clearly indicated but every other
element in between went into my list b
so that is how unpacking works so since
tuples are immutable it's impossible to
delete the elements within it but that
does not mean you cannot delete the
tuple entirely so that is what the dell
keyword does we'll implement this so
i'll create a tuple tuple one and put
some elements into it one two three four
now i'll use the del keyword now i'll
just print out this tuple
so we know it exists and what all
elements are within it so create our
tuples created it has the elements one
two three four within it now i'll use
the del keyword to delete this tuple so
i say del space followed by your tuple
name run this command now let's try
printing tuple one once again of course
since we did it all right hopefully this
tuple should not exist and this should
result in an error and it is resulting
in an error it says tuple 1 is not
defined so you can completely delete the
tuple if not delete elements within the
tuple so as i mentioned previously most
of the methods that you have with list
does not work with tuples because these
methods change the original list itself
but there are a few built-in functions
which do work with tuples they return
values or new lists and they do not have
any impact on the original tuple so it
works just fine we'll explore some of
these built-in functions
i'll continue using the tuple i created
before that's num so i'll create a new
tuple num1 which has the elements three
five say four twos
six five eight and now we'll perform our
built-in function operations on this
num1 tuple so the first one that we look
at is counting the number of occurrences
of a particular element so that is the
count function so you give your tuple
name dot count off and the element whose
count you wanna know so i want to know
the number of twos in my tuple num1 run
that and as you see there are four twos
now you can also find the sum of all the
elements within your tuple so that is
sum of num1 you just have your function
sum pass num1 to it now the sum function
works for tuples lists everything it's
not a function particularly for tuples
as such so the sum of all the elements
within a tuple is 35 and in a similar
way you also have the len function which
is in fact even used for strings so len
of num1 gives the number of elements
within num1 which is 9 we have 9
elements but remember our last index is
8 not 9. our element is a2
coincidentally now we have the max
function for finding out the maximum
number in your tuple so say max of num1
which is eight and we also have a
function for checking the minimum of the
numbers within a tuple which is two in
this particular case so now list and
double are very similar in the sense of
what they hold so what if i have a list
say lst which holds the elements one two
three four and i want to convert this
list to a tuple so we'll see how that is
done first i stored my list one two
three four so i'll just check the type
of the variable lst ensure that it's a
list which it is now we can convert this
to a tuple so to convert this to a tuple
enter your variable name and then pass
your list name within these braces for
the method tuple run this code and now
let's print out tpl and as you see our
list lsd has been converted to a tuple
we can also check its type so yeah a
conversion has worked out fine now this
kind of a situation often arises when
you put certain elements into a list so
you create a list that you desire and
then you realize that you don't want
this to be changed at all throughout the
program so then you can convert the list
to a tuple you cannot convert a tuple to
a list though so we previously saw how
we can have nested tuples that is tuples
within tuples now we can also have
tuples within lists so we'll check that
out now see i have a list lst and within
this list i'll define my tuples so two
of the elements of my list lst will be
separate tuples i have a tuple one two
three and i'll have another tuple as the
second element of my list as four five
six so i'll run this code print out lsd
so lst is created just fine it's a list
which holds two tuples now tuples are
immutable but lists are mutable so we
can add as many tuples as we want inside
this list so we can make modifications
to the list so i could say list dot
append and to this i'll pass another
list which has three elements say tuple
inside list from this code now if i
print out list you'll see that the third
tuple has also been added to the list
now we can also remove tuples from the
list just use the remove function so lst
dot remove and within this i'll pass the
list that i want removed which is my
first list in this case so run that code
and print out the value of lst to check
what's in it right now so first list has
been removed now we just saw how you can
nest tuples within lists now we'll check
out how we can nest lists within tuples
so i'll create a tuple tpl and within
this tuple i have two elements each of
the elements being a list so they have a
b
c in my first list and d
e
f in my second list run this
and print out the value of tuple before
we proceed yeah so that's our tuple with
two elements each element a list now we
cannot modify tuples so initially when
we had tuples within list we could add
more tuples to that particular list but
now we have lists within tuples and we
cannot add more elements to this already
defined tuple but what we can do is we
can modify the list within the tuples so
i can add elements to the first element
and the second element of my object
tuple so i'll try that out if i say
tuple 0
dot append so when i say tuple 0 it's
accessing the first element of the tuple
and the first element of a tuple is a
list so to this i can use the append
function and i'll append an element
z run this code and then check out the
elements within tuple and in the similar
manner we can also remove elements from
the list within this tuple so i can say
tpl of 0 dot remove
z
and then print out tpl so you see z has
been removed here now just for the sake
of it let's see what happens when we try
to add another list to this tuple so i
say tpl dot append and pass a list x
y z and then print out tpl
so we get an error because this time our
object was a tuple not a list and tuples
cannot be changed so with that we saw
the many concepts that is used with
tuple along with what tuple is and today
we'll cover the concepts in strings so
before we begin let's look at what
exactly a string is now just like you
have integers floats bytes and so on
string is a data type now what does this
data type hold it holds a collection of
characters and when i say characters
that could include letters numbers and
even special characters such as space
period dollar add rate symbol and so on
now the syntax for storing a string is
much like that for any other variable
you have the variable name followed by
an equal to sign and the value of your
variable but in case of strings it's
important that you always put your
values within double or even single
quotes so that is string at the very
basic let's start our demos and i'm sure
through the demos you'll have a better
understanding of how to use string and
where to use strings so let's start with
the most basic demo where we'll store a
string within a variable and then print
the value of this variable so my
variable name is sdg within which i'll
store the string simply alert so i'll
enter the string within double quotes as
you can see here
or i could also do this within single
quotes
like that and then in the very next line
i'll print the value of sdg let's run
the code
and as you can see here the value is
printed
now let me store a different value in
sdg i want to store the string tim's
birthday
so i insert this within single quotes
tim's
birthday
let me run the program
but here you see there's an error it
says syntax error which is an invalid
syntax so if you come back to your
string you'll notice this is because our
string itself has a single quote so we
try to enclose our entire string within
single quotes but what happened is when
the python compiler encountered the
single quote within the string it
assumed this to be the end of the string
so sdg became equal to tim and the rest
of the word that is the s space and
birthday was just there for no reason
and this resulted in the syntax error so
in a case like this what you do if your
string contains within it a single quote
enclose the string in double quotes
like this and now if you run your
program as you see tim's birthday is
printed now in a similar manner if my
string has within it double quotes then
i'll store the entire string within
single quotes
so let's say my string is
tim said
i am
busy today
so since my string has double quotes
within it i'll store it in single quotes
and a string is printed right now
suppose
tim said i'm busy today that is i
apostrophe m
so now in this case our string has both
single and double quote
so here what we can do is we can simply
escape the single quote here so for that
you use the
slash
and when you insert the slash what it
does is the character that just follows
the slash is taken as simply a part of
the string without any special meaning
so the python compiler in this case sees
this apostrophe and ignores it for any
special meaning
so if i print the string now both my
double and single quotes are printed
correctly
let's try something else out what if my
string needs to be of multiple lines so
let's say my string is hey there
and on the next line i'm typing welcome
to simply learn
so if i try to do this in the similar
manner that we did for the other strings
that is insert the entire string within
double of single quotes
as you see here that does not work
welcome to simply learn is just now
taken as a part of the string even if i
try single quotes
let's try that out
still no different still our second line
of the string is not considered a part
of the entire string so here what you do
is you start and you begin your string
with three codes now these three codes
can be either three single or three
double quotes
so if i'm going with single quotes i'll
have three single quotes here
and three single quotes at the end so in
this manner you can have a string with
multiple lines
let's print this out too so we have our
multiple line string so now that we saw
the various ways in which you can store
strings in variables let's try out
something new now the first thing we
look at right now is the length function
so the length function is something that
you'll come across very often when you
start programming
what the len function does is it returns
the length of your string
so if my string is say simply learn
and i want to print the length of sdg
variable
and just say print
len off
and within the brackets enter your
variable name
print that so simply learn is of length
11. what that means is that it has 11
characters within it so even if you have
a space in between even that will be
counted as a character because as i told
you a string is a collection of
characters and this character could be
anything
we print that out as you see 12 is the
new length of your string
now just like in case of arrays
even each character of your string can
be extracted separately
and again just like in arrays this is
done through the indices
so if i want the fifth character of my
string to be printed i can just say
print stg and just as the syntax is an
array the exact same way you have your
square brackets within which you have
your index number mentioned and print
that so our fifth character in the
string stg is i
now remember the indices in string two
start from zero capital s is at the
zeroth index i is at the first m is at
the second indus and so on
now if i want to access every character
of my string one by one i can do this
using a for loop because as we learned
previously for loop is used to iterate
over a sequence and the string two is a
sequence it's a sequence of characters
so my counter variable is i for i in sdg
and print i
so i will iterate through the string
start from capital s and go all the way
up till n and every time you're printing
the value of i that is the character
that's holding at that particular point
of time
so when i print it as you see every
character is printed in a new line now
if you want all the characters to be
printed in the same line of course you
can have your
end
attribute here print that and so the
string is printed the same line but
again it was printed one by one that is
one character at a time now with strings
there's a concept called slicing so
slicing is extracting a part of the
string right now we saw how you can
extract exactly one character from a
string now what if you want to extract
say the first five characters of your
string stg so this is where slicing
comes in and it's a very simple concept
all you have to do
is you give your variable name your
string variable name and within your
square braces as previously you
mentioned that one index this time we'll
mention the two indexes and a colon in
between so i want my first five
characters so i'll start from zeroth
index and go up till five with a colon
in between them so let's print this and
as you see i got my first five
characters of the string stg now when
you're starting from the beginning of
your string
you can avoid giving this first index
what i mean is you can just put in your
variable name and instead of having 0 to
5 here you can just ignore the 0.
so python assumes that your first index
is 0 when you just skip it
when we print this you see both the
results are the same now let's say i
want to extract all the characters from
the fifth index up to the end of the
string
in this case i can just say print off
stg
and within the square braces since we
want all the characters starting from
the fifth index our first index would be
five colon and since we want every
character till the end of the string to
be extracted we can leave the second
index space empty so when you do this
the interpreter assumes that your end
index is basically till the end of the
string so let's run this and as you see
here all elements from the fifth index
up till the end of the string has been
extracted
now suppose you want to extract some
elements from in between the string so
in this case it is compulsory that you
must enter both your beginning and your
end index so say print stg off and
suppose i want to extract all characters
from the second index up till the fourth
index so in this case my first index
would be two because i want to start
extracting from my second index position
and my end index would be five and not
4. so the reason here is that the
element at the end index position is
always excluded so if you put 5 here as
your end index then all the characters
till the 4th index position would be
extracted and if i enter four here then
all the elements till the third index
position would be extracted
let me print this two
so our last output it's the elements in
the second third and the fourth index
position
now python has a number of inbuilt
methods which makes it easy and
efficient to deal with the string data
type now there are a large number of
such methods and of course we don't have
the time to go through all of them so
we'll go through some of the most
commonly used ones
let's start
by creating a string
so my string is welcome to simply learn
now the first method we look at is to
print our entire string in uppercase
so print
your variable name
period
upper
so all the inbuilt methods this is how
they are called you have your variable
name your string variable name followed
by period and then your method name and
the parenthesis so some of the methods
require some parameters to be passed
within it and some of the methods do not
so the upper method prints our string in
uppercase now you must remember that
these methods do not change the value of
the original string they just return a
new string so stg.upper
let's print that and our entire string
is printed in uppercase in the similar
manner we have a method to print our
string in lowercase 2.
there you go that's just dot lower so
here are entire strings in lower case
entire string is printed in uppercase
now initially we saw that if you want to
extract a particular character at
certain location you can just give the
location index and the character is
extracted now what if you want to find
out the index of a particular character
in that case we have a method called
find find returns the index of the first
occurrence of the character
so the syntax is very similar
your variable name dot find
now for this method you need a parameter
passed and the parameter of course is
the character whose index we want to
find out so suppose i want to find the
index of the character capital s
so a character capital s is at the 11th
position with the positioning or the
index starting from 0 onwards now
there's another function which is
exactly similar to find which is the
index function and the index function 2
does the same thing it returns the index
of the character that you pass within
the brackets so if i say s here both of
them return the index which is 11. now
these methods they give the index of the
first occurrence of this character since
we only have one capital s it's obvious
it's giving the index of this particular
character now if i say l as you can see
a string it has an l here and one here
too
so if i give l in these two places let's
run a program you see the index return
is for this l that is our very first l
now let's look at another inbuilt method
for strings which is the split function
so what the split function does is it it
converts your string to a list and it
does this based on a delimiter that we
pass as a parameter to the method
so if i say print off
stg.split
and within these brackets i'll pass the
parameter now if you look at a string
here it's a sentence or a phrase where
each word is separated by a space so if
we want each word to be a separate
element of the list then what separating
these words is the space and that would
be a delimiter here
so within quotes i pass space
let's run this if you notice the last
output that we got here this is a list
and the elements of this list are the
words in our string
so if we observe the return value of
these methods you'll notice that the
first two return a string these two they
return an integer or the index number
and the last one that we executed that
is a split method that returns a list
now often this is a very useful method
so what you do is you store the return
value of this method in a variable
say x
equal to stg.split off
and then you can utilize this list in
doing multiple functions
in this case i have nothing to do with x
i'm just printing it
but when you start coding you'll find
that the split function comes very handy
now what if you want to replace a
certain part of your string for this
we have the replace method so you have
sdj dot replace
now within the bracket you have two
parameters to pass the first parameter
is that part of the string that is to be
replaced so suppose i want to replace
the word simply learn in my string so
that will be my first parameter
and my second parameter is what i want
to replace this particular part of the
string by so i want my string to say
welcome to python tutorial instead of
welcome to simply learn so i'll replace
simply learn with python
tutorial
let me print that out
so this method 2 will return a string it
will not change our original string none
of these methods do that
yeah so as you can see here it's
returned welcome to python tutorial
instead of welcome to simply learn now
python has another data type called
tuple if you would have gone through a
previous video on variables we
introduced tuples there so tuples are a
lot like lists except they're immutable
now our next method is the r partition
method so our partition method is a lot
like the split method but here it
creates a tuple so it returns a tuple
and this tuple always has three elements
let's start writing this method and then
i'll explain to you how it works
so sdg dot our partition
and within the brackets you enter that
one part of the string based on which
you'll create this partition now if i
pass within my brackets the string space
to space what this will do is my tuple
always has to have three elements so if
you look at the original string
this part here that is the space 2 space
forms the middle element of my tuple
that is the second element of my tuple
everything before this part that is the
entire welcome word will become the
first element of my tuple and everything
after this part which is the word simply
learn becomes the third element of my
tuple
so i'll print this out and you can see
how it looks like
so as you see here our partition
returned a tuple and split here this
returned a list so our tuples
second element is what we passed within
our brackets and the other two elements
are everything before and after it
respectively so these are some of the
basic and commonly used inbuilt methods
with strings in python now let's move on
to concatenating strings
so string concatenations are pretty
simple with python say you have two
strings
sdg one which holds good
and sdg 2
which holds morning
now using these two strings you want to
create a third string which holds good
morning
so what i can do is i'll just have a
variable stg and that will be equal to
sdg 1
plus now i need a space between these
two words so plus space
which will be inserted within quotes
because at the end it's all a string
again the plus and our next variable
which is stg2
and then i'll print sdg out
so you can see here scg printed out good
morning good from sdg one and morning
from stg2 now if you have no operations
to be done with the concatenation of two
strings that is you do not need this
third variable at all you can directly
put this concatenation part within our
print statement
like that
it's exactly the same now things get
slightly more complicated when you have
a number of strings to add
now let's say i have three strings so
sdg one which holds hey
sdg 2
which holds there
and sg 3
which holds all
now what i want my new string to have is
hey there comma
all followed by an exclamation now this
could be done in the previous way we can
have the plus symbol to add the various
strings including the space the comma
and everything inserted within quotes
but that gets a little messy when you
have a number of variables to add and
other extra strings to be added in
between so here is where we use the
format inbuilt function for strings so
what we're going to do here so we'll
have a fourth variable sdg now i'll just
write down the format first and then
i'll explain it to you
okay so how this works is first
you have to give a format for your
string so that is inserted within double
quotes now these braces here the curly
braces they are called placeholders
wherever the curly braces are placed
that is exactly where the respective
string from your format function will go
to that is our first placeholder will be
replaced by the value of stg1 our second
placeholder will be replaced by the
value of sdg2 and our third placeholder
here would be replaced by the value of
sdg 3 and everything that is in between
is printed exactly the same so here i
have inserted a space this space will be
printed exactly as it is in the same
location that i have given the comma and
the space here two will be printed
exactly the same way and the exclamation
would be printed the same too so at
first you give a string within which you
have placeholders for these strings that
already exist
followed by dot and then the format
function to which you pass the variables
that take the place of these
placeholders
so now let's print out sdg
and as you see sdg holds exactly what we
wanted hey there comma space all
exclamation dictionaries and sets in
python so first let's have a look at
what a dictionary is by definition a
dictionary is an unordered collection of
data stored as a pair of key and value
so dictionary basically is another data
type just like your lists and your
tuples but here they are not exactly a
sequence because the order in which you
store the elements are not very
important in the case of a dictionary
also every element is a pair of values
so there's the key and there's the value
the key is basically like your index in
a list or a tuple but here in
dictionaries keys can be not just
integers but also strings so that is the
main difference between dictionaries and
other sequences such as lists and tuples
now let's have a look at exactly how
this works but first we look at its
syntax so you have your variable name or
the dictionary name equal to and within
curly braces you have your data stored
so each data here is a key value pair as
i mentioned earlier so our first data
would be key one and then you have the
double colon so the double colon
basically separates the key and the
value so value 1 is assigned to key 1
value 2 is assigned to key 2 and so on
and every pair of value and key is
separated by a comma so now we'll move
to jupiter notebook to have a look at
how dictionaries work let's start with
creating dictionaries so first we'll
make an empty dictionary so how is this
done you have your variable name which
will be your dictionary name basically
so i'm taking my variable name as d1 and
as we previously saw dictionary elements
are enclosed within curly braces so you
can just put down curly braces here and
since you are creating an empty
dictionary have no element inside and
that is pretty much it that's how you
create an empty dictionary i'll just
print this out print d1 also print out
its type
so as you see here guys this is an empty
dictionary the class is ticked the short
for dictionary of course now let's
create a dictionary with elements so my
dictionary name this time would be d2
again curly braces and now within these
curly braces we'll enter our elements so
my first elements key is say 1 and the
value assigned to this key would be
welcome my second elements key is 2
value assigned to this would be 2 3rd
key and third value and finally the
fourth key and its corresponding fourth
value
now let me print d2 out so we created
our second dictionary successfully now
here these integers are the keys and the
strings are the values now i mentioned
previously too that in case of
dictionaries the keys are like indices
but here these indices slash keys do not
need to be integers they can also be
strings so next up let's create a
dictionary with the keys being strings
too so my next dictionary's name is d3
and now within curly braces enter your
elements again so my first element key
would be name the double colon and then
enter the name although name is a key
since it's still a string we need to
enter them in double quotes did not
forget that the next key would be age
which is 22 and finally the profession
and sam here is a student
so that's our dictionary d3 i'll print
this out too so we created an empty
dictionary we created a dictionary with
its indices as just integers now there's
another method of creating dictionaries
which is using the dict method so let's
check this out my dictionary name is d4
and i'll be using the dictionary method
now i'll pass the dictionary elements
within the dictionary method again using
curly braces now this kind of creation
of a dictionary is not needed the above
methods are so much more simpler and
that's what we usually go with but just
for the sake of your knowledge we'll
check this out too so again i'll just
put down these elements here copy paste
them inside these curly braces and then
print out d4 so as you see it's just the
same thing we get the exact same result
using this dictionary method to now when
you're using the dictionary method make
sure that you have not named any
variable as dict previously in that case
if you did name any variable when you
put down this method it'll give you an
error saying method is not callable so
if you did by mistake create a variable
or a method saying dict make sure you
delete it before you run this line now
another syntax for using the method and
creating a dictionary let's look at that
so now my dictionary is d5 using that
method again so this time we'll pass
every key and its corresponding value as
a pair within round brackets so we are
basically passing these pairs as
elements of a list or by syntax you can
say as tuples within a list so you have
one is welcome
remember to put the quotes always for
strings two
so as you notice in this case we are not
using the double colons what we are
doing is to the method we are passing a
list of pairs of the elements and each
of these pairs are enclosed within these
round brackets here now print out d5 so
there's an error here the error is of
course that we have double colons
in space of comma so i'll correct that
and run the code again and there you go
so d5 is also created it's exactly the
same as d2 or d4 it's just a different
method of creating it now the final type
of dictionary that we'll be creating are
nested dictionaries so you can have a
dictionary within a dictionary just like
you can have a list within a list or a
tuple within a tuple so let's see how
this is done and why this would be done
too so if you look at d3 here we had
this key name which had one value sam
but now what if our key name has two
values that's the first name and the
second name now in this case name can be
the key to another dictionary and within
this dictionary we can store the first
and the second name again with their
corresponding keys so we look at that i
have my dictionary d6 here and we'll use
a simple method of creating a dictionary
i'll just copy paste this line where i'm
storing sam's details and edit this out
so name is the key to a dictionary and
within this dictionary i'll have two
keys first which is basically your first
name that is sam and last that sam's
last name which is crew and that's how
you create a nested dictionary print d6
out so it's done as you can see here
name is the key for our dictionary which
is inside our main dictionary and inside
this nested dictionary too we have two
keys first and last each of them with
values so now that we learned how to
create dictionaries let's see how you
can add more elements to them so i'll
create an empty dictionary first say d
and now i want to add my first element
to this dictionary so i can say d of 0
just like how you do in case of list
equal to and the value then i'll print
out d so that's how it's done 0 becomes
your key and welcome is the value now i
can also add a tuple to this dictionary
so if i want my second element or the
value of key 1 to be a tuple i go like d
of 1 equal to and then just how you
would define a double go ahead and
create that
and then i'll print out d so now we have
two elements in our dictionary d the
first is the string welcome followed by
a tuple with three elements so i just
missed out a comma here and forgot to
close my strings so yeah our dictionary
has two elements the first one is a
string welcome and the second element is
a tuple with three elements within it
which are how are and the string u so so
far we use numbers as indices for adding
elements which made the number the key
now as we saw previously dictionaries
can also have keys which are strings so
how do you assign these well the same
way but now instead of number put down a
string and i say d of name equal to sam
right and then print out d so our first
two elements have the key 0 and 1
integers our last element is having the
key as name which is a string and a
value which is again a string now
similarly you can also add dictionary as
an element to this already existing
dictionary now in this particular case i
don't want to add another element in
fact i want to update the value of a key
name i want the value to be another
dictionary just like we had previously
so i'll again say name where the index
is supposed to be and then equal to
curly braces where i'll create my
dictionary so that'll be
the key first which will have the value
sam and the key
last
which will have the value true print d
out and there you go so your value for
the key name has been updated now so we
saw how we can add elements or update
elements now let's have a look at how
you can access the elements which are
already present in your dictionary so
the syntax we use again here is very
similar to that for lists or tuples
before we move ahead though i'll just
print out
d so that we can refresh us to whatever
was stored in d so we have three
elements here key 0 has the value
welcome key 1 with the tuple how are you
and then finally key 3 which is name
which has a dictionary as its value and
the dictionary holds the first and the
last name so now if i want to retrieve
the value of the key name i can just say
d of
name and i'll give you the value of the
key name now if i want the value of just
the key first which is within the key
name
i can go ahead with the sort of syntax
you'd use for lists and tuples again
when they are nested so d of name which
returns this dictionary here as we saw
previously and now from this dictionary
if i want to extract the value of the
key first then i would just say first
within the square brackets and that is
how you retrieve the value within a
nested dictionary now this is a very
simple method yet again we have a method
which is specific for retrieving values
with dictionaries which is the get
method so if i say d dot get off and
within the brackets i pass the key say 1
run this line here and that too
retrieves the value of the particular
key so we created dictionaries we
inserted elements into it updated those
elements and even saw how to access
these elements now let's look at how you
can delete the elements so once again
before we begin i'll just print out our
dictionary on which we'll be operating
so that's d and these are the elements
within d now the first method that you
can use for deleting elements is the pop
method so i'll say d dot pop off and
within the bracket to insert the key
whose values you want to delete so
suppose i want to delete welcome which
is at key 0 so i just enter 0 in here
run the code and the pop method
basically deletes the value for the key
that's given and it returns this value
so it's returned welcome
also if we check d now welcome won't
exist within it anymore now the other
method which is popularly used for
deleting elements is pop item now with
pop we specified the element we want to
delete with pop item we did not specify
this element because it's always the
last element of the dictionary so you
just say d dot pop item run the code
again pop item just like pop returns the
element while deleting it also so i'll
print out d now and as you see here d
just has one element left after the two
deletions which is the value of key one
and that's basically how you delete
elements from a dictionary now we'll
also check out some inbuilt methods or
inbuilt functions with dictionaries
before we move on to that though we'll
put a dictionary back into its previous
state so we'll just run the line where
we created our dictionary once more this
line here let's check out d now so our
dictionaries back to its original state
and now we can perform the next few
operations on them so there are a number
of inbuilt functions used with
dictionaries but here we'll just focus
on some of the very important and
commonly used ones so the first one
we're going to look at is values so you
say d dot values off now what this
function does it returns all the values
of the dictionary so it returns just the
values not the case run this so as you
can see here all the values are returned
as a dict values type object now there's
a slightly different method of creating
a dictionary which is using the from
keys function so what this function does
is basically it takes two sequences one
for the keys and one for the value and
then it creates a dictionary using these
keys and values so first i'll create a
sequence for my keys my keys would be
abcd
and then i'll just have one single value
here one and i want each of these keys
to have the value as one so this is
where the from keys method comes very
handy say dick dot from keys and then
you pass on the sequence of keys and the
value let's run the command so a
dictionary is created here with our keys
abcd and as i mentioned previously you
can probably notice here the best that
dictionaries are unordered so just
because i gave the sequence as abcd does
not mean that this sequence or this
order will hold in the dictionary that's
created and now finally we'll use the
clear method to completely remove this
dictionary now if i try to print d here
it's an empty dictionary so with that we
come to an end of what dictionaries is
and next we look at sets
so what are sets in python by definition
a set is an unordered collection of
unique elements so the terms we must
concentrate on here are unordered just
like dictionaries in sets also there's
no particular order to the elements
stored in it also unique element as in
suppose you have the letter a and you
enter this twice while creating the set
ultimately when the set is stored or
when you print out the set you'll notice
that a only occurs once so every element
of the set is unique now set basically
brings out the mathematical notion of a
set that means you can easily find out
the union of two sets or the
intersection of two sets or any such
operation that you'd normally do on
mathematical sets also sets are iterable
and mutable and they provide a very
optimized way of checking if an element
is within it or not now let's have a
look at the syntax of a set you have the
variable name or the set name equal to
and then you use the set method to
create the set you pass to this a list
of the elements that you want inside the
set so unlike dictionaries in sets you
don't have key value pairs it's just the
values now we'll move back to our
jupiter notebook to demonstrate sets so
first things first let's create a set my
set name would be s and then i'll use
the set method and within this i'll pass
for elements one two three four and
that's how i create my set very simple
isn't it i'll just print out my set and
also print out its type so we can
confirm that what's stored in s is
actually a set run the code so as you
see here we have our set one two three
four belongs to the class set now sets
need not have just integers or just
strings it can be mixed of course and we
look at this while also looking at how
you can add elements to a set so for
adding elements you use the add method
so s dot add off and then within the
brackets you pass whatever the element
is that you want to add in this
particular case i'm adding a so i'll run
that and then print out s
so yes a is added to the end of the set
but again since this is a set the order
does not matter so now sets are mutable
so i was able to add a new element to
the set now we have another thing called
frozen set now frozen sets are just like
sets except they are immutable so here
i'll create a frozen set for which we
use the function again called frozen set
pass on the elements here and then i'll
print out fs so the syntax for creating
a frozen set is just like that for
creating a set and yeah we have the
elements here now i want to add an
element to fs if i say fs add off and
pass e here you'll notice you get an
error and the error says that attribute
add is not associated with frozen set
this simply because add modifies a set
and frozen sets do not allow this kind
of a modification now as i mentioned
before set in python represent the
notion of sets in math so that means
that we can also have operations such as
union and intersection on set and these
are the most common operations that you
do perform with sets so let's have a
look at these so i'll create two sets
initially s1
which will have the elements 1 3 7 2 and
then s2 having the elements three
two eight nine so these are our two sets
now first we'll apply the union
operation so you say s1 dot union off
and within the brackets pass s2 run this
so what union does is it brings all the
elements of s1 and s2 together into
another set and of course any kind of
reputation is removed because sets have
unique elements so as you can see here
you have three in s1 and s2 both but
three appears just once in our union set
now we can also have intersection of s1
and s2 now we can also subtract a set
from another so s1 dot difference of s2
basically removes all the elements from
s1 which are also found in s2 run this
line here and the result is 1 and 7. so
we'll go back to our list here and
confirm this now s1 has 1372 but s2 has
elements 3 and 2. so when you remove s2
from s1 all you're left with is 1 and 7
if else statement in python so if else
is a decision making statement and there
are various formats of this so let's
begin and one by one we look at each of
these formats so the first one and the
most primitive form of the if else
statement is the if statement here's the
syntax for if so you have the keyword if
followed by the condition and then we
have the double colons on the next line
you can put in your statements which
will be executed if this condition
results in true so all these statements
are indented slightly towards the right
this indicates that these statements are
within the if block so how exactly does
this if statement work let's look at the
flow chart to understand this so at
first we have the test expression or the
condition now if this condition results
in true that means that the statements
which are inside the if block those will
be executed if this condition results in
false then the control of the program
will skip to the statement after the if
block and in either case the program
then proceeds to print these statements
right after the if block so we'll better
understand this through an example i'll
move on to my jupiter notebook where
i'll demonstrate a code now i'll have a
variable a which is equal to the value
20. so i'll write an if statement the
keyword if followed by the condition and
my condition here is if a is greater
than 50. so if a is greater than 50 we
want to enter the if statement or the if
block and in here i'll print out this is
the if body and if a is not greater than
50 we would skip this entire part and
directly move on to the statement which
precedes the if block and here i'll have
the statement print this is
outside the if block
so i'll run this program now so in this
particular case the value of a was 20
which is obviously less than 50 which is
why we did not enter the if block we
simply skip to the statement after the
if block now if i make the value of a
equal to 60 and then run the program you
see that we have entered the if block so
this print statement here that is the
body so this print statement which says
this is the if body is printed and then
the control moves on to the next
statement which is outside the if block
which is this is outside the if block so
both these statements are printed this
is how if works so the next format for
if is the ifl statement so so far we
could specify the statements that will
be executed if a condition is true now
in case of if else we can specify the
statements which will be executed in
case the condition is true and a
separate set of statements in case the
condition is false so that is the part
that comes under else now look at now
let's look at the syntax here there's if
followed by the condition and then the
double colons just as before under which
you have your statements which will be
executed slightly indented to the right
and following the if block you have the
else block so if your condition results
in false the execution of the program
moves on to the else block and under the
else block again you have your
statements which will be slightly
indented to the right so here we'll have
a look at the flowchart for the if else
statement if the test expression or the
condition results in true we move on to
the body of if and the statements within
this body of if will be executed after
which we'll move on to the statements
just below if if the condition initially
is false then we'll move on to the else
block and we'll have a separate set of
statements within the else block which
will be executed after which again we'll
move back to the statements just below
the if so again we have a demo here to
better understand how if else works we
will print out if a number is odd or
even so initially i have a variable i
which is equal to 20 and then i'll have
the if statement and then i'll have the
if n statement to check if i is order
even so i have i mod 2 equal to equal to
0 so if i mod 2 is equal to 0 that means
the number is even because i is
completely divisible by 2. so in that
case i'll print out
this
is
the if block
and i is an even number and if i mod 2
is not equal to 0 we need to print out
that i is odd so initially we did not
have this capability with just if
statement but when you have the else 2
if imod 2 is not 0 the control goes to
the else statement and only the
statements which are inside the else
block gets printed so here i have print
this is the else block
and then print i is an odd number
now let's run our program so as we know
20 is an even number so imod 2 results
in 0 we go inside the if statement and
these two statements get printed this is
the if block and i is an even number now
i'll change the value of i to 23 which
is an odd number so then the statements
inside the else block gets printed now
let's look at the nested if so nested if
is when you have an if statement within
an if statement this kind of a situation
often occurs when you have to filter a
variable multiple times so let's look at
the syntax for nested if you have if
followed by condition and the double
colon just as before and now within the
if statement indented again to the right
you'll have the second condition so
you'll have if and your second condition
which is condition two followed by
colons now you can have as many levels
of nesting as required but of course the
more number of nestings you have the
less optimized the program is so you
should always try to minimize or if
possible completely avoid nested ifs now
we look at a flowchart for nested if you
have your first expression let's call
this expression one if this results in
true then the control moves on to the
second expression that is the nested if
now if this condition results in true
you'll have the execution for the body
of if if this condition results in false
of else now of course this else is not
mandatory you can either have an else
statement or completely avoid it
altogether the control however after
else follows the statements right after
the if block now i'll move on to my
jupiter notebook to show yet another
demo for nested if so here i'll have a
number and first i need to filter this
number as to whether it's less than 25
or greater than 25 if this number is
greater than 25 then i need to also
specify so here i'll take an integer and
my first filter would be if the integer
is less than or greater than 25. if this
integer is less than 25 i further need
to specify if this number is even or odd
and if the number is greater than 25 i
just need to print out that yes this is
greater than 25 so let's begin i'll have
a variable c and for now i'll have the
value 21 student c now if c is less than
25 i'll first check if c is an even
number so if c is less than 25 and then
c mod 2 is equal to equal to 0 i'll
print out c is an even number less than
25 c is an even number
less than 25 else that is if c mod 2 is
not equal to 0 then i'll print out c is
an odd number less than 25
now if c is not less than 25 that is if
c is greater than 25 that would come
under the else block which matches with
our parent if statement so if you notice
the indentation here this else statement
which goes with this if statement is
indented at the same position and on the
other hand our parent if statement which
is paired with this else statement here
are indented at zeroth or the same
location so now under my parent else
statement i'll just print out
c is greater than 25 let me now run this
program and c is 21 so it gets into this
if statement here because it's less than
25 and then c more 2 which is 21 mod 2
is not equal to 0 so the control moves
to this else statement and c is an odd
number less than 25 gets printed if i
had 50 here run my program again this if
statement would not get executed control
would transfer to this else statement
here and c is greater than 25 gets
printed now so far with if and with if
else we had a very binary approach that
is if this condition results in true
print out the statement a if this
results in false print out statement b
now what if we have various other
conditions for example we have a number
a and we need to check if a is within
the range 1 to 10 in which case we need
to print out that this variable with is
within the range 1 to 10 else if it's
within the range 10 to 20 we need to
print that out now if it's in the range
20 to 30 we need to print that out that
is it's in the range 20 to 30. so in
this case we cannot just stick to if
else statement we need something more we
need something which has more steps and
that is where if lfl's ladder comes into
picture so here if we look at the syntax
we have your if condition first the
semicolons followed by your statements
and under this we do not directly have
the else statement but we have another
keyword the alif so the elif statement
lets you provide another condition and
not just go with the false of if so you
have elif and then condition 2 under
which you have statement now you can
have any number of elif statements and
finally you'll have your else statement
which will be executed if none of the
previous statements have been executed
so we'll have a look at the flowchart to
understand basically how the if lfl
slatter works you have your first
condition expression one if expression
one results in true body of if gets
executed and immediately you move on to
the statement which is right after the
else statement if your expression 1
results in false that means any of the
preceding l if or else condition could
result in true so the program keeps
checking all these conditions so your
next l if condition is checked which is
expression 2 and then if expression 2
results in true then the body of this
elif statement is executed and no
further statements are checked in the if
elif else block directly you move on to
the statement right after these blocks
if none of the previous life conditions
or the if conditions match the control
moves on to the else statement and the
else statement will definitely get
executed so once the else statement is
executed the control moves to the
statements which are right after the flf
else block so that is how the control
flows in if else ladder we'll have a
look at another demo to better
understand this so here i'll have a
variable say var which stores a single
alphabet which is for now z and then
i'll have the if alif else ladder to
check if this variable or if this value
stored within the variable is a vowel or
a consonant moreover with specific vowel
it is so first i have if bad equal to
equal to a
print this is a bubble and print this is
the vowel a now we have five consonants
that's a e i o u so we cannot directly
go with an else statement here we need
to check the condition for each of these
alphabets or these bubbles so now i'll
have the l if var equal to e
print
this is the vowel e just copy paste this
alif again the stem for i
then for o
u and finally if your variable is not
equal to any of these five letters then
we just print out that it's a consonant
so that can come in the else part so if
none of these statements on top execute
the control directly comes to else
statement and else definitely gets
executed so here we'll print out this is
a consonant
before i run this program a small
correction it should be double equal to
single equal to is used for assignment
okay now we can run this code and it
prints out this is a consonant so var
healthy value z which is of course a
consonant i'll put in a vowel now say o
run the code again and prints out this
is a bubble o so this works perfectly
fine loops in python so jake here wants
to print his name 10 times now there are
two ways of doing this
one is he can literally give 10 print
statements for printing his name or he
could use a smarter method and he could
have just one print statement and
somehow repeat the execution of this one
statement now this is where loops come
in so a loop is basically an instruction
that repeats multiple times as long as
some condition is met so jay could
simply use a loop to execute that one
print statement 10 times
now in python we have three main types
of loops there's the while loop the for
loop and finally the nested loop now
before we move into these loops let's
look at the flow of a loop so the dot at
the top represents the start of the
program now all the statements of the
program are executed one by one until a
condition for the loop is encountered
now if this condition results in true
the statements within the loop are
executed and once again the condition is
checked now this loop continues as long
as the condition is satisfied the minute
the condition fails the program's
control exits out of the loop and all
these statements following it are
executed
so now that we got a basic idea of what
loops are and how they run let's look
into our three basic loops the first is
the while loop so the while loop is used
to repeat a section of code an unknown
number of times until a specific
condition is met so suppose jake did not
want his name to be printed exactly 10
times but until the end of the page in
this case you can use while loop and the
condition would be print until end of
page is reached so what is the syntax of
a while loop you have the keyword while
followed by the expression or the
condition that has to be met and then
colons and following the colons on the
very next line you can start the
statements which will exist within your
while block intended slightly to the
right
now let's look at a short demo to better
understand how while loop works so i'll
move into pycharm
so we'll write a very simple program
that asks the user to enter a multiple
of 7 and the program keeps doing this
until a multiple of 7 is correctly
entered by the user so if the user
enters say 14 or 21 you simply print yes
this is a multiple of 7 but on the other
hand if the user enters say 10 or 12 or
any other number which is not a multiple
of 7 you got to take the input again so
let's begin first i'll take an input
from the user
and i'll store this in my variable val
so in python every input that you take
from the user is automatically taken in
the string format and you need to
convert this into int
so that is what this int function is for
and within the braces
you take the input
now we need to make sure that the number
entered by the user is a multiple of 7
and if it's not we need to take the
input again so here's where the while
loop comes in
we check the modulus of val
against 7
and if this is not equal to 0 that means
if val divided by 7 does not give a
remainder
that means val is not a multiple of 7.
so in this case again we need to take
the input from the user
so we'll repeat our first line once
again
let's have a look at the syntax for a
while before we move ahead so we have
the first keyword which is while and
then val mod 7 is not equal to 0 is a
condition
now every time this condition results in
true
this statement is executed
so this is the only statement within the
while loop
now we need to also take care of the
condition where the value is a multiple
of seven so this will come under else
now if you've gone through other
programming languages this might be
something new you're coming across
because else is always used with if you
don't use it with while or for or any
other loop statement as such but in case
of python this can be done
else colon and next line
print
so if the user did finally enter a
multiple of 7
we'll just say that this number is a
multiple of seven
[Music]
so when you're printing the value of a
variable within a sentence this how you
do it wherever you want the value to
appear in the sentence place the
placeholder have the placeholder for the
variable there so in our case val is an
integer type of variable therefore we
have the placeholder percentile d if val
was a string type we'd have percentile s
and after the code you put the modulus
sign followed by your variable name if
you have two or more variables after the
model is signed within brackets you can
enter your variable names separated by
commas
like this
so i just have one variable
and that's it now let's run this
save it first
so your first line enter a multiple of 7
is printed
let's enter 18 which is not a multiple
of 7 and see what happens so once again
as we wanted the input needs to be taken
from the user and this will continue
until you do give a multiple of 7. so
now if i give 14 there you go 14 is a
multiple of 7 and a program has
successfully terminated
now to better understand the flow of
while loop let's debug this program so
the first thing you do is you keep a
breaking point on your first line and
then you go to run
and debug the program
so in debugging we basically see the
execution line by line and to do this we
press f8 so after your breaking point is
placed press f8
and the first line is printed in your
console
so let's given an input
say 87 let's go back to our debugger as
you can see here the value of val is now
and we have moved to the second line
where val mod 7 was checked again 0 and
because it was not 0 this means that the
while's condition is true and you move
into the statements within the while
loop so now we have reached the third
line where we are taking the input from
the user again
so once again we do f8 and as you see
the user input needs to be taken again
so now i'll give 42 which is a multiple
of 7
enter and it goes back to the while loop
because now once again it needs to check
if val mod 7 is not equal to 0 and as
you can see here now the value of val is
42 we press f8 you'll notice how we
jumped from line 2 to line 5. this is
because this time 42 mod 7 was equal to
0. so the while resulted in false and
the statement right after false which is
your else is what got executed so now
you have the execution for the last
print statement
and if we press f8 once again you see a
program's terminated with the final
output 42 is a multiple of 7. so i hope
you understood while loop let's move on
to the next loop which is the for loop
now for loop is used to iterate over a
sequence the sequence could be a list it
could be a tuple it could be a array a
string or it could even be a range
basically if you have certain elements
arranged one after the other a for loop
can be used to iterate over these
elements so now let's look at the syntax
or for loop you have the for keyword
followed by counter so counter is
basically a variable say you want to
repeat your name 10 times what you do is
you always keep track of the number of
times you've already repeated your names
in your fingers and that is exactly what
a counter is to a for loop a counter
keeps track of the position that you're
in in the sequence after counter you
have another keyword in and then you
have the sequence so the sequence you
can literally give your list there or
you can have the variable which stores
your list tuple array or string now
let's move into a demo for the for loop
once again i'll open my pycharm
so now we'll write a program to iterate
over a list now i'll store my list in
the variable x and my list will have the
elements 1 comma 6 comma
simply learn
[Music]
now using the for loop i'll iterate over
x
so my counter in this case will be i
in
and my sequence which is x
always followed by the colon
and now i'll just print i
let's save this
and run it
so as you can see here the elements of x
are printed there's one six followed by
simply learn so what it does is
basically when you give i in x i assumes
the value of the first element in x
prints this value and every time you go
back to the for loop i is incremented by
one so the second time you reach the for
loop i is now holding the value six and
the third time i holds a value simply
learn
now the same thing can be done with just
a string so if x is equal to simply
learn
which is a string
and we run this code now
you see all the letters of the string
are printed one by one so in case of
strings i holds a value of each
character in the string right from the
beginning up till the end
now python also allows nested loops and
by nested loops we mean loops within
loops so now there are various ways that
nested loops could be implemented
it could be a for loop within a for loop
it could be a while within a while loop
a 4 within a while loop or a while
within a for loop
so in our demo for nested loops we'll
see one of the most popular applications
for it which is accessing the elements
of a matrix so first we'll begin with
creating a matrix
store my matrix in variable x
and my matrix will have two lists one
would contain the elements one two three
and the other will be of alphabet abc
now with a matrix as you can see there
are two lists within it our first for
loop will iterate over the elements of x
so the range is x
[Music]
so when i say that i iterates over the
elements of x i basically takes the
value of the first list in the first
iteration and the second list in the
second iteration now our second for loop
which is nested within our first for
loop will iterate over the values within
that list so for j in i let me explain
this once again so if i points to your
first list
j will be used to iterate over every
element in your first list and in your
second iteration i will point towards
your second list and j will iterate over
every element in your second list
we'll just print out the elements
and let's run this
just increase the size of my console
here run it
and as you can see the elements of your
matrix are printed 1 2 3 abc
now what if you want 1 2 3 to be printed
in one line and your next list elements
which are abc to be printed in the next
line so every time you print j you do
not want a next line
so put n equal to quotes what this does
is that it removes the new line which is
automatically put by the print function
in python and once you exit the inner
for loop you're basically moving to the
second list so now you want a change in
line and hence i just put a print
statement here let's run this
and as you see one two three abc now
nested loops can get a little confusing
with the flow for this purpose we'll
also debug this code
place your breaking point on the first
line
and debug
f8 and as you see x holds the two lists
one two three a b c
now f eight again and our first for loop
is executed and i now holds the value
one two three as you can see here we now
have moved into a second for loop
and j holds the value 1 so i right now
points to our first list in x and j
points the first element in our first
list in x
now once we execute the print statement
your first element gets printed and once
the first element is printed you go back
to your inner for loop
and now 2 gets printed once again you go
back to your inner for loop three is
printed and again you go back to your
inner for loop now you have reached the
end of the ith list
the next time you click the f8 you're
basically jumping over to the print
statement at the end which shifts to a
new line and now
and now we are back to our outside for
loop so out of for loops counter which
is i now points to the second list in x
which is abc so when we are back so we
click f8 again
and j has taken the value of the first
element in your second list which is a
once again f8 and as you can see a is
printed in the console below
we are back to our inner for loop
print
press f8 again b gets printed again we
are back to our inner for loop
and c gets printed now we have reached
the end of our second list2 so the next
time we press f8 the control skips to
the last print statement which is a new
line statement and it goes back to the
outer for loop now here too the counter
i has reached the end of our matrix x so
once again when we hit the f8 our
program terminates now as we saw loops
have a certain flow and you might come
across certain scenarios where you want
to break out of this flow so this is
where the loop control statement comes
in we look at the two most popular loop
control statements used in python
the first is the break keyword suppose
you're executing a loop for say 10 times
but if a certain condition occurs
between our first and our tenth
iteration we want to immediately exit
out of the loop in this case you can use
the break statement so i'll just move
back to my pycharm and show you a simple
demo on how play can be used
so the first thing we do is we'll create
a string
i'll store this in my variable x
now to iterate through the string of
course we'll use the for loop for i
in x
and colon now what we want our program
to do is that it should print only the
first sentence of our string so it
should print just hey there and as we
can see in our string here hey there is
followed by a full stop so we can say
that whenever we encounter the full stop
we'll break out of the loop and print no
more so if i
is equal to
full stop
will break out of the loop
and for every other case
we'll simply print i which is the
character in our string so let's run
this code
and as you can see here all our
characters here there are printed and
once i is equal to full stop the if
statement results in true and we
encounter the break statement which
breaks the loop so as you can see here
every character of our string is printed
on a new line which is not what we want
so in our print statement put end equal
to quotes
and this will ensure that you're not
going to a new line every time
let's run break again and yeah hey there
appears in the single line
so once again i'll repeat how the flow
of this program works goes to the for
loop i iterates over every character in
the string hey there how are you
and every time i is checked against a
full stop so if i is not equal to equal
to the full stop we come to this print
statement which is a part of our outer
for loop and only the character is
printed we go back to our for loop every
time and i is incremented so it keeps
pointing to the next character and once
i is equal to equal to full stop we
encounter the break statement which
breaks the control to outside the loop
and our program terminates successfully
now we'll have a look at our second loop
control statement which is continue so
in some cases when a certain condition
occurs within a loop you do not want to
break out of the loop but you want to
skip that particular iteration for the
loop so in this case you can use
continue once again we'll move back to
pycharm so i can show you a short demo
on how continue works
now for our demo for the continue
keyword we want to print all the numbers
in a list which are less than 10. so to
iterate through a list we have 4
i n
and our list which is 1 13
4 6.
now let's see how we write this program
without using the continuous statement
first so within the for loop if i is
greater than 10
which is basically the number we did not
want to print we have no action to give
under if because there's nothing we want
to do if the number is greater than 10
and under else which is if the number is
not greater than 10 we'd want to print
it
now this seems simple but the problem
here is that you cannot leave if without
any action this would result in an error
as you can see here there's an indent
expected and this is where continue
comes in so if i is greater than 10 you
continue so basically you skip all
statements after this continue statement
in the for loop and when you insert your
continue statement the control
automatically goes back to the for loop
so in that case you do not even require
your else statement here
and you can just have print under your
for loop so once again i'll explain how
this works i iterates over our list so i
points to our elements 1 13 56 4 and 6
in each iteration respectively and every
time we check if i is greater than 10 if
i is greater than 10 we do not want to
print i we just say continue so the
control goes back to the for loop and if
i is not greater than 10 that is if i is
any number between 0 to 9 we simply come
here
and the number is printed
so i'll save this and let's run this
code
so as you can see here one gets printed
4 and 6 is printed we can debug this too
just to see how the flow works so place
your break point here
and debug continue
as you can see first time i is pointed
to 1 now i is checked if it's greater
than 10 of course i is not greater than
10 so the control skips to the print
statement and if you go back to the
console press f8 you can see one gets
printed now the control goes back to the
for loop and this time i is 13 is 13
greater than 10 yes 13 is greater than
10 so the if condition is satisfied and
we reach the continue statement so once
the continue is executed as you can see
here the control transfers back to for
loop and i moves on to the next
iteration
and i currently holds a value of 56 so
this way all your numbers which are less
than 10 gets printed one by one so in
our previous video we went through what
loops in python are and we briefly went
through for loops while loop and nested
loop today we'll focus solely on for
loop so let's start from scratch and
look at what exactly for loop is so for
loop is used to iterate over a sequence
now the sequence could be a list tuple
add a string or even a range of numbers
so if you have multiple elements stored
consecutively for loop is exactly what
you need to access each of those
elements now here is the syntax for
follow so first you have the keyword for
followed by counter counter is just a
variable which keeps track of the
position of the element that you're
accessing right now and then you have
the keyword in followed by sequence now
sequence is basically the name of your
list your tuple array string or even a
range of integers and then it's followed
by colons and in the very next line you
can put down your statements which come
within the for loop so to better
understand this we have a series of
demos which i'll be showing on pycharm
so let's move on to that so our first
demo is a classic example of where you
use for loop that is to access the
element of a list so first we'll create
our list i'll name my list x and we'll
have the elements 1 4.2 and the string
simply learn
now this particular list of ours has
just three elements
so we could print the elements
specifying their positions individually
say x comma 0
x comma 1 and x of 2 so we could print
the elements of our list specifying the
indexes individually so say x of 0 comma
x of 1 comma x of 2 and if we run this
code
save this and run it
as you see here all the elements are
printed correct but what if our list had
hundred elements this would be quite a
tedious approach then wouldn't it so
here is where you use the for loop
with for you can have a counter variable
which is i in my case
in
and this is the place where you enter
your list name so x colon
and i'll just say print of i
so what we are doing here is we have
this variable i which is a counter and
will iterate over every element of x so
the first iteration i will hold the
value 1 the second iteration i will hold
the value 4.2 and the third it will hold
the value simply learn
so let's run this code
and there you go all our elements are
printed so this is a much simpler way to
print the elements of your list now for
can also be used to print every
character in your string separately so
if x is just equal to simply learn
and we run this code once again
you see all the elements of your string
are printed now if you want all of them
to be printed together that is in one
line in your print statement just put
end
equal to braces and then run this code
and your entire string is printed here
but character by character so we can
debug this to see how it's printed
just place a breaking point on your
first line
and debug sample
and i'll enlarge my console press f8 to
move from one line to the other
and our first lines executed so x holds
the value simply learn and now we are on
our for loop line the first time we
execute it i takes the value of the very
first character in our string x which is
s
so now when we say print of i
s gets printed go back to a console we
can see this here and next time we press
f8 now i will take the value
i from x and i gets printed in this
manner all the characters of your string
are printed one by one
and then your program terminates
so that's the very basic example of how
you can use for loop now let's try
another case where we want to print all
the even numbers in the range of 0 to
20. so once again we have for i which is
our counter variable in now when you
want to specify a range of values you
use the function range and give your
starting value
and your ending value
so the thing with range is guys that if
you keep your ending value as 20 it will
only consider the numbers from 0 to 19
but we want 20 also to be included
so our ending value is 21 here
put your colons
and let's just see what this prints
first so print of i
and we'll run this code so here the for
loop printed all the values from 0
up till 20. now we want only the even
values between 0 to 20 to be printed
one way of doing this is that you can
check using an if statement if every
value that is stored in i is a multiple
of 2 or you can simply modify this range
function slightly and put comma 2. so
here what this means is that every
second element is only printed so zero
will be printed one would be skipped and
then two would be printed
let's see that
run it
so as you see here in just two lines of
code we got all our even numbers between
0 to 20 printed
now say we want to find the sum of all
these even numbers but this time because
we want to use a slightly different
approach we'll use the if statement to
know if the value in i is even or not so
the first line would be about the same
except you delete the two from the range
and then you have if statement so if i
mod 2
is equal to equal to 0 you will have a
variable say sum which is equal to sum
plus
i
so what we're doing here is i will hold
a value between 0 to 21 and then this
value is tested to check if it is a
multiple of 2 that is if division by 2
gives any remainder or not in the if
statement and if it does not give any
remainder that is if the remainder is 0
then we come in and we keep adding this
i to another variable which in our case
is sum so sum is the addition of all the
even numbers
now we have not declared sum as yet and
some needs to have some initial value
so just outside your for loop put sum
equal to 0 so here we have added all our
even numbers now once this entire
procedures
we can print a variable sum
let's run this code and the sum of all
the even numbers between 0 to 20 is 110
now let's move on to our next demo where
we'll be printing patterns so patterns
are a great way to implement for loops
and also to sharpen your programming
skills in a previous video we had a
pattern with asterisk symbols we printed
an inverted triangle using asterix so
here this is the pattern we'll be
printing with numbers so for this
particular program we'll be taking input
from the user specifying a number so in
this example the number entered by the
user would be 5 and as you can see the
number given by the user is the last
digit of the last row also it is the
number of rows in the pattern so let's
begin coding this first we'll take the
input from the user in a variable say n
so all the inputs given by the users
always in string format in case of
python we need to convert this into end
so input
enter a number now we'll have the first
for loop
which is for every row so for i
in
range of 1 to
n plus 1 because if we give n then the
range will be taken only from n to n
minus 1. now that's our outer follow and
in case of patterns as you go through
others you'll notice that there are at
least two for loops even for the most
simple patterns
so here is where we implement nested
loops
specifically nested for loops now the
outer for loop as i mentioned earlier is
for the number of rows and we'll have
the inner for loop for every element in
the row for j
in
range of
again 1
up till i
so when we consider our outer for loop
it goes from 1 then 2 3 4 and then 5 and
the inner for loop prints from 1 up till
the ith number
now inside our inner for loop we'll just
print j
and we do not want to go to the next
line immediately after printing j
so put end
equal to quotes
but once we complete printing the entire
row then we want to move on to the next
line so after our inner follow that is
under our outer for loop we'll print the
new line so just put a plain print
statement here
now let's run this code
enter a number we start with five and as
you can see here one
one two one two three one two three four
has been printed but the fifth row is
not printed yet
so if you go back to your code you'll
see where the error is it's in the
second for loop we have run it from 1 to
i and not i plus 1. so what happened
here is that since we ran it till i
when i was 1 the inner volume ran zero
number of times
and therefore it's the first row that
was not printed and the second row
printed just one our third row print is
just one two and so on so we'll make
this correction and run it again enter 5
and there you go a pattern is printed
let's run it again and try a different
number this time say 10
so a pattern is printed for any number
that you enter
now another very popular application of
nested for loops is accessing the
elements of a matrix so here we
implement matrix as a list containing
list and what we'll do is we'll take two
such lists or two such matrices from the
user and we'll find a sum so to add to
matrices it's very important that they
have the same dimensions that is they
have the same number of rows and columns
so we'll take the number of rows and
columns from the user first
and convert this to paint
next take the number of columns my
variable c
now we'll create our list our first list
which is x
right now x is empty
okay so our first for loop will be to
iterate over the elements in our list x
so for i
in r because r is the number of elements
in x and c is the number of elements in
the list in x
so for i and r and now are in a for loop
so our outer for loop are for the lists
in x that is for the elements in x and
our inner follow will be for the
elements within those lists in x so for
j
in c
so the approach we'll be taking is that
we'll first create those individual
lists within x and then we'll add that
list to x
so let's name our inside list as val
and to add elements to a list use the
function insert now the element would be
inserted in the jth position and the
value for the element would be again
taken from the user so input
enter
the
i into j element so we'll enter the
placeholders
to
personality
element
i comma j
so we haven't declared val yet let's do
that it's initially an empty list so all
the values within our list val would be
inserted within the inner for loop so
once we are out of the inner follow our
list val would be ready so now we can
add this list val to our list x so
outside here put x dot insert at
position i
we insert val i'll explain this part
once again so our outer for loop for i
in r where r is the number of elements
in x that is the number of lists within
our parent list x would be counted in i
and our in a for loop which is for the
elements within our child list
would be counted in j
and inside our inner for loop we'll take
the input from the user and insert it
into a temporary list val and then once
we exited the inner for loop we'll add
this list val to our parent list x
and we are done with taking the input
for the first list now in the similar
manner we take the input for the second
list2 we'll name our second list y which
is initially empty
and you can just copy paste this code
here
change the x to y and that should do it
now one thing we missed out here is
clearing valve
we don't necessarily have to do this
because every time you go back to the
inner for loop and you say input this
value at the jth position of val the
previous value will be automatically
overwritten but still we'll clear it
every time we exit the inner forum
okay so we are done with taking the
input for both our list containing lists
and now we move on to the part where we
find their sum so first we create a
variable sum which will be an empty list
now this list will hold the added values
from the other two lists so again for
accessing the elements of a list
containing lists we need nested for
loops
so for i in
r once again
and for j
in c
so just like when we took input when we
are finding the sum2 we will first add
the elements of the child list
so say find the sum of the first list
with an x and the first list within y
and once we find the sum of these two
lists we'll put that into our parent
list sum so we'll use val again for a
temporary list and val dot insert at the
j position
the sum of the elements in the j
position of our ith list in x and y
so x
of i
j
plus
y of i j
and once we come out of the inner for
loop that means our val list is complete
we can add this list to a parent list
sum so sum dot insert at the eye
position insert valve and every time we
exit the inner for loop we also clear
valve and that's how you take two lists
of lists from the user find their sum
and finally print it so just print some
let's run this code enter the number of
rows let's start with 2 number of
columns 2 okay so we have an error here
for i in r
so the error here is r is an integer and
when we want to iterate over a range of
numbers we need to specify the function
range so range of and and the indices in
list or matrices start from 0 so 0 up to
r in the similar way let's make this
correction for all our for loops 0 to c
and here too
okay let's run the program once again
and now we gotta enter our elements so
our first element
second
thought
fourth element
so with that we completed all the
elements of our first list
zero zeroth element is the first element
in your first list of x zero one is the
is the second element in your first list
one zero is the first element in your
second list and one one would be the
second element in your second list all
in x now we start entering the elements
for y the first element of the first
listed y
so we entered all the elements for both
x and y and this is our list sum
but then this is not the sum of the
elements what has happened here is that
it's just concatenated the elements of
the two list so our first element in
list x that is one
and our first element in list y which is
2 is just concatenated and it's given 12
whereas we want 3 the sum of them this
because we took the input
from the user but we forgot to convert
it to int that means all the elements
were stored in the list as strings and
when we use just the plus sign on
strings it just concatenates the values
so now we'll convert each of the inputs
to integer
and there you go our inputs are now
converted to integer now we can run the
program once again
enter the elements
and this time
our sum
is printed right so 1 plus 5 is 6
2 plus 6 is 8 3 plus 7 which is 10
and 4 plus 8 is 12 while loops in python
so previously we briefly went through
while four and nested loops we saw that
for loops are used mainly to iterate
over a sequence while loops are
basically used to repeat a section of
code an unknown number of times so if
you have a certain code that needs to be
repeated say n number of times where n
will be decided during the runtime you
can definitely opt for a while loop and
every time you move into a while loop a
specific condition is checked the minute
that condition results in false that's
when you exit out of the while loop so
here's the syntax for a while loop you
have the while keyword followed by the
expression or the condition this is what
needs to result in true to enter the
while loop and the expression is
followed by colons and in the very next
line you can put down the various
statements that go into your while loop
so now that we saw what a while loop is
typically used for and the basic syntax
of a while loop let's move into a few
demos and explore the various
applications of while loop so i'll be
performing my demos on pycharm now my
first demo is a typical example of any
loop statement suppose i want to print
these strings simply learn 10 times i
could do this
using the print statement alone
and half the statement
copy paste it 10 times that could work
but with loops we have a much simpler
way of doing this since we are talking
about while loops
that's what we'll use so say while
and i want to print my string 10 times
so i is my counter
and i say i less than equal to 10
colon and in here i put my print
statement just once
now i is the counter as i mentioned
previously so this counter needs to be
initialized first we need to give it a
starting value
so i starting value will be 1 and i will
move from 1 to 10 that means every time
you're inside the loop every time simply
learn is printed i needs to be
incremented by one
so i equal to i
plus one
now a shorthand of doing this is you can
have i plus equal to 1 this is exactly
the same as i equal to i plus 1 just
shorter and simpler so i'll explain this
once again before we run it we have i
equal to 1 where i is something that
we're using as a counter and then we
have a while loop so now while loop we
are checking if i is less than equal to
10 and since the first time i is equal
to 1 we will enter the while loop simply
learn will be printed and in the very
next line we are incrementing i so every
time simply learn is printed i gets
incremented we go back to the while loop
and it's checked against this condition
whether it's less than equal to 10. so
the minute i is equal to 10 you'll have
simply learn printed one last time the
next time we go back to the while loop i
will be 11 and the while condition would
result in false so we exit out of the
loop and since we have no more statement
here our program terminates so let's run
the code
and check if everything works as we
expect it to
so here we go simply learn is printed 10
times now can you only increment your
counter no we can also decrement our
counter so if i say i is equal to 10
that is i start my counter from 10 and i
want to decrease the counter till 1 so
we'll have the while loop executed as
long as i is greater than one
and now that we're decrementing i every
time we need to change the plus sign to
a minus
so it's the exact same thing that we are
doing now as we did previously we are
printing simply learn the string 10
times but this time our counter starts
from 10 and we go down to one so every
time we check if i is greater than 1 and
the minute i is not greater than one
that is i is equal to one we do not
print simply learn anymore we just exit
out of the while loop
so let's run this co2 so here the string
simply learns printed only nine times
whereas we want it to be printed ten
times this because in our while
condition statement we put greater than
one what we need is actually greater
than equal to one so that even when i is
equal to one we are printing simply
learn once
so now if we run it again we'll see that
we'll have simply learn printed 10 times
so for our next demo instead of printing
something 10 times let's find the sum of
the first 10 natural numbers
so in that case i would start from 1 and
then we go all the way up till 10 so i
is less than equal to 10
and within your while loop
we can remove this print statement
and now every time i needs to be added
to some other variable
so we'll call that variable sum
and sum equal to sum plus i
so i starts from 1 and every time you go
inside the while loop you have to check
if i is less than equal to 10 so as long
as i is less than 10 you move into the
while loop and in the while loop you
keep adding this i to another variable
sum and after it's added you increment
the value of i so that i goes all the
way from 1 up till 10
and once i is 11 the while condition
results in false and you break out of
the while loop moving to the next
statement after the while loop which in
our case would be the print statement to
print the final sum
so let's run this code so can you guess
what the error is in this case our
variable sum here has not been declared
or initialized previously
so outside our while loop
let's have a variable sum and sums
initial value should be 0 let's run the
code now
and there you go so the sum of your
first 10 natural numbers would be 55.
now let's modify this code slightly so
we can find the sum of the even numbers
between 1 to 10. so our first few lines
would remain the same i will start from
1 sum will be equal to 0 a while
condition 2 will be the same but this
time inside a while loop we'll have an
if statement
and the if statement will check if i is
an even number so to check if a number
is even the remainder from the division
of the number with 2 should be equal to
0 so i mod 2 equal to equal to 0
and if that is the case we can find the
sum of the number
and whether that's the case or not we
still need to increment i every time
within the while loop so sum would come
under the if statement but i plus equal
to 1 would remain under the while loop
and not within the if statement so i'll
repeat this once again i which is our
counter variable will start from 1
sum will be equal to 0 every time a
while loop will check if i is less than
equal to 10 and every time i is less
than 10 we can enter the while loop now
within the while loop we need to check
if i is an even number because we want
to find the sum of only the even numbers
so if i mod 2 is 0 that means i is an
even number and we can add i to our
variable sum now whether i is an even
number or an odd number every time we
still need to increment i so
incrementing statement would be outside
the if statement and under the while
loop and finally once we exit the while
loop we'll print our sum
we run the code and the sum of all the
even numbers between 1 to 10 is 30.
now let's explore while loop for the
very purpose it was made that is to run
a certain code unknown number of times
so for this demo we'll work on reversing
an integer
so the first thing we do is we need to
take the input from the user so the user
will give us the integer
and i'll store my input in the variable
n
we also need to convert the input from
the user
into integer because it'll be provided
in the string format so we have the end
function within which we'll have our
input function
now we'll declare another variable nr
which is basically our reverse n and
this will be initialized to 0.
now suppose n is equal to 5 6 7 8
n r
should be equal to 8 7 6 5.
so if you look at the values of n and nr
you'll notice that what we basically
need to do is we need to remove the last
digit from n and we need to add it to
the front of nr
so to remove the last digit
from a number
we can use the modulus function that is
n
mod
and we need to keep doing this every
time with n so we'll keep doing this
until
n mod 10 is equal to zero
that is until there are no more digits
left in n
so this will be the condition for a
while loop
so while n mod 10 is not equal to 0
we can continue with our statements now
within the while loop
let's take a variable c where we'll
extract this digit that is nmot10 would
be stored in c
now we need to add c to the beginning of
nr but now nr is an integer and so is c
so if we just say
nr equal to nr plus c
what this will do is it will add the two
integers and will give you the sum so in
our case if 8 is put into nr the first
time and 7 is put into nr the second
time when we come to the statement where
nr is equal to nr plus c what it will
potentially do is give you the sum of 7
and 8 which is not what we want we want
87 to be stored in nr
we want the digits 8 followed by the
digit 7 to be stored in nr but now if we
multiply nr with 10 and then add c to it
our problem is solved so if the first
time we are putting 8 into nr since nr
is 0 it would be 0 into 10
plus 8 and nr would be 8. now the second
time when we extract 7 from n
and nr is already 8 and we come to this
statement here it says 8 into 10 which
is 80 plus 7 which will give you 87. so
this way we can slowly build up nr now a
small piece of the puzzle that we are
missing is that the value of n remains
constant throughout the while loop so
far so what happens if the value of n is
constant is that every time you do n mod
10 you're extracting
the digit 8. you're not moving forward
to 7. so what we can do here is that
once 8 is extracted we completely remove
the digit 8 from n
so that can be done by dividing n by 10.
so now n equal to n
by 10. but now in python again if we say
n divided by 10 it puts a decimal point
just before 8 so 8 is still there but on
the other hand if we say n slash
10 our result would be an integer and
only 5 67 would be returned to n
now since n has reduced from 5 6 7 8 to
5 6 7 the next time you go back to the
while loop and do n mod 10 it's 7 that
is extracted and this way we can extract
every digit from n and keep adding it to
nr in the reverse order
now that we are done with our while loop
outside our while loop we'll print the
value of nr
let's run this code
enter your number
so i entered 4652 and my output was 2 5
6 4 which is just as expected now we can
debug this code too
here's my debugger
so press f8 to move from one line to the
next
a first line n where you need to put the
input
so go back to your console put your
input i'll put a small number since
we're just trying to figure out how it
works so 467 should do
right now go back to your debugger so as
you can see the value of n is 4 6 7
press f8 again now the value of nr is 0.
we have reached a while loop statement
and n mod 10 is not equal to 0 that is
n10 is basically 7 right now so we move
into the while loop and the number at
the end of n is extracted and put into c
so c as you can see here is 7. now we
have reached the part where we add this
number to nr
so nr is now 7 because nr was previously
just 0 0 into 10 is 0 and plus c which
is 7 so nr is 7 press f8 again and this
time as you can see down here
the value of n has been changed to 46
because we divided it by 10. so right
now c is 7 from a previous iteration n
is 46 and nr is 7. now once again we go
back to our while loop the while
condition is checked and n mod 10 is
still not equal to 0. so we go into the
while loop now c is equal to 6 and nr is
now equal to 76 because it was
previously equal to 7 into 10 plus 6 and
once again the value of n is changed now
the value of n is just 4. so n mod 10 is
still not 0 go into the while loop c is
extracted c is 4
n r is calculated which is now 7 6 4
and n is changed now n is 0. so now 0
mod 10 is 0 and the while condition
results in false so we exit out to the
while loop and we reach the print
statement
and now
our nr should be printed in the console
as you can see here it is
now let's write another program to
calculate the length of a list without
using the lend function
so the first thing we'll do there is
we'll create our list
so my list name is x
and it has three elements 1
2.3
and the string simply learn
now let's initialize our variable length
which will hold the length of our list
and we'll be using the while loop to do
this we'll have a counter i which is
equal to zero now we'll run a while loop
as long as x of i has something with it
as long as x now we'll run our while
loop as long as x of i has anything
within it so we can just say x of i that
means if x of i is equal to something
we'll be able to enter this while loop
now within this while loop we'll
increment a length variable that is
every time we are entering the while
loop it means that x of i is holding
some value so our length is incremented
by one so you can say length equal to
length plus one
or as we saw earlier you can just go
with
length plus equal to one
now x of i holds a value we incremented
the value of length now we need to move
on to the next element whether it exists
or not so we increment the value of i
so i plus equal to 1 and that's pretty
much it
so the minute we reach the end of our
string that is x of i does not hold any
value while should result in false and
will exit out of our while loop so then
we'll print the value
within length
so let's run this program
but as you can see here there's an error
while x of i index error lists
index out of range this means that the
first time we're going through the while
loop when x of i is 1 there's an element
so this means that the first time we're
going through a while loop x of i holds
some value the second time to x of i is
holding some value and so is it the
third time but the next time when i is
equal to 3 that is we are trying to
access the fourth element of our list x
there is no value and this is resulting
in the index error
so this is where we use the try block
the block that produces an error is put
within the try block and the try block
is written like this with the keyword
try followed by colon and everything
within it must be spaced
or indented
slightly to the right
so while loop is the one producing the
error so the while loop comes within the
try block now what happens is once the
error has occurred try will catch this
error and we will write another block
which will handle this error
so this is our accept block
and this is how it's written you have
your keyword accept followed by the
error that this block will be handling
so in our case is the name of our error
index error
so put that down here
colon again and everything within the
except block is again indented slightly
to the right
and there you go so our error which was
occurring previously that is the index
error will be caught within the try
block and our except block will handle
this error
let's now run our code
and as you see here this time our error
is handled perfectly and it's just
ignored and the value of length gets
printed which is three so this is one
way you can find the length of a list
using while loop and not your len
function now a while loop can be nested
within another while loop so for our
next demo we'll have a pattern printed
using nested while loops so this is the
pattern we're attempting to print here
we'll take a value n from the user which
will be an integer and that number n
would basically be the number of rows in
your pattern
so in this particular example here
n is five and we start by printing one
so the digit one is printed once and
then in the next line the digit two
needs to be printed twice the digit 3 3
times digit 4 4 times and then finally
the digit 5 five times
so let's begin coding
first thing we take the input from the
user store it in our variable
n now we'll have one while loop which
will be to take care of the number of
rows
so our number of rows should be till n
so i is less than equal to n and i of
course will start from 1
so i will go from 1 up till n okay so
the outer for loop takes care of
printing each row now within each row as
you can see elements are printed so if
we are on our first row then the number
1 is printed just once if we are on our
second row the number 2 is printed twice
and so on so we'll have another counter
variable within our out of while loop
which is j and j will be initialized to
1. now j again has to run all the way
from 1 up till i because i number of
times an element is printed on the ith
row
now we'll have a second or a nested
while loop here
and the condition for this is j is less
than equal to i because j will go from 1
up till i
and as long as j is less than or equal
to i we enter the second while loop now
within the second while loop the only
element that is printed in every row is
element i
so if you're on the first row one is
printed second row two is printed third
row three is printed and so on so what
we need to print here is i
and every time we print i we need to
make sure that we are still on the same
line
so end equal to quotes
and increment j of curse
now once we exit our inner while loop we
increment the value of i so that we can
move on to the next row
so now that we have completed with one
row
we can then move on to the next line to
print our next row so here we put in an
empty print statement which will shift
to the next line
and that's pretty much it we can now run
our program
so enter a number let's say 5
and as you can see our patterns printed
here let's try out another number
say seven
so a pattern can be printed for any
integer now let's get on to our final
demo so here we'll try out a simple game
so program will generate a four digit
number using the random function and our
user needs to guess this number so for
every digit that the user guesses at the
correct position we print that one place
is correctly guessed so suppose say a
program generates the number
seven six
three two
and a user enters eight nine
three one if you compare these two
numbers you can see that the second last
digit here is both three so three has
been entered in the correct position
therefore we can output
one
digit
entered
at the
correct
position
and in this manner the user needs to
guess all the digit in their correct
order if the user wants to quit this
game at any point of time he or she just
needs to enter 10.
so let's begin coding first as i already
mentioned we'll be generating a four
digit number using the random function
so let's import a random library
let's now generate a random number
so i'll store this random number in num
p because the p is for permanent as
we'll have another variable which stores
the same number but the value in that
particular variable will be altered
numpy variable on the other hand will
remain constant
so this is a random number generated
and we want a four digit number
so our boundaries
will be set
now let's take the input from the user
so i'll store the input
in a variable n
okay so now let's begin a while loop and
this while loop will run as long as n is
not equal to 10
because as i already mentioned if the
user enters 10 basically the user wants
to quit the game now in here the first
thing we need to do is we'll create
another variable num
and into this variable we'll put the
value of num p because num is going to
be altered throughout this program and
yet we want to store the actual value
somewhere
so we'll alter num and num p where p
stands for permanent will remain
constant
now we'll have another variable cor the
short of correct
which will specify how many digits have
been guessed in the correct places so
initially the value of correct will be
0.
now to check if a digit is in its
correct place so we need to extract each
digit from both n which is the number
entered by the user and num p which is
the number generated randomly by our
program so to extract the numbers as we
did in our previous example
we'll use the mod function so we'll run
the while loop as long as
num of mod exists so you can just put
num of mod
so what this means is that every time
you do a number mod 10 it extracts the
last digit so if a number mod 10 does
not have anything to return that means a
number is empty and then we can exit out
of our while loop so now let's begin
extracting the numbers
now we'll have a variable num c which
will store the last digit from the
variable num which is basically the
number generated by our program so num10
would be stored in num c and we have
another variable which will hold the
digit extracted from the number guessed
by the user so i'll name that variable
nc and that will be equal to nmod 10.
now just like we did in one of our
previous demos every time you extract a
digit you also need to remove that digit
from the number itself so now
num should be equal to num
divided by 10 and n should be equal to n
divided by 10.
okay so now we have the extracted digits
now we need to check if num c and nc are
equal
so if
num c is equal to equal to nc
that means there's this one digit which
is held in both num c and nc which is
also present at the correct position in
that case
we increment a correct
and if this is not the case we simply
continue with our while loop now this
process will continue as long as there's
any digit left in num
or a variable n basically
now once we exit out of the while loop
we must check if correct is equal to 4
so if correct is equal to 4 that means
all the four digits guessed by the user
were right and in their correct places
and that means that the user gets the
entire number correctly so over here we
have if
correct equal to equal to 4
you print
congrats
you guessed it
right
and if this is not the case that is all
the digits were not correctly guessed
then we'll print how many digits were
actually correctly guessed in the
correct positions so else
percentile d digits were guessed right
now if all the digits were guessed right
that is the user guessed the number
right we can also break out
of our while loop so you put a break
statement there
and we'll come back here where we print
how many digits were guessed right since
all of them weren't we need to give the
user another try where the user again
enters a four digit number so once again
we'll just copy paste this input line
here
so that the user can again guess the
number
and this process will continue until
all the numbers are guessed right and
the control goes into this if statement
and breaks out of this while loop now
once the control flows out of this while
loop the program should be terminated
because we have nothing else to print
but if the user does enter
10 instead of a four digit number we
need to exit the program immediately
that is we need to exit this while loop
the outer while loop immediately so here
we'll have an else statement that is if
n is equal to 10
then we print
you
quit the game
and the program will end right there
okay so that is done let's now run our
program
enter a four-digit number so i'm trying
out five six seven three
okay i made a slight mistake here
percentile d digits were guessed right
but what is this personality
d is just a placeholder so we need to
place
the value of a variable cor there
let's run this program once again
6748 is my guess so zero digits for
guessed right let's try again
eight two
five six
again zero digits for guess right
okay so there are a number of
permutations to make it simpler
for the purpose of our demo
i'll just put in a print statement here
which will print the value of numpy and
accordingly i'll show you how the
program flows
let me run the code again
so our numbers three three four five
let's start with a completely incorrect
guess
so six seven
three two
zero digits for guess write now suppose
i guess my first digit is 3 and 9 7 6.
so one digit was guessed right now since
i know my number is 3 3 4 5 it's easy
for me to say it was the first digit
it's pretty obvious let me try three
five four five so three digits for guess
right and three three four five and
congrats you guessed it right now if i
had to quit the program
zero guesses but now i want to quit the
program so i enter just 10 and you quit
the game so as you can see our program
is running just fine to decrease the
complexity of the game you can change it
to like two digit numbers so you can go
from 10 to 99
or so you can put a smaller range too so
with that we come to an end to while
loops in python today we're going to
cover the basic array in python and some
of the functionality around it and
before we jump in i'd like to please
remind you that you can always post
something in the notes here on the
youtube videos or you can go to
www.simplylearn.com and go under our
forums and ask questions there we have a
team that monitors these and they'll be
happy to answer those questions array in
python array is a container that holds
multiple values of the same type and
this is very key is that the array has
to be of the same type
so the syntax for developing your basic
array is going to be your variable
whatever you want to call it my array or
whatever you're working on equals array
your type code and then the elements in
the array this is the main type that
they have for arrays and you'll see a
quick list here character is basically
your character as you know it you have a
b c d e f g they're represented by a
number between uh one there's like up to
128 characters that's how many numbers
are in there so when you have assigned a
character that means that they're now
using that instead of as a character
notation it's being used as just an
actual value plus or minus unsigned
character you don't usually use a lot of
these as far as signed and unsigned
characters but it does come up for using
them for containing a small amount of
space to do something and then you have
your pi unicode
the pi unicode is your unicode
characters so if you remember if you're
in the american set of characters they
use only half the memory but they don't
have all the different characters used
in different languages that's why a lot
of times you'll see especially when you
go international you need to be very
aware of whether unicode or just a
regular character and then there's the
interregular integer where they have
signed short so it has a smaller amount
of values unsigned short your signed
integer plus or minus again you're
unsigned then you have your long your
signed long unsigned long so if you want
to have a long basically is double that
so each one of these just doubles in
size and how much numbers they can hold
until you get all the way to float and
double so again those are just different
numbers and just depends on how many
significant digits you want to keep on
there that's a brief on type code
definitely we're not going to go into
too much detail any more detail on that
but we do want to jump in and actually
do an array and start showing you how
the arrays work and what you can do with
them now to do this you're going to use
your favorite python editor or ide your
interface i myself go through anaconda
and jupyter notebook certainly if you're
using any other interface i'll work just
the same this is very basic code in
python i use anaconda because it's a
great navigator for following your
different modules you install into your
python and it has different packages and
then jupyter notebook sits on there
there's also spyder which is another
python editor there's a ton of python
editors out there but we'll go ahead and
launch our jupiter notebook once i'm in
the jupiter notebook it opens up
whatever folder it's set to and i can
simply go under new and i'm going to
create a new python3
and that'll open up my python3 notebook
so now i can start writing code and
we'll start off the bat by importing so
we're going to
from array import we're going to import
all the different functionality that the
array offers and then we're going to
create our first array we'll just call
it arr or we can call it my array or
whatever you'd like and it is simply
array and then we're going to put in the
type and then we'll go ahead and just
put in brackets what we want for an
array
and we'll do 1 comma 2 comma 3 comma
four comma five real simple array
and then let's go ahead and just print
that out and see what that looks like
and we get an array of type integer one
two three four five
and then let's flip over and just
remember what the i is
lowercase is signed integer and
uppercase is assigned this is a
lowercase we have a signed integer this
um it's actually a short integer when
you do the i and then the h is the
unsigned short integer and to see what
that means when we're assigning this
let's go up here and change one of our
values to minus one and we have it set
to i and we run it and it comes out okay
no errors but what happens when we
change this to h which is the unsigned
short
integer we run this we're going to get
an error why because we gave it a minus
value and if you remember correctly from
the h
h is an unsigned short integer so there
should be no negative values in there
and we'll go ahead and go back and just
switch this to i and run it
and then there's so many things we can
do with this but let's start by looking
at what's going on in the computer array
buffer underscore info there we go and
we do an array buffer info we're just
going to print this out and we run this
this is going to show us the size of
what's going on with our buffer in here
this is our actual operating system
address and then the size is here it's
got a size of five so you can actually
go in there and you can hard locate this
on your computer usually we very rarely
use something like that but it's kind of
interesting that we can look that up so
easily and when we're manipulating the
array we can simply do print here's our
array we'll put our brackets in here and
if we print two let me go ahead and run
this and you look at this we got minus
one two three and it printed three and
the reason it does that is we always
count from zero so in programming
language you always start zero one two
and the two is going to be the section
where it says three on there and if we
can print just one object in there this
next one is so basic
the for statement for i an array this is
a simple iteration so what this means is
we're going to take each value in the
array we're going to do something with
it and in this case we're going to go
ahead and just print it out so if we
want to print out all the variables you
can go for i and array print i
i want you to notice the difference here
is instead of it printing out that this
is an array with the values in it it
comes down and just prints each
individual value in here now this does
all of them but let's say you are
looking at this you say hey i don't want
to do all of them we're going to do for
we'll do pointer instead of i for
pointer in range
five
and instead we're going to print
and here's our array r
and we're going to look up the index
pointer so this is going to print out
let's just see what this looks like here
we go it printed out the same thing so
we have our minus one two three four
five
so it starts at zero one two three four
five on here oops zero one two three
four on here that's how this is actually
red on here so if we actually print out
the pointer let's do that let's just
print out the pointer on here so you can
see what's going on
pointer comma
r pointer and let's run that and you can
see that the pointer 0 1 2 3 4 so it
does not include the 5 and it prints at
each value we can do something like this
we can go four and you can see it just
drops the bottom one off and we can even
do something like this range one to four
and it drops the top one off so by
changing your iteration loop you can
change the pointer and pull up any of
these values in your array
and another really cool thing we can do
we have our array we can actually do
array
reverse so instead of iterating and
creating a new array we know a
functionality in our array just lets us
reverse all the different values and
then if we go ahead and print the array
let me go and run that you'll see that
the array is now in reverse five four
three two minus one and let's just do a
quick rehash of what we covered so we
went over here and we're gonna go on
more there's three sections to this or
two another section or two we imported
our array so make sure you always import
it we set our value so we created array
equals array we have a type and then we
have the values in that type and if you
print it out you can see that it's an
array type i minus one two three four
and five we can look up the buffer info
so we can actually pull out the actual
memory location and then what kind of
resources it's using that's what the
five represents and then we came in here
we printed just one value out of it and
remember that it goes starts with zero
so we have zero one two which prints our
three position there our number three we
learn how to iterate through the whole
array for i and arr or i in our array
and we just printed the i out and then
we did for pointer in range one to four
we started off with range five and you
can see here where it goes one two three
and it printed out the values that
correspond with that pointer and finally
we went ahead and reversed the array so
we have our r dot reverse print r
and then the next step with our array is
we want to go ahead and add something
onto it and we do that simply with an
append so here's our append we're going
to append the value 10 and let's go
ahead and print array and now we have
five four three two minus one ten so
we've added that right on to the end of
the array and we can also if we're going
to pin something we can also remove
something so the simple command is
remove and we're gonna remove two and
then let's go ahead and print that print
r
run and you'll see here the value two is
now missing from the array so it goes
through and it finds number two in here
and this leads into an interesting
question what happens if we have two
values of the same or two twos there we
go we're going to put in two tubes so
let's go ahead and i'm just going to
copy this down here and recreate our
array and i'm going to add a second 2 in
here 2 comma 2. and let's see what
happens when we remove the two from
there it removes one of the two and the
way it works is it removes only the
first two in the list so we do the
remove value on there you'd have to
rerun this a number of times to get all
the different twos out
now earlier we did print
here's our r and we can do position
let's do position three we'll just run
that
and position three happens to point to
four
what if we wanted to do something in
reverse like print
r dot index
and i'm going to put the 4 in there and
let's see what happens
it prints 3 which was our pointer so
index does the reverse and if you
remember correctly when we did let me go
ahead and do let's just take this whole
array and recreate it again
and i'm going to change the index from
the 3 to the 2
3 is actually going to point to one of
the twos because we have to see 0 1 2.
so we're going to do
index of 2 let's run that
we have 0 1 2 and i did my argument of 2
which is going to come up as 2. but when
i did my index the index is only 1 y
because 0 1 it's going to look at the
first 2 in the array so when you do your
index remember if there's multiple twos
in that array it's only going to look at
the first one and then we'll go in here
in front we have our array imported and
let's go ahead and create a new array
this one we're just going to make as an
empty array it's going to be the i will
stick with that
and it has no values in it so that's
what this means and if we print it out
just print our array we say we just have
an array with no there's no values in
there nothing coming through and so we
want to go ahead and do on this array is
we're going to create an input and we'll
set a variable x equal to it has to be
an integer so it's going to restrict it
it's going to be an input and then from
our input we'll give it what's the enter
size of array there we go enter on this
and then let's do print what did we do
let's do it this way enter d
element x this is kind of a fun thing we
can set up on here this has to do with
print format on here so let's take a
look at this real quick and see what's
going on before we do our print let me
just take the print out there and let's
run this and of course it helps if i
match my brackets correctly there we go
so we're going to enter the size of
array so this is what this is going to
generate the first one generates our
input box and let's just put a four in
there just to see what that looks like
and we're going to run that and so at
this point we're not getting anything
coming out make sure i get all my
brackets in the right place there and
try it again so we're going to enter the
array 4 i hit the enter key and it's
going to print out enter 4 elements so
this is a marker in your print
statements for formatting and it just
lets us know we're going to take the x
value we're going to put it in there and
then from here we're going to do 4i and
range in this case x
and this should look familiar from
earlier so we're going to do if it's in
range of x and i enter the number 4 in
it's going to go 0 1 2 3. it always
starts at 0 on the range and we're going
to do n equals integer input
there we go and if you look at this this
is just another input statement just
like we had integer input inner size of
array now i have integer input again
we're not going to do we can actually do
like have a print something out but
we're just going to leave that blank
i'll show you what that looks like in a
second and we're going to append that
new value to our array and then let's
print it out let's print out our array
so let's go ahead and take a look and
see what this looks like when i run it
let's create an array of four since that
seems to be fun and it says enter four
elements so element one two three four i
hit enter and we print out our array we
see that i have an array of one two
three four so i can use a user input
just like this a real simple setup but
allows me to enter the data into the
array we look into what functions in
python are so first let's look at the
definition of a function a function is a
set of code that performs some task so
what this essentially means is that you
can have a number of instructions which
are bundled together in a function that
is given a particular name and now using
this name you can call this function to
execute these instructions from anywhere
in the program any number of times so
this is the syntax of a function you
have the keyword div following which you
have the function name and then the
double colons and then in the next line
you can put your statements or your
instructions so that is basically what a
function is we'll go through a number of
demos to understand the concepts of
functions so i'll move on to pycharm
let's start from the very basic that is
how to create a function now this is
called the definition of a function and
as we are creating the definition of the
function the keyword that we begin with
is def that is the short form of
definition and now following def we have
the function name so here i'm going to
have a function called welcome and
always you end your function name with
parenthesis now these parentheses may be
empty or maybe filled which we look into
later for now it's empty and then we
have the double colon so i want this
function to just print out good morning
so that is my instruction
and with that my function welcome is
complete now this function has no
purpose unless it's called and for that
we write the call statement for a
function welcome so for calling the
function just put in the function name
followed by parenthesis now let's run
the code and as you see here our call
was made to the welcome function and the
instruction within it was executed thus
we have good morning printed out here so
as i said previously these parentheses
here these could be filled or left empty
we saw what happens when it's left empty
now let me create another function where
i'm taking in values so sometimes the
operation that a function does requires
some values to be passed to it so this
is where we have parameters or arguments
coming so now i'm going to write a
function called add which will basically
add two numbers now these two numbers
need to be passed to this function so
the function does not know what these
two numbers are until you literally give
it the numbers so these numbers will be
stored in variables say a and b
colon and within this i'll have a
variable say total which will hold the
sum of a and b and then we'll just print
out the sum
and with that our add function is also
defined now we'll make a call to our add
function add and now as you see here we
are accepting two values in this add
function that means we also need to pass
two values to this add function now
suppose i want to add the numbers 10 and
20 i can go ahead and just put the
numbers 10 and 20 here or i can have two
variables say x which is equal to 2 and
y which is equal to 3 and then to add i
can just pass x and y either of these
methods work fine now i'll run the
program so as you see here the add
function is called twice this is our
first call to the add function where we
pass 10 and 20. so a holds 10 and b
holds 20 so the total of this is 30
which is printed out the sum is 30. now
after this we have another call to our
add function where we are passing x and
y x holding 2 and y holding 3 so over
here when we pass x we're essentially
passing 2 and when we pass y we are
passing 3 now this 2 and 3 get stored in
a and b respectively and our total is
again printed 2 plus 3 which is 5. now
this is one of the main advantages of
using function if i had to write this
code total equal to a b twice to add two
numbers that would be a little lengthier
procedure than having a function and
just making a single line call to the
function every time i want to add two
numbers now as you notice the values
that we are passing to a function are
very position dependent that is since
i'm passing 10 first 10 goes into my
first variable a and 20 which i'm
passing second goes into my second
variable b now just to make sure that
this is how it works let me print out
the value of a and b separately
so now let me run my program and as you
see here since 10 was passed first it's
stored in a
and 20 which is per second is stored in
b
same here 2 which was passed first
stored in a and 3 store in b now what if
i don't know whether the function
accepts a first or b first now in this
particular case it does not matter
because 10 plus 20 or 20 plus 10 still
gives 30 but we still want to ensure
that 10 does go into a and 20 does go
into b so let's say our function accepts
b and then a now we won't tend to go
into a but we don't know that a is the
second or the first argument that's
accepted in the function so this is
where we have keyword arguments so with
keyword argument what happens is that
since you want 10 to go into a you can
specify here a equal to 10 and you want
20 to go into b so specify b equal to
20. now let's run this program so as you
see here although the function accepts b
first and then a and we passed a first
and then b still the values that are
held are correct because we said a
should be 10. so 10 went into a and we
specify that b should be 20 so 20 went
into b so here we are making our values
that we are passing independent of the
position of the arguments so far we pass
exactly the number of variables or
values that the function is expecting
now what if although this function add
is expecting two values we only pass one
i'll just remove this part here and i
only pass 10 i run the program and
there's an error now we don't want this
error to happen so even if we are
passing an unknown number of variables
that is we don't know how many variables
the function takes we are just passing
values i want that something happens it
does not result in an error so in this
case what i can do is i can give all the
values that i'm accepting a default
value make this back to a comma b so if
the value a is not passed its default
value should be 0. if value b is not
passed the default value should be 0
again so this how i set my default
values now let me run the program so now
as you see although we only pass 10 it
does not result in an error because the
first value went into our first argument
a holds 10 and since b has a default
value it's 0 and the sum is 10. now what
if the one who's writing the program
does not know how many inputs the user
could give or the user could give
variable number of inputs to the
function now suppose i want this
function add to be able to find the sum
of two numbers of five numbers or even
10 numbers in that case the argument
that the add function would accept could
be a list and as you know a list can
hold any number of values so now in my
call i can just pass n number of numbers
and i'll just delete this line because
now we don't have a b we have one list a
and we want to find the sum of all the
elements in this list a so for this i
can use a for loop to iterate through
the list so for i in a and total equal
to total plus i and total needs to have
an initial value so total equal to zero
and let me run this program now so the
sum is hundred and ten so what happens
here is we are passing four numbers now
even if i want to pass just one number
that would also be completely acceptable
by this function all these numbers are
put into a list and a list can have
variable number of values now we are
using a for loop to iterate through this
list and we keep adding each number to
our variable total and finally we print
out total so if you are unaware of how
many values a function can accept or you
want to provide the function the
capability of being able to access
variable number of values you can go for
a list we now move back to a previous
version of our program where we are
accepting a b just adding a b and
displaying it and we are passing our
values to the add function through our
variables x and y now we will make
certain modifications here so x holds 10
y holds 20 we are passing x and y to our
function add now in at what if i change
the value of a and b so i say a equal to
2 and b equal to 3 and then i'll also
put a print statement here to print out
the sum of x and y
let me run this program now so the first
line of our output that is the sum is 5
comes from our function add and add has
changed the value of a to 2 b to 3 but
now when we are printing the sum outside
our function at it seems like our
variables are still holding 10 and 20
and not 2 and 3 that means that the
change in the value was reflected on our
variables a and b within the function
but then that did not affect our
variables x and y so although we are
passing the value of x and y to a
function at and a is holding the value
of x initially and b is holding the
value of y initially are a and x
essentially different that is does a
hold a different memory space and x hold
a different memory space so let's find
this out let's print out the addresses
so here after we created x and y let's
print out the address of x and y
then within our function before we
actually change the values of a and b
let's print out the addresses of a and b
and after we change the values let's
again print out the address
i'm running the program so when you look
at the ids here our first line of output
which is the id for x and y comes from
here our second ids come from this line
here and a third line of ids comes from
here so our first line prints out the id
of x and y which is exactly the same as
our id for a and b within the function
but then again after our values of a and
b are changed the id differs so the id
here printed out in this line is
different from the id printed out in
this line so what this means is that x
and y is actually passed to a and b a
and b and x and y are holding the same
memory location but the minute you
change the value of a and b the location
also changes so this kind of a passing
from the call to the definition is
called call by reference
so call by reference is when you're
actually passing the object and not just
a pointer to the object so you're not
passing the value of x and y you're
passing x and y to a b which is why the
id here that is the id of x and y is
exactly the same as the id of a and b
but once you change the value within the
function this is not reflected back in x
what python does it creates two new
objects a and b and the values are then
put into these now we know that integer
strings and most other things in python
are immutable so this might be why we
have new objects being created every
time we are trying to change the values
so what if we pass something that is
mutable and try to make a change to this
as we know lists are mutable so now
let's pass a list to our function and
try to change the value in the list
within our function and see if this is
reflected back on the original list so
i'll just delete all of this although we
won't be using the function to add
anything right now let's leave the name
of the function at add now i'm passing
lst list to my function at and then i
say lst of 2 equal to 0 and outside my
function i'll first create my lst so
that is 0 1 2 are my three values then
i'll call add and i'll pass lst to it
since we have no print statement there's
no output so i'll have a print statement
here lst and i'll also have a print
statement before the call so again print
lst run the program so as you see here
the first time we created our list the
values we gave for it are 0 1 2. so this
is what's printed in this line here then
we made a call to our add function and
in the add function we change the value
of the element in the second index
position or the third element of the
list we change that to 0 and when we
printed the value of lst even outside
our function this change was reflected
in our original list so it printed 0 1 0
and not 0 1 2. so with this we come to a
conclusion that with integers we were
creating new objects every time we
wanted to change the value because
integers are immutable but with list
since they are mutable the changes are
reflected back in the original object so
we are back to our basic program of the
add function accepting two values a and
b finding their total and printing it
out now what if we don't want total to
be printed within the add function so
the add functions like sure i'll do the
operations but i do not want to give the
output right here so in this case what
we want so the add function should be
able to somehow send the value of total
back to this line of call and then we
can print out the value of total so
first of all add will not print the
value of total anymore add will instead
return the value of total to its call so
for this we use the keyword return
followed by the value that it's going to
return which is total in our case and
the line where we are making the call
this is the same line where the value
will be returned so now we need a
variable here which will hold the
returned value so let me say sum which
is our variable so result is a variable
which will hold the return value of our
function at and then
over here we can print out
result let's run this code and that
worked perfectly fine so i'll explain
this flow once again execution starts
from this line here the result equal to
add 10 comma 20 first add of 10 comma 20
is called so the add functions called a
holds 10 b holds 20 and the total is
calculated then this function returns
this value total to the calling line so
this is a call line and we have a
variable here result which will hold the
returned value then we use this variable
we just print out the value today we'll
cover what objects and classes in python
are so previously we saw that python is
an object-oriented programming language
so what this means is that python is
completely focused around the presence
of an object and this is why we will
stress more today on what this object
actually means and what classes are in
relation to objects so let's begin first
we look at what an object is so in the
real world everything tangible is an
object the table the chair your mobile
phone your laptop even you are an object
and in the similar manner in python
since you are focusing so much on an
object and programming a round object so
every instance in python is an object
now if that is what an object is what is
a class a class is a blueprint of
similar objects so you'll have multiple
objects in programming often and all
these objects have some similar features
so a class basically holds all these
objects together and gives them a common
definition now let's better understand
this through an example so here we are
considering person as a class now if
person's a class every person has
certain features that is name gender age
irrespective of who the person is the
person has to have these features so
this is something common shared by all
the people now a person also has a
behavior and behavior basically means
the functions a person is entitled to
perform so obviously there are a number
of things that a person can do but in
this particular case we look at just two
of them which is talk and vote
definitely there are some exceptions
which we'll not dwell into right now so
now that we saw what features and what
behavior are and how person which is a
class describes these things let's look
at what an object would look like under
this class person so here we have two
objects of the class person our first
object which is on your left hand side
has the features named gender age and
the behavior talk and vote now every
object has to have these features
because these are what's defined under
the class person and in a similar manner
the object that's defined to your right
also have the same features and the same
behaviors now what is it that makes
these two objects two separate entities
then it's the value of the features so
our features name gender age in either
case has a different value for example
our first object has the name sam our
second object has the name mia gender is
male and for a second object gender is
female age is also a different value for
both objects now they could have the
same value that is there could be some
common features but if all of them have
the same value that wouldn't make sense
they wouldn't make them two separate
objects so to summarize this person is a
class and the class defines the features
name gender and age it defines behaviors
talk and vote and then we defined two
separate objects and gave value to the
features in these objects now let's
begin to code this example so i'll move
on to pycharm first thing first let's
create a class so our class is created
using the keyword class and then put
down the name of your class which in our
case is person followed by colon and
enter so your class is created now once
that your class is created the next
thing we need to focus on are the
features that this class defines so the
person class defines the features name
age and gender now in our previous video
on oops we saw that the features or the
members of a class are defined using a
constructor usually so let's create a
constructor which is def
init
and once you click on init the self
parameter automatically appears self
basically refers to the object that
you're passing to this constructor or
the object that is being created when
the constructor is called now we'll give
value to our three features so our
features are name and that will have the
value say sam
gender
male
and age
22. now one thing that we're missing out
here is that we need to remember that
name gender age all these are features
of the class that means these features
are strictly tied to an object that
would be the object that's created when
this init function is called for that
particular time so the reference to that
object would be stored in self
therefore we won't just write name equal
to sam but instead self dot name equal
to sam
and in a similar manner self.gender
and self.age so we have defined our
features of the class person and also
given it value now next thing is we have
to define the behaviors so behaviors are
implemented through functions or we can
say methods so methods are basically
functions but the functions which are
called through an object or tied to an
object are called methods
so let's define our methods
our first behavior is the talk behavior
so if the talk method is called we just
want to print out
hi
i am and the value of the name attribute
of the object that's calling torque
now our next behavior to be implemented
is the vote behavior
so for that we'll create a method vote
and here we'll put in a condition so if
the age of the person is less than 18
the person's not eligible to vote so
we'll print this out and if the person
is above 18 then we'll print out that
the person is eligible to vote so if
self dot age
is
less than equal to 18
i am
not
eligible
to vote
actually less than 18 if the person is
18 they are eligible to vote
and let's print
i am
eligible
to vote
so the two behaviors of the class person
are implemented through methods now now
all that's left for us to do is to
create the actual object so how do you
create the object
if my object name is obj i'll write obj
equal to
and then put in the type
of the object and the type of object is
of course the class now here's something
that you need to understand everything
that you create in python is actually an
object
so i'll explain this a little more in my
console so if i have a variable say a
and i give this variable the value 100
we know that 100 is an integer type
value therefore that makes a an integer
type variable but then if i check the
type of this variable
it shows class int that means the type
of a is the integer class which makes a
an object in the similar manner if i
have another value to a
say simply learn
and now if i check the type of a
we'll see that a is now an object of
class string str is basically the short
form of string therefore everything in
python is an object of some class and
that is how our object here obj is an
object of the type person where person
is our class
so now that we have created an object
during this creation of the object our
constructor will be called and the
features of this object will be given
some value now we can use this object to
call its behaviors so this can be done
either in this manner so you put in
person which is the type of our object
dot
the method and within the bracket as a
parameter you can pass the object in the
similar manner we'll also call our
behavior vote
and again pass obj within it now let's
run this code just pull up my console
here
run the program and as you can see here
so we created an object and the object
got its values as mentioned in the
constructor that is in it and then we
called the talk behavior or the talk
method using our object obj and this
printed our first line which is hi i'm
sam and then we call the vote behavior
and in the word behavior the age of our
object was checked since our object's
age was greater than 18 it says i'm
eligible to vote now these two lines
where we are calling our methods can be
done in a different way
instead of calling it with the type of
our object and then passing our object
we can directly call it with our object
so we can have it in this way obj dot
talk off
and over here
obj dot
vote off
so we must remember that in this
particular case where we are creating
classes and objects and have this kind
of a structure all these methods are
actually tied to the object which is why
we cannot just say talk of we need an
object to call it or at least pass an
object to this method
let's run the code now so it's the exact
same result works just fine now in this
case we just created one object and the
values for this object were
predetermined and just put in our
constructor now what if we want to
create two separate objects and the
values for these objects vary so in this
case so to demonstrate this we'll create
two objects just like in our example
previously we'll have our first object
which is obj1 now both these objects
will be of course of the type person
which is our class
so put that there now every time the
object is created automatically our init
method is called so if our object needs
to have separate values what we can do
is instead of putting in predetermined
values here we can pass the values for
the features of the object in the
brackets so if i want my name to be sam
i pass sam
my gender and the age so these are the
three values for the three features that
this object has which will pass into the
constructor or the init method now in
the init method we need to be able to
accept these values so other than self
will have one variable which will store
the value of the name when it's passed
from here we'll store it in variable n n
for name and the gender will store it in
variable g age will store in variable a
so what happens here is basically these
values that you pass within the
parentheses when you're creating your
object are sent to your init method now
in the init method we are putting down
these three variables to accept the
values so these three variables store
these three values so sam goes to n
male goes to g and 22 goes into a
now instead of putting in the strings
here self.name can be equal to n so the
value which n got is now put into
cell.name
and the value which g received is put
into cell.gender and the value which a
received will be put into self.h
so that way we created our object and
provided a way in which we can actually
have unique values for each object so
now if we have another object say obj2
which is also of the type person we can
put in different values into these
parentheses
so say our second object's name is
jessie
she's female
and
16 years old so now these values will go
into these variables and will be
assigned to these features
so for obj1 if i say
obj1.name the name would be sam if i say
dot name it would result in jessie we'll
see that now let me just print that out
obj1 dot name
and obj2 dot name so as you see although
our feature is the same we are printing
the feature name in both the cases the
object to which this feature is tied is
different so the first time it's
printing name related to object one and
the second time it's printing the name
related to object two now this is not
what we want to show here here what we
want to do is after creating our two
objects we'll call the methods using
these objects
so obj1 dot talk off and obj1 dot vote
off now we'll call the same two methods
using obj2 so obj2 dot talk off
and obj2 dot vote off
run the program and here's our output so
what happened here is obj1 was created
and the three features which are name
gender and age were given the respective
values for obj1 and the similar manner
obj2 also received the values for its
various features now we used obj1 to
call our two methods talk and vote at
talk all we did is print our name of the
object so the first time when we called
with obj1 it printed hi i'm sam because
sam was the name related to our first
object and then we call the vote method
using obj1 itself so our first object's
age was 22 which means it's eligible to
vote and that is what's printed here i
am eligible to vote then we call the
same two methods using obj2 and got
different results so obj two's name was
printed here which is jessie and then
jesse is under age that is she is 16 so
it printed out i am not eligible to vote
when obg2.vote was called so that is the
basic crux of what objects and classes
are in this we're going to cover a basic
understanding of object oriented
programming and we'll be specifically
working in the python interface or the
python code oops the most con the basic
concept is not the accident you just had
or the mistake you just knocked your
coffee cup over off your desk but it's
actually stands for object oriented
programming and whether you're working
in python which we'll be doing today or
in any scripting language almost all of
them rely on object-oriented programming
as their basis programming paradigm that
focuses on objects so everything is an
object in the coding every instance in
python is an object and again this is
true for any of the main programming
languages you know if you're working in
java or scala or any of these you're
going to be looking at object oriented
programming it just makes a lot of sense
and really is the one of the
cornerstones of today's programming and
when we talk about object in programming
an object has two different things it
has a tribute it has two different
things attributes which is data
describing the object and behavior
methods on the attributes
so the first one is your actual data and
the second is what are you doing to that
data and if you're a car lover we're
going to use cars as an example this is
kind of easy to see how that might fit
in to the different objects and so we're
going to start with a bmw for example
that's an object and with the bmw you
might have like the year of the
manufacturer maximum speed those would
be attributes of that car and then you
have the behavior these are methods on
the attributes for example you might
display the speed or change the speed so
even though you have a maximum speed you
might have current speed also which
changes depending on what you want it to
do step on the accelerator go faster
step on the brakes go slower and the
primary terminology in programming is
usually class and it's definitely true
in python so class is a collection of
similar objects and in this example we
have car as our class so you might have
trucks bicycles and airplanes but in
cars we have some very specific things
cars have four wheels that are on the
ground maybe a spare hanging down
headlights steering wheel things you
would expect in a car doors to get in so
it's all inside but in here we actually
have a number in the collection we have
our bmw our ford our audi you can guess
the guys in the back like the bmw the
best i don't blame them and so we work
with classes or collection of items
today i'm going to use the user
interface pycharm it's one of the very
popular python editor i myself have
never used it so this is a new
experience for me it's pleasantly fun to
use and easy to set up you can go to
jetbrains.com that's the people behind
it so
www.jetbrains.com slash pycharm slash
and once you're on the pie charm if you
go under downloads you'll have two
options let me just hit the download now
button it'll take you to the two options
one is the professional which you would
pay for which allows integration between
teams and company setup and has a bunch
of extra cool tools you need for a
business and then there's a community
version which is the lighter weight one
for the purposes of this demo and most
the work you do the community one's
probably just fine you can download it
it's open source and it's free i don't
know about you but i like open source
and free and a lot of my stuff and i've
already opened up a project file but you
can create a new project file up here
put a note down in the youtube and they
can send you some of this code or go
visit simply learn they'll send you the
code itself if you need it there's a lot
of different like i said functionality
in here we're both mostly going to be
underneath just run the demo in this
case i'm doing oops simply learn so
we'll just be running what i'm working
in here let's go ahead and start with
creating a class in python and you
simply just tell it it's a class so the
class means this is going to be our
python template whatever we are working
on i'll call this car and this is
interesting because class itself let me
just highlight that so when i put up
class here that is a python object and
then i'm using that to build car my
class is specifically on here and let me
go ahead and just change that font i
have it pretty large already in my
editor let's go back down here to editor
font and i put it up all the way to 26 i
think we can get it by with 30 so you
can really see it hopefully that's going
to be big enough on there and so once we
have our class we wanted to do something
and so in a class when you put the words
def that stands for definition whatever
that's called that is a function it's
going to actually do something on there
and you'll see what i like about this is
nice with pycharm it automatically
automatically puts self in there why
because self refers to whatever the
object is now it doesn't refer to the
template class car it refers to the
instance of that and i'll show you in a
minute what that exactly means but in
this case we're going to do something
simple we're just going to have it print
and you see it automatically indents it
so python if you remember or if you're
new to python is based on indentations
you have to indent so everything under
this indent is part of the def
everything under class that's indented
is part of the class and so we're just
going to look down at our speedometer
and we're going to print 155 miles per
hour maybe it's on the audubon in europe
i don't know race track not very often
you go 155 miles and now we're in a car
at least not in my experience
maybe in the future we have auto cars
that do hundreds of miles per hour and
shoot down the freeways and let's go
ahead and create an instance of the
class and we'll simply do bmw equals car
and we'll put brackets on there and
let's also do let's do a ford ford
equals car so if you remember
car is like a template it's still an
object so i have bmw equals car and i
have ford equals car these are two
separate instances so they're copying or
they're actually putting a pointer to
car so everything under car is part of
bmw and the same thing with ford and we
can do something like this we can go car
dot
get
speed let's put in the bmw there or we
could also do
car dot get
speed forward given the choice i think
i'd go with the bmw and there's another
way you can do this we can also do bmw
dot
get
because remember it points back to the
original template so all the
functionalities in the original template
and then we could also do forward dot
get
speed
these are a little bit more calming more
than you'll see the top part but let's
go ahead and run this and if we go under
run we find out that alt shift f10 you
can use the hotkeys which i'll probably
start doing and i just simply hit make
sure i highlight the one i'm working on
and it runs it down here and so you can
see right here we have 155 miles per
hour printed out by the bmw 155 miles
out printed by the ford uh car get speed
and then i did it in a different format
bmw dot get speed and four dot get speed
the thing to notice is the term
self that is a python term which means
that when we create an instance whatever
comes in here is what's being processed
and so if i call the class or the
template directly in this case i did car
get speed i have to include what that
self is in this case it's a bmw or if
i'm calling it from the instance bmw
because it includes the car class it
knows that git speed and it knows
automatically that this is self that's
where the term self comes in so that's
important to note in there in python
it's a one of the more pythonic kind of
solutions is that when you see the term
self that refers to that instance that
you created in this case the bmw
instance and the forward instance when
you're setting up a class there's a lot
of things you can do in here there is a
key term init what this means is that
when i create the new instance whatever
happens in here is going to be set this
sets up your information let me show you
how that works and we're going to do is
we're going to pass year and speed in
here and this is really important is i
need to take self that's going to be the
new instance i created i mean the k in
this example will be our bmw and our
forward and put a period here and then
year
equals year that's the variable that was
passed and we'll do the same thing with
speed self.speed equals speed so when we
create this we now have two different
variables in here and if you remember
from our slide an object has attributes
data describing the object and a
behavior methods on the object and so in
our class or our template we're going to
net it initialize it and hit it we're
going to initialize it with the year and
the speed on here but if we initialize
it here when we create the instance we
have to send that information so that
knows what the year is and what the
speed is for the bmw and the forward and
that means we create this instance let's
go ahead and do
maybe this is the maximum speed that
shows up on the speedometer i don't know
but 2018 and we'll put it at 155 miles
per hour and then we'll take the ford a
little bit older runs a little slower
it's a 2016.
and this will be the maximum speed we'll
do 140 miles per hour that's the fastest
it can go and then so now we we've set
up some data on our object
right here coming through and so bmw now
has
a year and a speed and so does ford and
when we get speed let's go ahead and
change this and in fact i'm going to do
let's just get rid of this middle part
because i tend to do the standard
bmw.getspeed
and we'll call this maximum speed
maximum
speed is and then we'll just put down
self speed so that's our variable so
it's whatever the instance is so self
speed is going to refer to our bmw or
our ford and if we go ahead and run this
and that was go up here to run and alt
shift f10 i'm just going to do alt
shift f10 it's already set to the tab
i'm on hit enter and we come down here
and you can see had an error there this
is a double underline for the init
the code that they sent me had just a
single and i forgot to double check that
uh so we have a double underline init it
comes in gear and speed the bmw has 2018
with the maximum speed of 155 and when
we print that out bmw get speed you'll
see it right here the maximum speed is
155 and then it does it for the fort
maximum speed is 140 and then we're done
processing it so we've stored some data
in here we started the year we stored
the speed and then we've had a process
on that data and that is to go ahead and
just print it out print out the
self.speed and let's go ahead and
briefly look at encapsulation def
set speed self speed so we're going to
send it a new speed value to set the
speed and from here we'll go ahead and
do self dot speed equals speed and we'll
just work with the bmw on this one let's
take the forward out of there for a
moment and we have our forward get speed
and then we're going to set the speed
and the new speed is going to be oh
let's make it 143
just an odd number so it's easy to see
and then we'll go ahead and do bmw dot
get
speed and when we go ahead and run this
i'll do the alt shift
f10
and run it as you can see here it comes
out and says
155 because that's what the speed was
when we first entered it and then we
went ahead and changed it bmw dot set
speed and is now 143. so you can see
here how we can alter the information in
our template and if we remember we had
the ford the ford is completely separate
from this so if we still have ford down
here equals car
2016 140. if we still had that down here
this 143 isn't going to affect the
forward at all because this ford
instance is separate from the bmw so if
i do forward dot get
speed and we do an alt shift f10 to run
it there we go here's our forward 140 so
it hasn't changed even though we did we
set the speed on the bmw to 143. the
first thing we want to look at is
inheritance and so inheritance is a
mechanism for a new class to use the
features of another class and if you've
ever done like word processing you might
use a template from that template you
can have all kinds of stuff you put into
the template and you can save it in
different instances depending on what
you're doing and then those particular
instances you've saved could be used as
a template for your next thing i use
that all the time when i was in cells i
would or i do some cells on the side as
part of my job working with them to
support them and build the software for
them we'd build put together a document
and then we take that document and then
become the template for the next three
documents that are very similar this is
the same way you have a class and from
that class we can inherit everything
from there and then make changes on it
and then we're going to go ahead and
cover let's do this
ford bmw just close that up take this
out of here for now okay let's go ahead
and do uh inheritance that's where we're
going to take the class car and we're
going to bring all these features from
class car into a new template or a new
class and let's start with a
class sedan and the sedan is going to
inherit from car so it's going to bring
the car in and now we have a sedan
coming down once we create the sedan
this is now a child class to car coming
down and under this class i'll just go
ahead and we'll just type in
a def
accelerate
course self and on here we're just gonna
have it print
and oh let's have it do
let's say i would do 150 that seems like
very high let's go 133 just because
i don't know why i like the 133 let's
change it to 137. there we go and then
let's do another one here
we'll do this
a class
suv and it also is going to inherit from
car and this too is a child class of car
so we'll just put a label there so we
can remember that and we'll also give it
an accelerate
and when we do an accelerate keep the
self and we'll print let's see uh this
year whatever production is 180 i don't
know why that seems awfully high for an
suv versus a sedan
let's do um uh 1
27. the svp goes a little bit slower
than the sedan there we go so let's go
and hit enter on there and let's take a
look at what we got going here i have my
bmw i have my ford and let's add a honda
and we're going to make it equal to the
sedan and just for fun let's add one
more thing def
open
trunk
self a little bit print
trunk has been opened there we go let's
take a look and see we got going here
i've created my honda if you remember up
above we have our bmw and i'll just do
just the bmw get
speed and then i want to do the honda
get speed and when we run this we can
see our bmw is 155 and our maximum speed
on our honda is 150 because that's what
we set now remember this inherited it
from cars so this init is now part of
the sedan the open trunk if we do this
if i go the other way around let's say
oh let's do this let's do the honda open
trunk
and then we'll do just to throw an error
here
this is going to give us an error it
doesn't even auto type it for me so
we'll do alt shift f10 and run it and
you can see down here is that we had our
bmw get speed okay there's our 155
we had our honda get speed we had our
honda open the trunk and because our car
when we go up here to car does not have
open trunk the bmw does not have that
definition so it gives us an error so we
can't do that unless we add that to the
top as part of a car it just turns out
though that let me just take the bmw out
for whatever reason this bmw doesn't
have a trunk i think they all have
trunks but that's okay for this example
we'll just leave it like that so you can
see right here we've inherited and then
we've gone ahead and added new features
to our new class so this child class of
sedan has come in here now has both
accelerate open trunk the suv which
we're going to look at in just a second
also has
open trunk so we've got a lot of
functionality when we have our original
car template so when whatever's set up
up here comes down here and then we've
added both accelerate let me just do
that right here or honda can accelerate
the honda
and if we run that you can see the honda
has their acceleration come in and
prints out in this case 137 down here
that's why i like to mark it with a
weird number like 137 so you can tell
the difference where we're going so we
have our accelerate so we've added
features into our sedan encapsulation is
a important feature preventing data from
direct access this is what we call
encapsulation we'll discuss that more
later on but what it means in this
particular case is that when you create
a class from another class you can't
alter the original template the
child class can make all its own changes
to that class and do all kinds of things
but it can't make any direct changes to
the parent let's go ahead and take a
look at encapsulation in the code itself
so we can have a better idea of what
we're talking about so we have our class
car and we have our definitions here's
our init this is from if you remember
from the last slide we had our net maybe
we had a couple more functions to it or
modules to it and we have get speed and
set speed all of this under class car is
encapsulated what that means is that if
i create an instance of it in this case
i'm going to create a bmw wouldn't that
be nice i can just whip out a bmw make a
bmw when we create our instance bmw it
does not change the class car this
whatever we do to this instance does not
make changes to our class and the same
thing with the ford the bmw doesn't get
speed it might do something here in the
definitions under the class but the
initial class if i create another car
let's say we take our bmw we set the
speed for 155 like we did here and we
create a ford whatever i do with the 4
does not change the class car and if i
create like we did before with our
inheritance a subclass that's not going
to change the class car that's what they
call encapsulate it bundles things
together and it really is central to
oops object oriented programming is
we're basically bundling things together
and then we keep them in a nice safe
bundle anything we do from that we
either point to it and say hey let's use
this definition or we make a copy of it
so we kind of do a combination of there
and say okay here's our new inheritance
but you can see right here this is
encapsulation and again that's like
central to oops this is how oops was
originally discovered created and
founded is when they realized hey why
don't we just bundle things together
instead of rewriting the code over and
over and over and then polymorphism we
talked about encapsulation in classes
just recently like i said we'll go in
this and we open up the code
polymorphism is we take the feature in
the code and then we can alter that
feature so we can use the same function
in multiple ways that's a lot of fun a
lot of power in that let's go ahead and
take our polymorphism and take a look at
it what's going on in the actual code
when writing our python code so here we
have our parent class car and we switch
colors here we have a sedan where we
inherited the car and an suv also an
inheritance and when we look at this we
have up here our init let me just put so
we have our definition we're
initializing it the first class we've
added in accelerate so what that means
is with our acceleration that's not part
of the initial car class right now until
we add it in so we have our definition
accelerate which print 150 miles per
hour so all sedans have a print of 150
we need to accelerate all other cars
don't have anything going on in them
right now and then with suv
we're going to define the accelerate
differently so we have the accelerate
down here with self print 180. so we
have two different polymorphs going on
here we have accelera one polymorph
going on in this example we've added
accelerate to both of these classes and
so it doesn't matter which one i
accelerate it's going to do something
and so if we create in this case we're
going to create an object down here an
instance of it do this in pink here's
our instances oop that's a little light
let's do something a little darker than
that one there we go so we have our
instances and we're going to create one
object which is a sedan a camry and one
object which is an suv scorpio and then
we can just go through the objects we
can actually just loop through the
objects one object at a time and if we
do print object name and end we have our
object name so it's going to print the
name in this case i'll print camry and
i'll print scorpio and then we have
object accelerate and for the sedan
since that's our camry it's going to
print the 150 and for the suv's going to
print 180 for the scorpio and so by
doing this we polymorph the same
definition to do two different things
depending on what our child class is so
we can polymorph all kinds of things and
we'll actually look at a couple more
objects in there when you go through the
full code later on there's a couple more
examples in this but this is a
polymorphism coming down and you can see
how we're able to leverage the same name
for the definition to do different
things depending on what our object is
today we look into threading in python
so before we jump into what threading is
let's have a look at what a process is
because that is a core concept that you
need to understand before you understand
threads so a process is an executable
instance of a computer program that
means anything that is running on your
computer is actually a process so a word
pad that's opened a mail that you're
sending anything that's running that's
working could be a process now that we
know what a process is let's look at
what a thread is now a thread exists
within the process so the definition of
a thread is that it's a sequence of
instructions in a program that can be
executed independently of the remaining
program so if we write a large program
of course there are many small tasks
that the program performs now each of
these small tasks can be a thread as
long as their execution is independent
of the execution of the other tasks but
then why do we need threads so consider
your system now these days we all use
multi-core processors that is we have
multiple cores in our system now the
point of threading is to make the
maximum utilization of these cores so if
one program would run on a single thread
that means it would utilize just that
one cpu or that one core but if we can
divide a program into multiple threads
and have each of these threads use a
different cpu a program would execute
much faster and it would be way more
efficient so this is why we use trit so
now let's look at threading in python
through some demos so first let's look
at the most basic and the simplest way
of creating a thread i have a function
here show and this function will just
print
this is a child thread as we are going
to have the child thread execute this
function so first thing we need to
create our thread now before we create
the thread let's import the threading
package
so we have included everything from the
threading package now we'll use the
thread of method to create a thread
which will be called t
and to this method thread off we'll pass
the target of our thread that is
basically the task that our thread will
be performing which in this particular
case is the show of function so you say
target so we set target's value equal to
show our function show and now outside
here we'll just print this is the parent
thread
so i'll just explain in general how a
thread works now the minute you write a
program and you start running it there's
a thread created now this default thread
that is created is called the parent
thread so the execution of your program
is performed on the parent thread unless
you explicitly create a separate thread
so if we had not created this thread
here our entire program would be run on
the main thread like every other program
is but now that we created a thread here
this thread that is t will run only this
show of function because that is the
target of this particular thread and
everything else in the program will be
run on the parent thread which is why we
have this print statement here saying
this is the parent thread because this
print statement is not within the show
of function and hence it will be run by
the parent thread now so far we have
only created the thread though so we
need to start this thread and to start a
thread use the thread name followed by
dot and you call the start of method so
the start of method belongs to the
thread class and as you have probably
noticed already a thread here t is an
object of the thread class so once you
say t dot start the target function of
this particular thread is run which in
our case is show now i'll run this
program pull this up here and as you can
see first we have our child thread
executed and then we have the parent
thread executed now let's look at the
second way that you can create a thread
which is by importing the thread class
so you still need your threading package
and i'll create a class
my thread which is a user defined class
so i'll be defining this class and this
class will now be a sub child of the
thread class now the thread class
already exists it's a predefined class
and we're extending this thread class
into our class my thread class what this
does is all the properties of the thread
class is now present within our my
thread class now within the my thread
class i'll be creating a function def
run within which i'll just print this is
a child class say five times using the
for loop
and outside here i'll create my thread
so now that our class my thread has
extended the thread class we can create
an object for my thread and that by
itself would be a thread so t is my
object of my thread which would also be
the thread now if you notice here i'm
not passing any target so this is
because when you don't pass any target
by default your thread will call the run
function so it will come here and it
will execute this function so the thread
class has a blueprint of the run
function and every thread that is
created as an object of the thread class
is designed to call this run function by
default so what we do here in our my
thread class is we redefine this run
function for our purpose
now of course you need to start your
thread and outside here which is the
path that will be executed by my main
thread i'll just print out this is the
main thread
and let's run this code so we'll just
add the new lines so here there's child
class main thread main thread main
thread so on and then we're back to
child class so if you're wondering why
this kind of a mix-up is happening i'll
explain that to you now our entire
program was initially planned to be run
on the main thread but we created a
child thread here which is steep and
made the child thread take care of the
execution of this def run of this
function run now while our thread our
child threat team was executing this for
loop and between that gap of sprinting
this out and moving to the next
iteration our main thread was completely
idle so the main thread took up this
time to start printing out this for loop
and that is why you have this mix up of
child class and the main thread
printouts and now we'll have a look at
the third way you can create a thread
this time we'll not be extending the
thread class so i'll have a class say
demo within which i'll have a function
show and within this function i'll print
out this is the child thread five times
using the for loop
now outside here i'll create an object
of my class demo
and now i'll create a thread which is
basically an object of the thread class
and to this i'll pass the target just
like we did previously but this time
because a function exists within a class
we'll refer to the function with an
object so we have a reference now and
once that's done back to starting our
thread and outside here i'll print out
this is the parent thread five times
using the for loop
let me run this code now so you can see
the output here we have this is a child
thread printed five times and then five
times of the parent thread now python
can be quite deceiving so now that we
looked at what thread is and how
threading works in python exactly we can
move on to multi-threading so
multi-threading is a model where you
have multiple threads within a process
and all these threats can execute
independent of one another but they are
also sharing all the resources of the
process so by the resources of the
process we could mean the various data
the process holds the files or the
stacks and so on now all the threads
that are taken care of the execution of
this process will share these resources
but they will be independent of each
other's execution too so let's look at
multi-threading through an example here
we'll write a program where we want to
print out in the first line a number say
1 followed by the double of the number
and then the square of the number now we
want these three statements to be
printed for every number from 1 to 5. so
what we'll be first doing is we'll have
a class and within this class we'll have
three functions where each function is
responsible for one of the following
which is printing the number printing
the double of the number and printing
the square of the number so let's begin
writing our code since we'll be using
threads here the first thing we do is
we'll import our thread package
name my class demo and within this i'll
start defining my functions so my first
function is def num and this function
will just be printing out the number
so we want all the numbers from 1 up
till 5
so that's all our first function is now
our second function which is for
printing out the double of the number
2 into i and finally our third function
where we'll be printing out the square
of the number
so now we have the three functions now
here's our challenge we want one
iteration of every function to happen
one by one so what i mean is for i in
range one to six in a function def num
we want the number is 1 to be printed
and then immediately after that we need
to move on to the first iteration of a
function square now for this kind of an
execution of course we need three
different child threads and each thread
will take the responsibility for
execution of one of these functions so
we'll create our threads down here but
before that first of all we need to
create an object of our class demo
and now we'll create our threads my
second thread and while we are creating
our threads we also need to specify the
target so t1 is responsible for
execution of the num function t2 will
take care of the execution of the double
and t3 for square
so we have created a thread now we need
to run these threads or we need to start
these threads so for that we have t one
dot start off t2 dot start off and t3
dot start off now we need to end these
threads or we need to make sure that the
program does not terminate until these
threads have completed their work so for
that we use the join function
and out here which will be run by the
main thread we'll just print out this is
the main thread
and that's all it is that's our program
so everything in this program was
initially meant to be run by the main
thread but since we created our child
threads the main thread is responsible
for running only this much of the
program now t1 t2 t3 will take care of
the execution of these functions
respectively now let's run this program
well we are not getting what we expected
all these iterations are being completed
in blocks so the first function is
completing itself first followed by the
second function but now in between the
second function the third function also
started printing and this is a complete
mix up so how do we fix this now the
first thing we need to see is as we saw
in context switching we cannot
completely predict the order in which
these print statements would be carried
out or the order in which the threads
would be executing so what's happening
here is while double was printing this
while the thread that is t2 which is
doing the execution of double function
was printing this there was some time
where t2 went into an idle mode and
during this time t3 started printing so
how can we fix this so first of all to
prevent this kind of an output where a
print statement is printing something
out but then it stops for a while and
another thread takes on the execution
and the previous thread was not able to
print it correctly so to prevent this
what we can do is we can have a sleep
function on each of these threads so for
that first i'll import the time package
now what the sleep function does is it
basically puts that particular thread
into sleep or in idle mode for the
amount of time that we specify in
seconds so if i say time dot sleep of
one it holds this particular thread
which is t1 at sleep for one second and
during this time we expect e2 to begin
its execution now once t2 has finished
one iteration let's put t2 also into
sleep for one second and we hope that
during this one second of hold for t2
t3's first execution will take place so
we put here time dot sleep of one after
the execution of t3 now t3 is put into
hold and again we can start off with t1
second execution or t1 second iteration
followed by t2 then t3 and so on so this
two has not fixed our problem there's
still a mix up of statements now if you
see the statement here you'll notice
that this mainly occurred because your
second thread started before the
completion of the previous thread so in
that case our problems not with the
child threads but in fact in the main
thread so what if i put a sleep for the
main thread after every thread has
started its execution
and even after t2 put a sleep now since
i'm putting a sleep of 0.2 seconds
during this time we can ensure that the
previous thread has completed at least
printing out one complete statement and
the printout is not halted or is not
interrupted by the second threads
process now let's run our program once
again see if it worked this time and
yeah it did so once we put sleep on our
main thread we kind of had a control
over how our threads are starting we saw
that the output that we wanted is
exactly what we got so this is how
threads work and how you can control
threads using time dot sleep function
and that is pretty much all the basics
about threading python scripting so what
is scripting scripting is writing
programs to automate a task and python
by itself is a scripting language so
what this means is that the lines that
you write the code lines they are
interpreted rather than compiled so they
are executed at run time so in this
tutorial we look at a few libraries
which demonstrate the scripting feature
of python very clearly other than that
we'll also look at a few libraries which
demonstrate its runtime behavior so
let's begin i'll be coding on pycharm
today and the first library that we look
into is the os library which stands for
operating system so to use the os
library
first we need to import it so say import
os
now in here i'll have two functions i'll
just demonstrate two of the most common
functions that you can utilize from the
os library first one is to extract the
current working directory create a
function and i'll have a variable cwd
which stands for current working
directory now this variable will store
the return value from a function which
retrieves the current working library so
you say os dot get cwd and that is it
one line and you have your present
directory stored in our variable cwd so
i'll print this out and that's our first
function so out here i'll call the
function so now we can run our program
so this is our current directory you can
see the users within the user my
particular user name and pycharm
projects slash demo is this particular
project under pycharm okay so that is
our first function let's have a look at
the second one now i'll demonstrate how
you can retrieve the path of a
particular file so create another
function here and to this function i'll
pass a file name now in here have
another variable i say path which holds
the value of the path that this file is
stored in and to retrieve that you say
os dot path dot apps path which stands
for absolute path now you know there are
two types of paths there's the absolute
and the relative path name the absolute
path name is it gives the path name
right from your c drive or d drive
whichever drive it belongs to so the
relative path name is the path
respective to our current working
directory now i'll have a variable file
name out here which will hold the name
of my file whose path i need to find out
so i see sample.txt and then i'll pass
this file name to my function file path
and that's it now let's run our code
okay so we have not printed the value
out let's do that
print path run your code again the first
function that we call is to retrieve our
current working directory and the second
function is to retrieve the path of this
file sample.txt and this is the right
part this is exactly where i've stored
my file so all is good so those are the
two most common functions that you use
with the library or the module os there
are quite a lot more which you can
definitely check out so next we look
into the time module so as usual first
import the module now before i show you
a few functions in the time module you
need to understand what epoch is so
first january of the year 1970 is the
starting point of a certain timeline and
ebook time is basically the number of
seconds that's passed since first
january of 1970. so to get your epub
time use the function time
dot time off and i'll store the value of
this function returns the epic time and
i'll store it in a variable ppc print
that out
so that's the number of seconds that has
passed as of right now since first
january 1970. now obviously this has no
meaning to us so what we do is we'll
convert this to a format that means
something to us and for that purpose we
use the function local time so i create
a variable local time and use the
function local time to which you pass
the epc variable now print out local
time so as you see here now we actually
have numbers that make sense to us we
are in the year 2019 the third month
which is march date is 18 12 hours 42
minutes 47 seconds so this is something
we can actually decipher now again this
is a structure it's not in a traditional
formatted way so if you want to extract
certain information from this structure
you can easily do it saying local time
that you use the variable
and then just use these keys in here to
extract that particular value for
example i want to extract the year so i
say tm underscore year
print that and you see here the year
alone is extracted now if i want the
entire thing to be displayed in a more
formatted way that's exactly what we
have the function c time for that you
say print and use a function c time
again to this you need to pass the epoch
value that's epc run our program so now
you see we have it in a more formatted
way monday march 18th so we even got the
day of the week in here so those are the
basic things you can do with the time
module let's move on to our next module
so the next module we'll look at is the
smtp module now just like http smtp is
also a protocol this is a protocol for
sending emails so it stands for simple
mail transfer protocol so first we
import smtp smtp lit now in this demo
what we'll be doing is of course we'll
be sending out an email so we'll send an
email to someone's email id through
python now obviously python itself
cannot send an email out what you have
to do is you'll be accessing a domain so
you'll give the username and password
for this domain and you'll put in
commands here such that it automates a
process of sending a mail from that
particular domain to another email id so
first we need to set a domain and a port
and for that we use a function smtp
lib.smtp
and the first so this takes two
arguments the first argument is our
domain name now the domain name is
basically like if you're using gmail
it'll be
smtp.gmail.com if you're using hotmail
it would be
smtp.hotmail.com and so on so i'll be
using gmail.gmail.com
and the second argument is the port
number which is generally 587 now 587 is
the standard port number according to
the standard encryption standard which
is tls now that you have set the domain
and the port number the next thing you
need to do is make these servers
communicate with one another that is
basically the sender server telling the
receiver server hi i'm present here and
the receiver server gives an appropriate
response now in here we'll be using smtp
dot e h l o instead of h e double l o
that is basically just an extended
version of hello it adds a few
additional features to your smtp now
before that we need a variable into
which we'll store the object returned by
this function so i'll have smtp obj so
that smtp is the object through which
will be referencing our domain and port
number so now you say smtp obj dot ehlo
now the next thing we do is we'll put
our smtp in the tls mode so for that we
use the function start tls so as i
mentioned before guys this port number
is the standard port number for tls so
now it must be clear why we are using
this particular port number it's because
we are using the tls connection so you
say start
okay so now a connection setup account
through which will be sending out the
email so you say sntp obj dot login and
now you pass two parameters in here the
first is of course the email id and that
is followed by your password so to
create our file first we need to import
the os package
and in particular we need to import path
library from the os package now create
function under this function i'll be
passing the path at which i'll create my
new file so now before you create the
file you actually need to check if the
file is already present so you say if
not path dot is file test so you're
passing the destination here to this
function dot is file and if your files
already present then this portion of the
code will be skipped because our entire
program is for building because the
entire purpose of our program is to
build a file which we do not need to do
if it already exists now in here
you say open dest comma w so guys this
function actually returns true only if
this file is present and this particular
part is actually a file so suppose this
destination whatever password this is
present but it's a folder not a file
we'll still enter this particular block
and so in here what you do is you open
this folder in write mode and say f dot
write welcome to python so let's assume
destination was a folder and not a file
you enter this block here a file is
created which is opened in the right
mode and within that file you enter the
content welcome to python scripting now
you're ready to close the file now
outside here i'll assign the path to
destination so this is the path guys i
want to create this file sample.txt
under this path so basically along with
the path name where you're creating your
file you also pass the file name and
then you call this function create file
passing test and once your file is
created you can just print out file
created right okay now let's
now we need to run our code well we
don't need a input from the user so we
say print so we print file created now
let's run our code according to the
statement here there's no error our
program executed completely and created
a file so now let's check if this
actually worked so i go to my desktop
this is the folder where sample should
have been created and yes it is we'll
open the file and as you can see the
content two matches so we were
successfully able to automate the
creation of a file so the first argument
is the email id
so you have the email id within quotes
put it within single quotes and then
your second is the password for this
particular id and that's my password so
with these credentials your smtp will
basically log in to your account and
then use the services of this account to
send to send an email now the next
function that will be used now the next
function that we'll be using is the one
that basically sends your email out so
that's called send mail and in here you
will put in your to and from email ids
okay next is the id that we are sending
the email to next is the from id i'll be
sending an email to the id enj2 simply
learn again gmail.com now the third
argument to this function is the message
that we'll be actually sending so i'll
be sending a very short message here the
first thing you enter is the subject and
the subject would be smtp check and then
to move on to the next line which is
basically the body of your message put
in slash n this is a test email and
that's it that's the body of my message
with the subject preceding it and the
and the last thing we need to do is we
will quit the snt connection so once
your mail sent out will close the
connection
this terminates the program let's now
run this code so programs run now to
check if this actually worked we need to
go
open our account at anj2 simply learn
and check if this particular message is
present in our inbox so guys this is the
mailbox that i send the email from and
this is the one that i send the email to
as you can see here and j2 simply learn
and here is the message which has been
sent so we checked out three libraries
in python the os library the smtp and
the time library next we'll check out a
few programs which determine things at
run time so now i'm going to write a
function punch1 and this function will
receive a few arguments i'll fill in the
space later on now all this function
does is it prints out the various
arguments that it receives so suppose
the arguments are stored in i and what
you pass here is also i so you pass a
number to this function and this
function prints out that number so out
here we'll be calling the function and
passing a value to it say 10. now what
if i want to pass varying number of
arguments so say 10 20 30 for this
particular run and maybe the next one i
want to pass four arguments i want to
pass 42 so how do we make this function
flexible enough that it accepts any
number of arguments and prints these out
that is where we have args args come in
so when you put this within the brackets
what happens is that your function will
take any number of arguments that you
pass to it and store it in the variable
args so now to print out each value
that's passed to this function you take
a for loop and you iterate that over
arcs and then one by one you can print
each of these values out so let's run
this program now and as you see 10 20 30
40 each of them have been printed out in
a separate line and the beauty with this
function is you can change the number of
values that you print in fact you can
even given different types of argument
so i have all integers here followed by
a string and it all works so that is
where you use the variable arcs now
similarly we have another variable which
is used in this argument space which is
called quarks so that's k w a r g s and
you always proceed this with two stars
two asterisks so so far we looked at how
a function can accept variable number of
arguments now we look into how the
function can do this while accepting the
arguments as values to labels so what i
mean here is instead of just passing 10
20 30 what if i want to pass a equal to
10 b equal to 20 c equal to 30 and again
the number of such pairs could vary so
in that case we have arcs for the
varying part and quarks for the label
part so what you do here in the similar
manner you will have a for loop which
will iterate through works and we want
to extract every item in it so we say
items and print out i run this code and
as you can see here so you get all the
pairs printed out so we saw how python
allows a function to determine the
number of arguments it receives at
runtime instead of it being fixed
beforehand itself now let's move on to
another program which demonstrates
automation and that is creation of a
file so this is one of the most common
and the most basic things that you come
across when you're learning scripting
not just in python but any language so
so far we saw how a function work we
have a function name and within it we
have some code to perform a certain
function now functions in python can
also be nested and that is what we look
at now so i'll first create a function
func one and in here i'll have a
variable say x which is equal to 10 and
within this function i'll create another
function so that will be the nested
function function and to function i'll
pass x and within funct2 i'll just
increment x by 1 and return this value
so here's the thing now within function
1 we need to have a call to function 2
so you say func 2 and you pass x to it
and out here we'll call function1 so
result equal to funct1 print out the
value of result so what happens here is
you're calling the function func one
control goes in here x is assigned the
value 10 and over here there's a
definition for functo but right now it's
kept it moves on to this return line now
in the return line you're basically
returning func 2. so what that does is
it will call function2 along with the
argument x and function 2 returns x plus
1. so where will this value be returned
of course it will be returned to the
statement from where the call is made so
that is still within function 1 and that
means function 1 will return the value
that function 2 is returning so what we
have in result would be 10 plus 1 which
is 11 let's now run this code so as you
see here 10 plus 1 11 is what's passed
that is how nested functions work now
why are nested functions important they
are important to understand the concept
of how functions can also be passed as
an object in python and why we would do
so so i'll delete this entire code
create a function func one once again
and in here i'll print this is first
function so that's func one now within
function one i'll have my second
function the nested function and within
the nested function i'll print out this
is the nested function and out here i'll
have a third function which i'll call
the outer function which will print out
this is the outer function now what i
can do here is instead of directly
making a call to outer function so
sometimes what happens is you do not
want to make a direct call to a
particular function you want to make a
direct call to say function a and
through function a you want to call a
function b or c so for that what you do
is you make a call to func one and as an
argument to func one you passed another
function name as an object so i pass out
a funk so as you see here guys outer
funk is essentially a function but i'm
passing this function as an object to
func one so func funk1 will receive this
function i'll store that in a variable
called func maybe called func will also
be passed to our nested function and
within the nested function we'll make a
call to this past function and of course
finally the return statement where we'll
be calling our nested function let's now
run this code our outer function was not
call and that's because we did not put
these parentheses here which does not
really make it a call statement let's
run this code now and as you see all our
three functions were called but through
a call statement for just one so we just
called our outer function func one
passed the other outer function as an
argument to this and that took care of
executing all the three functions that
we have this kind of a situation does
not come handy very often but in certain
applications where you need to decide
which function needs to be executed at
runtime then having the capability of
passing a function name as an object
comes really helps so we saw how you can
create functions at runtime now python
also allows you to create classes at
runtime so let's check that out now the
term for creating class at run time is
called factory so what you do here is
you have to basically create the
skeleton or just write down the basic
description for all your possible
classes so you'll mention the class that
it inherits from and the attributes
associated with these classes but you do
not create it you just give that sort of
definition and then later you'll have
certain expressions to evaluate which
class is to be created depending on
certain situations so let's begin
creating the definition for our classes
so my first class would be a base class
of course so you say type base class and
this will inherit from the mother of all
classes which is the objects class and
following this you'll have list of all
the attributes associated with this
class so i have no attributes associated
with my base class now the second class
i create c1 will inherit from my base
class which is b and with this class c1
we'll have an attribute named val
associated to it to which we'll assign
the value 5. now my third class c2 will
be about the same thing as c1 just that
this time my attribute val will have a
different value 10 just so we can
differentiate between the two and of
course our class name would be c2 now
we'll have a function say def class
creator and to this i'll pass a variable
say bool now if the variable is true you
say return c1 and that will essentially
create your class c1 else return c2
which will create class c2 now outside
here i'll call the class creator
function and i'll call it with both the
values true and false so we can see the
difference now of course this just
creates a class so to extract an
attribute value which is how we'll be
able to differentiate between the
creation of the both classes say dot
attribute name which is val in our case
and in a similar manner we'll call class
creator again but this time with false
extract the value so let's run the code
now so as you can see here guys first
time we pass true to class creator and
if it is true it's creating class c1
which is this and that has the value 5
associated with attribute val similarly
when we pass false it creates c2 just
the value 10 associated with the
attribute valve so that's how python
allows you to create classes even during
runtime so now that we looked into that
we are back to our nested functions or
program in which we call functions as
objects now suppose i want to call this
outer function alone now the question is
is this the only way of calling the
outer function within the func one what
i mean is func one is basically your
wrapper function right now and every
function that's called through func one
comes inside this so i want to call all
the functions in the same manner in the
same serial as before but is there an
easy way to do this well yes there is
this is where decorators come handy so
just on top of outer funk if i say at
funk1 that way this allows me to call
outer object through func one but just
with this one statement in this format
so i just say out of funk but now that i
have added decorator of funk one
although i'm calling out a funk it'll be
called through funk one just as before
let's run this quote and as you see here
your funk one has been called first and
outer funk has just been passed as an
argument to funk one so that is what
decorators basically do they allow you
to change the operation or the
functionality of a function thanks guys
now we have a picture to teach you about
five important libraries used in python
python is the most widely used
programming language today when it comes
to solving data science tasks and
challenges python never ceases to
surprise its audience most data
scientists out there are already
leveraging the power of python every day
hi i'm a peksha from simply learn and
well after some thought and a bit more
research i was finally able to narrow
down my choice of top python libraries
for data science what are they let's
find out so let's talk about this
amazing library tensorflow which is also
one of my favorites so tensorflow is a
library for high performance numerical
computations with around 35 000 github
comments and a vibrant community of
around 1500 contributors and it's used
across various scientific domains it's
basically a framework where we can
define and run computations which
involves tensors and tensors we can say
are partially defined computational
objects again where they will eventually
produce a value that was about
tensorflow let's talk about the features
of tensorflow so tensorflow is majorly
used in deep learning models and neural
networks where we have other libraries
like torch and thiano also but
tensorflow has hands down better
computational graphical visualizations
when compared to them also tensorflow
reduces the error largely by 50 to 60
percent in neural machine translations
it's highly parallel in a way where it
can train multiple neural networks and
multiple gpus for highly efficient and
scalable models this parallel computing
feature of tensorflow is also called
pipelining also tensorflow has the
advantage of seamless performance as
it's backed by google it has quicker
updates frequent new releases with the
latest of features now let's look at
some applications tensorflow is
extensively used in speech and image
recognition text based
time series analysis and forecasting and
various other applications involving
video detection so favorite thing about
tensorflow that it's already popular
among the machine learning community and
most are open to trying it and some of
us are already using it now let's look
at an example of a tensorflow model in
this example we will not dive deep into
the explanation of the model as it is
beyond the scope of this video so here
we're using amnest dataset which
consists of images of handwritten digits
handwritten digits can be easily
recognized by building a simple
tensorflow model let's see how when we
visualize our data using matplotlib
library the inputs will look something
like this then we create our tensorflow
model to create a basic tensorflow model
we need to initialize the variables and
start a session then after training the
model we can validate the data and then
predict the accuracy this model has
predicted 92 accuracy let's see which is
pretty well for this model so that's all
for tensorflow if you need to understand
this tutorial in detail then you can go
ahead and watch our deep learning
tutorial from simply learn as shown in
the right corner interesting right let's
move on to the next library now let's
talk about a common yet a very powerful
python library called numpy number is a
fundamental package for numerical
computation in python it stands for
numerical python as the name suggests it
has around 18 000 comments on github
with an active community of 700
contributors it's a general purpose
array processing package in a way that
it provides high performance
multi-dimensional objects called arrays
and tools for working with them also
numpy addresses the slowness problem
partly by providing these
multi-dimensional arrays that we talked
about and then functions and operators
that operate efficiently on these arrays
interesting right now let's talk about
features of number it's very easy to
work with large arrays and matrices
using numpy numpy fully supports object
oriented approach for example coming
back to nd array once again it's a class
possessing numerous methods and
attributes nd array provides for larger
and repeated computations numpy offers
vectorization it's more faster and
compact than traditional methods i
always wanted to get rid of loops and
vectorization of numpy clearly helps me
with that now let's talk about the
applications of numpy numpy along with
pandas is extensively used in data
analysis which forms the basis of data
science it helps in creating the
powerful n-dimensional array whenever we
talk about numpy the mention of the
array we cannot do it without the
mention of the powerful n-dimensional
array also number is extensively used in
machine learning when we are creating
machine learning models as in where it
forms the base of other libraries like
sci-fi scikit-learn etc when you start
creating the machine learning models in
data science you will realize that all
the models will have their bases numpy
or pandas also when number is used with
scipy and matplotlib it can be used as a
replacement of matlab now let's look at
a simple example of an array in numpy as
you can see here there are multiple
array manipulation routines like there
are basic examples where you can copy
the values from one array to another we
can give a new shape to an array from
maybe one dimensional we can make it as
a two dimensional array we can return a
copy of the array collapsed into one
dimension now let's look at an example
where this is a jubilee notebook and we
will just create a basic array and uh
for detailed explanation you can watch
our other videos which targets on these
explanations of each libraries so first
of all whenever we are using any library
in python we have to import it so now
this np is the areas which we will be
using let's create a simple array
let's look what is the type of this
array
so this is an end array type of array
also let's look what's the shape of this
array
so this is a shape of the array now here
we saw that we can expand the shape of
the array
so this is where you can change the
shape of the array using all those
functions now let's create an array
using arrange functions if i give
arrange 12 it will give me a 1d array of
12 numbers like this now we can reshape
this array
to 3 comma 4 or we can write it here
itself
so this is how our range function and
the reshape function works for numpy now
let's discuss the next library which is
scipy so this is another free and open
source python library extensively used
in data science for high level
computations so this library as the name
suggests stands for scientific python
and it has around 19 000 comments on
github with an active community of 600
contributors it is extensively used for
scientific and technical computations
also as it extends numpy it provides
many user-friendly and efficient
routines for scientific calculations now
let's discuss about some features of
scipy so scipy has this collection of
algorithms and functions which is built
on the numpy extension of python
secondly it has various high level
commands for data manipulation and
visualization also the ndmh function of
scipy is very useful in
multi-dimensional image processing and
it includes built-in functions for
solving differential equations linear
algebra and many more so that was about
the features of sci-fi now let's discuss
its applications so cyber is used in
multi-dimensional image operations it
has functions to read images from disk
into number arrays to write arrays to
discuss images resize images etc solving
differential equations fourier
transforms then optimization algorithms
linear algebra etc let's look at a
simple example to learn what kind of
functions are there in sci by here i'm
importing the constants package of scipy
library so in this package it has all
the constants
so here i am just mentioning c or edge
or any and this library already knows
what it has to fetch like speed of light
planck's constant etc so this can be
used in further calculations data
analysis is an integral part of data
science data scientists spend most of
the day in data munching and then
cleaning the data also hence mention of
pandas is a must in data science life
cycle yes pandas is the most popular and
widely used python library for data
science along with numpy and matplotlib
the name itself stands for python data
analysis with around 17 000 comments on
github and an active community of 1200
contributors it is heavily used for data
analysis and cleaning as it provides
fast flexible data structures like data
frames series which are designed to work
with structured data very easily and
intuitively now let's talk about some
features of pandas so panas offers this
eloquent syntax and rich functionalities
like there are various methods in pandas
like drop n a fill n a which gives you
the freedom to deal with missing data
also partners provides a powerful apply
function which lets you create your own
function and run it across a series of
data now forget about writing those for
loops while using pandas also this
library's high level abstraction over
low level numpy which is written in pure
c then it also contains these high level
data structures and manipulation tools
which makes it very easy to work with
pandas like their data structures and
series now let's discuss the
applications of pandas so pannas is
extensively used in general data
wrangling and data cleaning then pandas
also finds its usage in edl jobs for
data transformation and data storage as
it has excellent support for loading csv
files into its data frame format then
pandas is used in a variety of academic
and commercial domains including
statistics finance neuroscience
economics web analytics etc then pandas
is also very useful in time series
specific functionality like date range
generation moving window linear
regression date shifting etc now let's
look at a very simple example of how to
create a data frame so data frame is a
very useful data structure in pandas and
it has very powerful functionalities so
here i'm only enlisting important
libraries in data science you can
explore more of our videos to learn
about these libraries in detail so let's
just go ahead and create a data frame
i'm using jupyter notebook again and in
this before using pandas here i'm
importing the pandas library
let me go and run this so in data frame
we can import a file a csv file excel
files there are many functions doing
these things and we can also create our
own data and put it into data frame so
here i am taking random data and putting
in a data frame also i'm creating an
index and then also giving the column
names so pd is the alias we've given
pandas random data of 6x4 index which is
taking a range of six numbers and column
name i'm giving as abcd now let's go
ahead and look at it
so here it has created a data frame with
my column names abcd
my list has six numbers zero to five and
a random data of six by four so
dataframe is just another table with
rows and columns where you can do
various functions over it also i can go
ahead and describe this data frame to
see so it's giving me all these
functionalities where count and mean and
standard deviation etc okay so that was
about pandas now let's talk about next
library and the last one so matplotlib
for me is the most fun library out of
all of them why because it has such
powerful yet beautiful visualizations
we'll see in the coming slides plot and
matplotlib suggests that it's a plotting
library for python it has around 26 000
comments on github and a very vibrant
community of 700 contributors and
because of such graphs and plots that it
produces it's majorly used for data
visualization and also because it
provides an object oriented api which
can be used to embed those plots into
our applications let's talk about the
features of matplotlib the pi plot
module of matplotlib provides
matlab-like interface so matplotlib is
designed to be as usable as matlab with
an advantage of being free and open
source also it supports dozens of
back-ends and output types which means
you can use it regardless of which
operating system you're using or which
output format you wish pandas itself can
be used as wrappers around matplotlibs
api so as to drive matplotlib via
cleaner and more modern apis also when
you start using this library you will
realize that it has a very little memory
consumption and a very good runtime
behavior now let's talk about the
applications of matplotlib it's
important to discover the unknown
relationship between the variables in
your data set so this library helps to
visualize the correlation analysis of
variables also in machine learning we
can visualize 95 percent confidence
interval of the model just to
communicate how well our model fits the
data then mat modeler finds its
application and outlier detection using
scatter plot etc and to visualize the
distribution of data to gain instant
insights now let's make a very simple
plot to get a basic idea i've already
imported the libraries here so this
function matplotlib inline will help you
show the plots in the jupiter notebook
this is also called a magic function i
won't be able to display my plots in the
jupiter notebook if i don't use this
function i'm using this function in
numpy to fix random state for
reproducibility now i'll take my n as 30
and will assign random values to my
variables so this function is generating
30 random numbers here i'm trying to
create a scatter plot so i want to
decide the area
let's
put this so this is multiplying 30 with
random numbers to the power 2 so that we
get the area of the plot which we will
see in just a minute so using the
scatter function and the alias of
matplotlib as plt i've created this if i
don't use this and i have very small
circles as my scatter plot it's colorful
it's nice so that's one very easy plot i
suggest that you explore more of
matplotlib and i'm sure you will enjoy
it let's create a histogram so i'm using
my the style as gg plot and assigning
some values to these variables any
random values
now we are assigning bars and colors and
alignment to the plot and here we get
the graph so we can create different
type of visualizations and plots and
then work upon them using matplotlib and
it's just that simple so that was about
the leading python libraries in the
field of data science but along with
these libraries data scientists are also
leveraging the power of some other
useful libraries for example like
tensorflow keras is another popular
library which is extensively used for
deep learning and neural network modules
keras drafts both tensorflow and theano
backends so it is a good option if you
don't want to dive into details of
tensorflow then scikit learn is a
machine learning library it provides
almost all the machine learning
algorithms that you need and it is
designed to interpolate with numpy and
sciby then we have c bond which is
another library for data visualization
we can say that cborn is an enhancement
of matplotlib as it introduces
additional plot types now richard will
focus on libraries like numpy pandas
matplotlib and scikit learn following
this richard will also focus on helping
you understand web scraping better
welcome to numpy
what's in it for you well today we're
going to do part one of numpy in a
two-part series now we're going to go
over what is numpy installing and
importing numpy numpy array numpy array
versus python list basics of numpy
finding size and shape of any array
range and arrange functions
numpy string functions and then in part
two i'll move on to cover axes array
manipulation and much more
so let's start with what is numpy numpy
is the core library for scientific and
numerical computing in python it
provides high performance
multi-dimensional array object and tools
for working with arrays and i'll go a
step further and say there are so many
other modules in python built on numpy
so the fundamentals of numpy are so
important to latch onto for the python
so you can understand the other modules
and what they're doing number's main
object is a multi-dimensional array it's
a table of elements usually numbers all
of the same type indexed by a tuple of
position integers in numpy dimensions
are called axes
take a one-dimensional array or we have
remember dimensions are also called axes
you can say this is the first axis
zero one two three four five and you can
see down here it has a shape of six why
because there's six different elements
in it in the one dimension array and
they usually denote that as six comma
with an empty node on there and then we
have a two dimensional array where you
can see zero one two three four five six
seven and in here we have two axes or
two dimensions and the shape is two four
so if you were looking at this as a
matrix or in other mathematical
functions you can see there's all kinds
of importance on shape we're not going
to cover shape today but we will cover
that in part two did you know that
numpy's array class is called nd array
for numpy data array
now we're going to take a detour here
because we're working in python and two
of my favorite tools in python is the
jupiter notebook and then i like to use
that sitting on top of anaconda and if
you flip over to jupiter.org that's
j-u-p-y-t-e-r.org
you can go in here you can install it
off of here if you don't want to use the
anaconda notebook but this is the
jupiter setup the documentation on the
jupiter jupiter opens up in your web
browser that's what makes it so nice is
it's portable the files are saved on
your computer they do run in ipython or
iron python and you can create all kinds
of different environments in there which
i'll show you in just a minute i myself
like to use anaconda that's
www.anaconda.com
if you install anaconda it will install
the jupiter notebook with the anaconda
separate and you can install jupyter
notebook and it'll run completely
separate from anaconda's jupiter
notebook and you can see here i've now
opened up my anaconda navigator what i
like about the navigator this is a fresh
install on a new computer which is
always nice i can launch my jupiter
notebook from in here i can bring other
tools so the anaconda does a lot more
and under environments i only have the
one environment and i can open up the
terminal specific to this environment
this one happens to have python37 in it
the most current version as of this
tutorial and then you open a terminal if
you're going to do your pip installs and
stuff like that for different modules
you can also create different
environments in here so maybe you need a
python36 python35 you can see we're
having a nice framework like anaconda
really helps so you don't have to track
that on your own in the jupyter notebook
in your different jupiter notebook
setups we'll go ahead and launch this
jupyter notebook and then i've set my
browser window for a default of chrome
so it's going to open up in chrome and
you can see here this opens up a folder
on my computer we have a couple
different options on here remember i set
the environment up as python 3.7 you
would install any additional modules
that aren't already installed in your
python on this and it keeps them
separate so you do have to for each
environment install the separate modules
so they match the environment on there
and in here we have a couple things we
can look up what's running
you have your different clusters again
this is i just installed this on a new
machine so i just have the one a couple
things in here that were run on here
recently and what we go on here is we
then have on the upper right new and
from the pull down menu you'll see
python3
and this will open up a new window
and now we're in jupiter python so this
is a python window and we'll just do a
print
and this of course is let's go hello
world
and we'll run that and it prints out
hello world in the command line there's
a couple special things you have to know
we're not going to do today which is on
graphics if you've never seen this
one of the things you can do you can
also do a equals hello world and if you
just put the a in there now if you do a
bunch of these where you have a equals
hello world b equals goodbye world and
you put a b a and return b you'll only
run the last one but you can see here if
you put the variable down here it will
show you what's in that variable
and that has to do with the jupiter
notebook inline coding so that's not
basic python that's just jupiter
notebook shorthand which you'll see in a
little bit
so back to our numpy numpy array versus
python list python list being the basic
list in your python why should we use
numpy array when we have python list
well first it's fast the numpy array has
been optimized over years and years by
multiple programmers and it's usually
very quick compared to the basic python
list setup it's convenient so it has a
lot of functionality in there that's not
in the basic python list and it also
uses less memory so it's optimized both
for speed and memory use
and let's go ahead and jump into our
jupiter notebook since we're coding best
way to learn coding is to code just like
the best way to learn how to write is
right and the best way to learn how to
cook is cook so let's do some coding
here today
and just like any modules we have to
import numpy we almost always import it
as np that is such a standard so you'll
see that very commonly we can just run
that and now we have access to our numpy
module inside our python and then the
most common thing of course is to go and
create a number array
and in here we can send it a regular
list
and so we'll go ahead and send this a
regular array uh let's do one two three
to make it simple and then i'm just
going to type in a and we'll run this
as you can see down here the output is
an array of one two three and we could
also do
print just a reminder that this is an
inline command so that wouldn't work if
you're using a different editor you can
see that it's array123 but we'll go and
leave it as a
kind of a nice feature so you can see
what you're doing really quick in the
jupyter notebook
and just like all your other standard
arrays i can go
a of
which is going to be a value of 1. of
course we do a of 1. you go all the way
through this
a of 1 has a value of 2 in it
so whether you're using the numpy array
or the basic python list that's going to
be the same that should all look pretty
familiar and be pretty straightforward
remember the first value is always 0
and when we set on there so let's take a
look why we're using numpy because we
went over the slide a little bit but
let's just take a look and see what that
actually looks like and what we want to
look at is the fact that it's fast
convenient and uses less memory so let's
take a glance at that in code and see
what that actually looks like when we're
writing it in python and what the
differences are
and to do this i'm going to go ahead and
import a couple other modules we're
going to import the time module so we
can time it and we're going to import
the system module so that we can take a
look at how much memory it uses and
we'll go and just run those so those are
imported
so we'll do b equals oh range of one
yeah one thousand is fine
and so that's going to create a list of
one thousand zero to nine hundred ninety
nine remember it starts at zero and it
stops right at the one thousand without
actually going to the one thousand and
let's go ahead and print
and we want system dot get size of
and we'll pick any integer because we
have you know zero to
a thousand we'll just throw one in there
five it doesn't matter it's going to
whatever integer we put in there's going
to generate the same value because we're
looking at the size of how how much
memory it stores an integer in
and then we want to have the length of
the b that's how many integers are in
there
and if we go ahead and execute this and
run this in a line we'll see
oops i did that wrong comma
if we multiply them together
we'll see it generates 28 000 so that's
the size we're looking at is 28 000 i
believe that's bytes that sounds about
right
so let's go ahead and create this in
numpy
and we'll go with c equals np
and this is a range
so that's the numpy command do the same
thing that we were just doing in a list
and we'll also use the same value on
there the 1000
and then once we've created the
c
value of c for np dot a range let's go
ahead and print
and we can do that by doing c dot size
times
c dot
item size
when it's very similar we did before we
did get the size of so the c size is the
size of the array and each item size
just reversed so it's the size of an
integer five item size it's going to be
the integers and c size let's just take
a look and see what that generates
and wow okay we got four thousand versus
twenty eight
a significant difference in memory how
much memory we're using with the array
and then let's go ahead and take a look
at speed let's do um oh let's do size
we tried this with lower values and it
would happen so fast that the npra kept
coming up with zero
because it just rounded it off
so size and let's create an l1
moles
range of size
and we'll do an l2
we'll just set up to the same thing it's
also range
of size on there there we go
and then we can do on a1
equals
np dot
a range size
and then let's do an a
equals np dot
a range we'll keep it the same size
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take these two different arrays
and we're going to perform some basic
functions on them
but let's go ahead and just load these
up now we'll go ahead and run this so
those are all set in memory
except for the typo here
quickly fix that
there we go so these are now all loaded
in here and let's do a start
equals
time dot time
so it's just going to look at my clock
time and see what time it is
and we'll do result equals and let's do
let's say we got
an array and we're going to say
let's do some addition here x
plus y
for x comma
y in
and we'll zip it up here
two different arrays so here's our two
different arrays we're gonna multiply
each of the individual things on here l1
l2
there we go so that should add up each
value so l1 plus l2 each value in each
array
then we want to go ahead and print
and let's say
python list took
and then we'll do
time dot time
we'll just subtract the start out of
there so time whoops i messed up on some
of the quotation marks on there
okay there we go
time
minus the start
and we'll convert that to second so
we'll go because in milliseconds or
times one thousand
and let's hit the run on there it's kind
of fun because you also get a view while
we're doing this
of some ways to manipulate the script
and as you can see also my bed typing
there we go okay so we'll go ahead and
run this
and we can see here that the python list
took 34
actually i have to go back and look at
the conversion on there but you can see
it takes roughly 0.34 of a second and we
go ahead and print the result in here
too
let's do that
we'll run that just so you can see what
the what kind of data we're looking at
and we have the 0 four six eight so it's
just adding them together it looks
pretty straightforward on there and if
we scroll down to the bottom of the
answer again we see python list took 46
a little different time on there
depending on what um
core because i have this is on an eight
core computer so it depends on what core
it's running on what else is pulling on
the computer at the time and let's go
back up here and do our start time
paste that into here
and this time we're gonna do a result
equals and this is really cool notice
how elegant this is so straightforward
this is a lot of reason people started
using numpy is because i can add the two
arrays together by simply going a1 plus
a2
it makes a lot of sense both looking at
it and it's just very
convenient remember that slide we're
looking at fast convenient and less
memory so look how convenient that is
really easy to read real easy to see
and i don't know if we don't need to
print the result again so let's just go
ahead and print
the time on here
and we'll borrow this from the top part
because i really am a lazy typer
and this isn't the python list this is
the numpy list or number
array let's go ahead and see how that
comes out
and we get 2.99
so let's take a look at these two
numbers 46 versus 2.99 so we'll just
round this up to 3. that's a huge
difference that's that's like more than
10 times faster that's like 15 times
roughly at a quick glance i'd have to go
do the math to look at it and it's going
to vary a little bit depending on what's
running in the background the computer
obviously so we've looked at this and if
we go back here we found out it's much
faster
yes there's different going to be
different speeds depending on what
you're doing with the array very
convenient easy to read and it uses less
memory so that's the core of the numpy
that's why a lot of people base so many
other modules on numpy and why it's so
widely used
so we did glance at a couple operations
when we were looking at speed and size
let's dive into a little bit more into
the basic operations
these are always nice to see i mean
certainly you want to go get a cheat
sheet if you're using it for the first
time you know look things up google is
your friend
we did this with the most basic numpy
dot array or np.array
and we'll go ahead and create an array
let's do
pairs
one comma two
and then let's do a three comma four and
if we're gonna do that let's do five
comma six
there we go and if we go ahead and take
this
and run this and go ahead and do our a
down here so it's in line and i'll print
that out
you can see it makes a nice array for us
so we have a and if you look at that we
have three different objects each with
two values in them and hopefully you're
starting to think well how many
dimensions or indexes is that and you'll
see three by two so let's go ahead and
take a look and let's go how about a dot
in dimensions speaking of which
we'll run that and we have two
dimensions for each object and then we
can do the item size so a dot
we saw this earlier we looked up how
many items it was up here where we
wanted to multiply item size times the
actual size of the object so the memory
is being used versus the item size and
we should see
four there
memory is compressed down that's always
a good thing
and then the shape the shape is so
important when you're working with data
science and you're moving it from
one format to another
so we have our shape we just talked
about that we have three by two three
rows by two objects in each one
generally i don't look too much at the
size but the dimensions i'm always
looking up this is nice you can automate
it so you might be converting something
you might need to know how many
dimensions are going into the
next machine learning package so that
you can automatically just have it send
that information over
so we looked at a shape
let's go and create a slightly different
array np dot array let's go ahead and
just do as our original
setup here
and one of the features we can do which
is really important is we can do d type
equals in this case let's do
np
float
64. and so what we've done is converting
all of these into a float and we've type
in a
and now instead of having one two three
four five six you see they're all float
values one dot zero there's no actual
zero in there just there's a one dot or
the one period two three period four
period five period six period
and this again data science i don't know
how many times i've had to convert
something from an integer to a float so
that's going to work correctly in the
model i'm using
so very common features to be aware of
and to be able to get around and use and
we'll also do let's just curiosity
item size
we'll go and run that
and we see that it doubled in size so
it's not a huge increase well doubling
is always a big increase in computers
but it's not a huge increase compared to
what it would be if you're running this
in the python list format
and then we did the shape earlier
without having it set to the float64
let's go ahead and do a shape with it
set to 64. and it should be the same
three comma two so it all matches
so we've gone through and remember if
you really if this is all brand new to
you
according to the cambridge study at the
cambridge university if you're learning
a brand new word in a foreign language
the average person has to repeat it
163 times before it's memorized
so a lot of this you build off of it so
hopefully you don't have to repeat it
163 times but we did manage to repeat it
at least twice here if not a little bit
more and let's go ahead and take this
we're going to look at one more setup on
here
and let me just take this last statement
here on the converting our properties of
our data
and instead of float 64
let's do complex let's just see what
that looks like and let's go ahead and
print that out and run it
and so we now have a complex data set up
and you'll see it's denoted by the one
dot plus zero dot j
and if we flip over here and do a basic
search for numpy data types
better to go to the original web page
but pull up a bunch of these you can see
there's a whole list of different numpy
data types
shorthand complex we have complex
complex 64 complex 128
complex number represented by 264-bit
floats real and imaginary components
one option on there float16 float32
float shorthand for float64 most
commonly used and of course all the
different ones that you can possibly put
into your numpy array so we covered a
basic addition up there we're comparing
how fast it runs it's some very basic
components how to set up a numpy array
how many dimensions it has item size
data type item again we went to item
size and there's also
the
shape probably one of the more used i
used a shape all the time very commonly
used
and then down here you can see where we
actually created a numpy complex data
type
so let's look at some other features in
numpy one of them is you could do numpy
dot
zeros
and we're gonna do three comma four
there we go and we'll go ahead and run
this and you can see if i do np dot
zeros i create a numpy array of zeros
this is really important i was
rebuilding my own neural network and i
needed to create an array where i
initialized the weights
and i want them all to be the same
weight in this case i want them to start
off as zero for the particular project i
was working on and there's other options
like you can do numpy ones
and we'll do the same thing three comma
four we'll run that
and you can see i've created a an array
of numpy ones in this case it comes out
as a float array
and this is an interesting to note
because we have let's go back to our
python and do l range five
and we'll print the l so there's our
list
and if i run that
it doesn't create the range until after
the fact until you actually execute it
that's an upgrade in python python27
actually created the array zero one two
three four this one actually creates the
script and then once it's used it then
actually generates the array
and if we do that in numpy a range
remember that from before
and if we do a numpy a range 5
and let's do l equals
or we can just leave it as numpy that's
fine there we go just run that
you can see there we actually get an
array zero one two three four for the
value the numpy arrange a range five
generates the actual array
and for part one we're going to do just
one more section on basic
setup
and we're going to
concatenation
do a concatenation out example
there we go we're going to do strings
let's take a look at strings what's
going on with there and let's do
oh let's see print
let's do an np
character something new here
and we're going to add
and then here's our brackets for what
we're going to add
oh and let's say
let's do
hello
comma hi
and
in the brackets on there let's create
another one
and this one's going to be
a b c
and we'll do
x y z so we're just creating some
randomly making some up on here and then
we'll go ahead and just print this
if we run that and come down here
and of course make sure all your
brackets are open and closed correctly
and then
you can see in here when we concatenate
the example in numpy
it takes the two different arrays that
we set up in there and it combines the
hello with the abc and the high with xyz
and if we can also do something like
print
oh let's do
np character dot multiply
so there's a lot of different functions
in here again you can look these up it's
probably good to look them all up and
see what they are but it's good to also
just see them in action let's do hello
space comma three
and we'll run this one
and run that without the error you'll
see it does hello hello hello so we
multiplied it by three and we can also
let's just take this whole thing here
instead of retyping it
and we can do character center so
instead of multiply let's do center
and over here
keep our hello going
take the space out of there
and let's do center at 20
and fill character
equals and we'll fill it with dashes
so if we run this
you can see it prints out the hello with
dashes on each side
and we keep going
with that we can also in addition to
doing the fill function we can play with
capitalize we can title we can do
lowercase we can do uppercase we can
split split line strip join these are
all the most common ones and let's go
ahead and just look at those and see
what those look like each one of them
here we're going to do the hello world
all-time favorite of mine i always like
to say hello universe and you can see
here we do capital h with the world but
so we want to capitalize so capitalize
is the first one in the array so we get
hello world on there and we can also
take this
and instead of capitalizing
another feature in here is title
and let's just change this to how are we
doing
how
are you doing instead of
do you
let's run that
and you can see here because we created
as a title it capitalizes the first
letter in each word
and in this one we're going to do
character lower
two different examples here we have an
array we have hello world all
capitalized and we have just hello and
you can see that one is an array and one
is just a string if we run that
you get a an array with hello world
lowercase and hello lowercase
and if we're going to do it that way we
can also do it the opposite way there's
also upper
and let's paste those in there and you
can see here we have
character.upper opposite there
python.data and that will do python is
easy
hopefully you're starting to get the
picture that most of the python and the
scripting is very simple
it's when you put the bigger picture
together and starts building these
puzzles and somebody asks you hey i need
the first letter capitalized unless it's
the title and then we have you start
realizing that this can get really
complicated so numbi just makes it
simple and we like that
and so in this case we did python data
it's all uppercase python is easy like
shouting in your messenger python is
easy
and then if you're ever processing text
and tokenizing it a lot of times the
first thing you do is we just split the
text and we're just going to run this in
p dot character dot split are you coming
to the party if we do that returns an
array of each of the individual words
are you coming to the party splitting it
by the spaces
and then if we're going to split it by
spaces we also need to know how to split
it by lines
and just like we have the basic split
command we also have split lines
hello and you'll see here the scoop in
for our new line and when we run that if
you're following the split part with the
words you should see hello how are you
doing the two different lines are now
split apart
and let's just review three more before
we wrap this up commonly used string
variable manipulations we have strip and
in this case we have
nina admin anita and we're going to
strip a off of there let's see what that
looks like
and then you end up with nin diminish
basically takes up all leading and
trailing letters in this case we're
looking for a
more common would be a space in there
but it might also be punctuation or
anything like that that you need to
remove from your letters and words
and if we're going to strip and clean
data we also need to be able to reformat
it or join it together so you see here
we have a character join we'll go ahead
and run this
and it has on the first one it splits
these letters up by the colon and the
second one by the dash and you can see
how this is really useful if you're
processing in this case a date we have
day month year year month date very
common things to be have to always
switch around and manipulate depending
on what they're going into and what
you're working with and finally let's
look at one last character string
we're going to do replace
if you're doing misinformation this is
good pulling news articles replacing
is and what in this case we're just
doing here's a good dancer and we're
going to replace is with was
and you can see here he was a good
dancer hopefully that's not because he
had a bad fall he just was from like you
know 1920s and has gotten old
so there we go we covered a lot of the
basics in numpy as far as creating an
array very important stuff here when
you're feeding it in how do we know the
shape of it the size of it what happens
when we convert it from a regular
integer into a float value as far as how
much space it takes we saw that that
doubled it item size you have your n
dimensions and probably the most used is
shape and we'll cover more on shape in
part two so make sure you join us on
part two there's a lot of important
things on shaping in there and setting
them up we also saw that you can create
a
zeros based array you can create one
with ones if we do a range you can see
how it is a lot easier to use to create
its own range or a range as it is in
numpy
you saw how easy it was to add two
arrays we saw that earlier just plus
sign then we got into
doing strings and working with strings
and how to concatenate so if you have
two different arrays of strings you can
bring them together we also saw how you
can fill so you can add a nice headline
dash dash dash well we saw about
capitalize the first letter we saw about
turning it into a title so all the first
letters are capitalized doing lowercase
on all the letters upper for all the
letters just lower and upper nice
abbreviation we also covered how to
split the character set how to strip it
so if you want to strip all the a's out
from leading aias and ending a's or
spaces you can do that very easily also
how to join the data sets so here's a
character join option for your strings
and finally we did the character replace
today we're going to do the pandas
tutorial really is a core python module
you need for doing data science and data
processing there's so many other modules
that come off of it there it actually
sits kind of on numpy so if you've
already had our numpy array hopefully
you've already gone through the numpy
tutorial one and two so today we're
going to cover what is pandas we'll
discuss series we'll discuss basic
operations on series then we'll get into
a data frame itself basic operations on
the data frame file related operations
on a data frame visualization and then
some practice examples roll up our
sleeves and get some coding underneath
there and let's start with just some
real general what is pandas pandas is a
tool for data processing which helps in
data analysis it provides functions and
methods to efficiently manipulate large
data sets
now this is a step down from say using
spark or hadoop in big data so we're not
talking about big data here but we are
talking about pandas when there is some
connections there's like an interface
going on with that so there is
availability but you really should know
your pandas because if you're working in
big data you'll know there's data frames
well pandas is a data frame primarily it
has a couple different pieces we'll look
at here and if you've never worked with
data frames before a data frame is
basically like an excel spreadsheet you
have rows and columns you can access
your data either by the row or the
column and you have an index and
different that kind of set up and we'll
dig more into that as we get deeper into
pandas but think of it as a giant excel
spreadsheet that's optimized to run a
larger data on your computer
and then i said it that it's a data
frame so the data structures in pandas
are series one-dimensional arrays and
then we have data frame two dimensional
array and it really centers around the
data frame the series just happens to be
part of that data frame and here's a
closer look at a pandas series series is
a one-dimensional array with labels it
can contain any data type including
integers strings floats python objects
and more so it's very diverse if you
remember from numpy we studied they had
to be all uniform not in pandas and
pandas we can do a lot more and pandas
actually kind of sits on numpy so you
really need to know both of those if you
haven't done the numpy tutorials and you
can see here we have our index one two
three four five and then our data a b c
d and e very straightforward it's just
two columns and we have a nice index
label and a column label for the data
and then a data frame is a
two-dimensional data structure with
labels we can use labels to locate data
and you can see here we had if we go
back one we had our index one two three
four five so in each one of these series
they would share the same index over
there the row index so you have your row
index df dot index and then you have a
column index df.columns and this should
look like i said this would be really
familiar if you've done any work with
spreadsheets excel
so it kind of resembles that this does
make it a lot easier to manipulate data
and add columns delete columns move them
around same thing with the rows so you
have a lot of control over all of this
now we're of course going to do this in
our jupiter notebook you can use any of
your python editors but i highly suggest
if you haven't installed jupyter and
haven't worked with it it is probably
one of the best ways for easily
displaying a project you're working on i
skip between a lot of different user
interfaces or ides for editing my python
and it's just simply jupiter.org
j-u-p-y-t-e-r.org
and then i always let mine sit on
anaconda anaconda.com
and just real quick we'll open that up
for you oops offline mode don't show me
that again
but you can see here that i have
different tools that i can actually
install in my anaconda including the
jupiter notebook which comes by default
and then i have access to the
environments
and again that's
anaconda.com named after the very large
one of the largest world's largest
snakes and then jupiter notebook in this
case jupiter.org and when we're in our
i'm going to go in here to our jupiter
notebook and we're going to go ahead and
just do new and a python 3
and this will open up a python 3
untitled folder
so diving right in let's go ahead and
give this a title pandas tutorial and
we'll go up to cell and we'll change the
cell type to mark down so it doesn't
execute it as actual code
one of those wonderful tools when you
have jupyter notebooks so you can do
demos with this and let's go ahead and
import
pandas
and usually people just call it pd that
has become such a standard in the
industry so we'll go ahead and run that
now we have our pandas has been imported
into our jupyter notebook
and then oh we can go ahead and let me
do the control plus since it's internet
explorer i can enlarge it very easily so
you have a nice pretty view oops too big
there we go and whenever you're working
with a new module it's good to check
your version of the module in pandas you
just use the in this case pd dot
underscore underscore version underscore
underscore that's actually pretty common
in most of our python modules there's
different ways to look up the version
but that's one of the more common ones
and we'll go ahead and run that we get
0.23.4
and if we go to the pandas site we see
0.23.4 as the latest release and of
course a reminder that if you're going
to environment you need to install it so
you'll need to do pip install pandas if
you're using the pip installer we'll go
and close out of that
and the first thing we want to do is
we're going to work with series a lot of
stuff you do in series you can then do
on the whole data set we need to do what
create one we need to manipulate it
take pieces of it so query it query it
delete so you can delete different parts
of it so we want to do all those things
with the series and we'll start with the
series and then almost all the code in
fact all the code does transfer right
into
the actual data table so we go from a
series of a single list of one column
and then we'll take that and we'll
transfer that over to the whole table
and we'll start by creating let's put up
there we go
creating a series from
list
and let's just call this arr equals
and we'll do 0 1 2 3 4. if you remember
from our last one we could easily do
r equals
range of 5 which would be 0 to 4. but
we'll do r equals zero to four and we'll
call this s1 and we'll go pd
and
series is capitalized this one always
throws me is which letters do you
capitalize on these modules they're
getting more and more uniform but you
gotta watch that with python and we're
just going to go ahead and do arr
so we're just going to take this python
list and we're going to turn it into a
series
and then because we're in jupiter we
don't have to put the print statement we
can just put s1 and it'll print out this
series for us
and let's go ahead and run that and take
a look
and you'll see we have two rows of
numbers so the first one is the index
now it automatically creates the index
starting with zero unless you tell it to
do differently so we get 0 index row 0
is 0 1 1 2 2 3 3 4 4. and because it's a
series it doesn't need a title for the
column there's only one column so why
title it
and this also lets you know that it's a
data type of integer 64. so we print
this out this is our series our basic
series we've just created
and let's do a second series
pd and we'll use the same
data list and let's go ahead and do
order we'll give it an order
equals oh let's do it this way
let's go
index
equals order
and it helps if we actually give it an
order so we'll do order
equals and let's do one two three four
five so instead of starting with zero
we're going to give it an order starting
with one we're going to run that and
we'll go ahead and print it out down
here
s2 and we'll see that we now have an
index of 1 2 3 4 5 and that represents 0
1 2 3 4 in the series and we're still
data type integer 64. and very common as
you're missing with numpy arrays is we
can import our numpy as np remember that
from our numpy tutorials we can go ahead
and create a numpy out of random with
the random numbers of five
and let's just see what that end looks
like so we can see what our number looks
like so we have some nice random float
values here 2.33 so on and this from our
last tutorial the numpy tutorial one and
two and instead of calling it order
let's call it index
and we're going to set our index equal
to a b c d and e
i want to show you that the index
doesn't have to be an integer so it can
be something very different here and
then let's go ahead and create our we'll
just use s2 again and here's our np for
numpy
series capital s
and n is our
np for numpy
pd for pandas there we go switching my
anachronisms so we have pd.series of n
and we're going to do our index
equals our index we just created
and then let's go ahead and see what
that looks like s2 is a print it and
let's run that
and we can see here we have a nice
series going on a b c d and e for our
indexes so instead of it being 0 1 2 3
or 4 we can make this index whatever we
want and you can see the numbers here
going down that we randomly generated
from the number array so we use numpy to
create our
panda series right here
and so continuing on with creating our
series this one i use so often we create
a series from a dictionary so we have
our dictionary in this case we went
ahead and did a of 1 b is 2 c a3 d4 ef5
so each one of those is a key and then a
value and then we're going to use oh
let's use s3
equals pd for pandas
series
and then we want to go ahead and just do
d in here
print out s3 here and let's go ahead and
run this and you can see we got a is 1 b
is two c is three d is four e is five
and it's still of integer 64 because the
actual data is one two three four five
and it's all integer 64 type 64. and the
last thing we want to do in the creating
section of our series is to go ahead and
modify the index because we're going to
start modifying all this data so let's
start with modifying the index of the
series and if you remember let's do a
print this time s1
i'll go ahead and run this and the
reason i did print is because it only
prints out the last variable so if i put
s1 up here and we're going to do another
variable back down lower it won't print
the first one just the last one and
we're going to go ahead and take s1
the index and we're just going to set it
equal to a new index and obviously
the number of objects in our index has
to equal the number of objects in our
data and then because it's the last
variable we can go ahead and just do an
s1 and let's run that and you can see
how we went from 0 to 0 0 1 2 3 4 as our
index we've now altered it to a b c d
and e
so this would be much more readable or
might be representational of a larger
database you're working with
so cool tools we've covered creating
database based on
our basic array python array we've
showed you how to reset the index
then we showed you how to use a numpy
array so you can put a numpy array in
there it's all the same you know
pd.series a numpy array and then we can
set the index on there and the same
thing with the dictionary so it's very
versatile how it pulls in data and you
can pull in data from different sources
and different setups and create a new
series very easily in the pandas and
then we left on changing your index so
now we have a new index on here
and then we want to go ahead and do some
selection let's do some basic
slicing most common thing you'll
probably do on here and we'll just do s1
this notation should start to look
really familiar again this is going to
put an output so i'd usually it doesn't
change s1 this just selects it so we
might do a equals s1 and then print a
and you'll see that it just looks at the
first three zero one two and we can do
the same thing by not having the a in
there i'll go ahead and take that out
but just a reminder that it's not
actually changing s1 it's just viewing
s1 so simple slicing on here and we can
likewise do an append so before we do a
pen let's just do a quick kind of fun
one we'll do two minus one and you'll
see it covers everything but the e of
course you can do minus two on this side
so one another way to select it is to go
how far from the end and likewise we can
do a two here
cde to the end so it starts at the
second one and another way we can do
this is we can do a minus two over here
and that looks at just the last two in
the slice so you can see how easy it is
to slice the data and of course
there's no reason to do this but you
could select all of them
if you wanted to view all of them on
there helps 32 there's not 32 so it's
just going to show the first three there
we go and then we can also append so i
can take and oh let's create another
series and append one to it and if you
remember we had s3 there's our s3 and we
have our s1 we'll go ahead and do s1
and let's go ahead and do
oh let's call it s4
equals s1
a pin
s3
so we're just going to combine those two
into s4
and if we go ahead and print s4 on here
you'll now see that we have a b c d e a
b c d e zero one two three four one two
three four five because we started the
data at one
so very easy to append one series to the
next
and if we're going to append one series
to the next we need to go ahead and drop
or delete one and drop is a key word for
that and let's just do e our index e and
so if i run this
you'll see that it'll print it out and
a b c d there's no e
and remember all these changes if i type
in s4 again
you'll see that s4 still has e in it so
this change does not affect the series
unless you tell it to so i'd have to do
like x s4 equals s4 dot drop e and
there's another way to do that which
we'll show you later on let me just cut
this one out there we go
all right so we've covered all kinds of
cool tools here we have appending we
have slicing we did all the creating
stuff earlier as you can see here on the
setup how easy it is to manipulate the
series
so next what we want to get into is we
want to get into
operations that happen on the series let
me go ahead and change this cell to
mark down there we go and run that
so series operations what can we do with
the series
and let's start by creating a couple
arrays we'll call it array one and we'll
do zero through seven and array two six
through six seven eight nine five i
don't know why we threw the five on the
end let's go ahead and run those so
those load up into jupiter
and we'll do this a little backwards
we're going to do s5 equals a panda
series of array two so i'm doing this in
reverse and then when we do s5 you'll
see that we have zero to 4 it
automatically assign the index
for our series
and let's go ahead and do the same and
we'll call this s6 and we'll set this
equal to pd series for
our first array
and if we do an s6 down here to print it
out
we'll see something similar i got zero
through six
zero one two three four five seven for
the data so those are two series we just
created series six five and six
and one of the first things we can do is
we can add one series to the next so i
can do s5 dot add s6
and let's see what that generates and
just a quick thing if you never use
pandas what do you think is going to
happen with the fact that this only has
five different values in it and this one
has seven values
so let's see what that does
and we end up with six eight ten twelve
9 and it goes oh i can't add this
there's nothing there so it gives us a
null return very different than the
numpy that would have given you an error
this instead tells you there's no value
here because we couldn't generate one so
we can easily add s5 dot add s6 and
likewise we can do s5 dot
sub for subtract
s6
and we'll run that and on the add the
subtract and you guessed it we're going
to do multiply and divide next again you
can see there's null values where it
can't subtract the two because there's
no values there to subtract we can also
do s5 multiply mul they're all three
letters on these that's one of the ways
to remember how they figured out the
code for this so remember these are all
three letters mole we'll go ahead and
run this
and you can you can see how they're
multiplied together and then we can also
do the s5 div three letters again
s6
and run that
and you'll see here this goes to
infinity because we have zero in the
wrong position so it actually gives you
a whole different answer here that's
important to notice and then in the null
values because there's no data and it
can't actually produce an answer off of
an old off of missing data and since
we're in data science let's do s6
median so let's look at the median data
which is simply median sorry for those
who are following the three letters
because median is not three letters and
you can see an s6 is 3.0 and let's do a
print here and we'll do median
or average s6
and let's print max
comma s6
and just like median there's max value
and if we're going to have a max value
we should also have a minimum value so
let's pop in minimum
we'll go ahead and run this
and you're starting to see something
that would be generated like say an r
where you're starting to get your
different statistics we have a medium
value of 3 max value of 7 and a minimum
value of 0. and what it does when it
hits these null values if there is no
values in there because we could still
do that we could actually you know what
let's go up here and do
let's pick this one where he multiplied
let's go s7
equals
i'll go and print the s7 just so i keep
it nice and uniform so i still have my
s7 down there and run it and then i want
to take the s7
because s7 now has
null values and an infinity value and
let's see what happens
this is going to be interesting because
i want to see what it does with infinity
and we end up with a median of 6 maximum
of 27 and minimum of zero which is
correct it drops those values so when it
gets to there and it had doesn't know
what to do with them it just drops those
values and then it computes it on the
remaining data on there so it's
important to know when you're making
these computations you're looking at min
and max and median
you're not going to know that there's no
values unless you double check your data
for the null values it's a very
important thing to note on there so just
a real quick
review on there we've done our created
our pd series and we've gone ahead and
done addition subtraction multiplication
division all those are three letters so
sub min div add
and then we looked at median maximum and
minimum so we're going to go ahead and
jump into the next big topic which is to
create a data frame so now we're going
to go from series and we're going to
create a number of series and bundle
them together to make a data frame
there we go cell type markdown let me go
ahead and run that so we have a nice
title on there it's always good to have
a good title all right so our first data
frame we'll jump in with some stuff that
looks a little complicated we'll break
it down first i'm going to create some
dates and you know what let's just go
ahead and do this i want you to see what
that looks like what i'm creating here
i've created a series of dates pd date
range and we're going to use these for
the index okay so when you look at this
you'll see that it's just basically it
comes out kind of like a basic python
list or a numpy array however you want
to look at it with our different dates
going down and we've generated six of
them and it's going to have whatever
time it is right now on your on the
thing for the date for the time that's
that time stamp right there and then
you'll see we have 11 19 2008 11 20 11
19 and looking into the future there so
that's all this is is generating a
series of dates that we're going to use
as our index and this is a pandas
command so we have a date range which is
nice it's one of the tools hidden in
there in the pandas that you can use
and next we're going to use numpy to go
ahead and generate some random numbers
in this case we'll do the
np.random.random
in six comma four you can look at this
as rows and columns as we move it into
the pandas and of course you could
reshape this if you had those backwards
on your data but we want the six to
match the rows and we have six periods
so our indexes should match along with
the rows on there and then you know
before we do the next one let's go ahead
and just print out our numpy array so
you can see what that looks like here we
have it one two three four by one two
three four five six four by six
so it's a nice little setup on there and
since working with data frames can be
very visual let's give our columns we
have four columns and we're going to
give them names a b c and d so now we
have columns on there also and then
let's put this all together in a data
frame and we can actually you know what
let's do this since i did it with
everything else let's go ahead and do
columns and you can see there's our
columns on there
and we'll go ahead and do df1
equals
pandas dot
data frame and note that the d and the f
are capitalized series it was just the s
and i always highlight this because you
don't know how many times these things
get retyped when you forget what's
capitalized on there it's a minor thing
you'll pick it up right away if you do a
lot of it and the first thing we want to
do is we want to go ahead and take our
numpy array because that's what we're
going to create our data frame off of is
the numpy array and then we want our
index equal to our dates so there's our
index in there and then we also have
columns equals
columns
and then finally let's see what that
looks like now remember we had all the
different data that just looks like a
jumble of data we have our column names
and everything else our numpy array kind
of just a jumble array over there four
by six you could sort of read it but
look how nice this looks i mean this is
you come into a board meeting you're
working with your
shareholders
this is pretty readable this is you know
this is our date this is our a b c d
whatever it is maybe it's one of these
dates has your leads
closures lost leads total dollar made
you know whatever it is fits in a
business maybe it's measurements on some
scientific equipment whether searching
material you know where this is like
higher the temperature low of the day
humidity of the date whatever it is so
you can see that we can really create a
nice clear chart and it looks just like
a spreadsheet you know we have our rows
and we have our columns and we have our
data in there now this one i use all the
time if we're going to create we can
create it like you saw here with our
numpy array very easy to do that and
reshape it you can also create it with a
dictionary array so here we have some
data let me just go down a notch so you
can see all the data on there we have an
animal in this case cat cat snake dog
dog cat snake cat dog we have the age so
we have an array of ages we have the
number of visits and the priority was it
a high priority yes
no
and then we're going to take that we're
going to create some labels we have a b
c d e f g h i and what i want you to
notice on this is we have a title animal
and then we have basically a python list
and these lists they don't necessarily
have to be equal because we can have
non-data you know np.nand numpy array
null value but we want to go ahead and
create labels that are equal to the
number in the list so a
the first cat b the second cat c the
snake d the dog and so on so we'll go
ahead and create our labels which we're
going to use as an index
and we'll call this df let's do it this
way we'll call this df2
equals pd for pandas
data frame
and then we have our data just like we
did before and we have our index equals
labels
and if we're going to go from there
let's go ahead and print it out so we
can see what that looks like df2 so
let's go ahead and run that another
again you have a nice very clean chart
to look at we've gone from this mess of
data here to what looks like a very
organized spreadsheet very visual and
easy to read
animal age visits priority and then a
through j cats and all your different
animals so on and so on and then when
you do programming a lot of times it's
important to know what the data types
are so we can simply do df2
types
and if we run that
we can see that our animal
is an object because it's just a string
but it comes in as an object age is a
float64 integer 64 and then priority
again is just an object and exploring
this this one's very popular let's go
df2
[Music]
head
and if we print that out the df2 head
returns the first 5 and we can change
this you don't have to do five you might
want to just look at the top two maybe
you want to look at
let's see oh let's do six so maybe we'll
look at just the top six in the database
in your data frame
and you can actually this creates
another data frame so i could have a df
three equal to df2 and this now takes
the df2 and just the first six values
so if we do df3
run get the same answer
and if we do it the head of the data we
can also do the tail it's the same thing
df tail you can look at the last
we'll just do the tell which by default
does five the last five and of course
you can just look at the last three of
those real quick just to see what's at
the end of the data and this is
the tell i love doing the tail of one
because i'll have like the index or
something like that and it will just
show me the last whatever the last entry
was looking at stock values and i might
want to look at just the last five days
of the stock values i can do that with
the data frame tail
and some other key things to look up
are the index so we can do df2 dot index
and i want you to notice that this isn't
a call function so if i put the brackets
on the end it'll give me an error
because index is not callable it's just
an object in there
so we do
df2.index there's also columns
so we can go ahead and let's do a let's
print this
remember the first one is not going to
show unless i print it and then df2
column so now we can see we have our
indexes
and we have our columns listed here
df2.columns animal age visits priority
it tells you what kind of object it is
or what kind of data type it is and
they're both object
and then finally df2 dot
values and again there's no brackets on
the end of df2.values
because this is an actual object it's
not a callable function so we'll go
ahead and run that
and it creates just displays a nice
array a very easy way to convert this
back to a numpy array basically so
before i go into the next section let's
just take a quick look at what we
covered so far with the data frame we
came up here we created our data frame
we did it from a numpy array first
setting the columns and the index the
index is setting it up is the same as
when we set up the series so that should
look very familiar so is the whole
format the numpy array the index dates
and the columns columns and remember in
our numpy array we're looking at row
comma column so six rows four columns is
how that reads in the data frame
and we went ahead and also did that from
a dictionary in this case animal was the
column name with all the date data
underneath that column and then age with
that data visits that data priority that
data and then of course we added our
labels in there for our index so there's
no difference in there but it
automatically pulled the column names
important to know when you're dealing
with a data frame and importing a data
frame this way
and then we did looking up d type we
looked at head and tail looking at your
data really quick
we also did index and columns and values
and note these don't have the brackets
on the end
so the next thing we want to do is go
ahead since we're dealing with data
science is we want to go and describe
the data so we have
df2.described to do that and we're going
to manipulate it in just a minute but
let's just see what this generates
and you can see right here we have age
and visits
so looking at our data from up above let
me just go all the way up here
animal age visits priority
and it does a nice job generating your
age versus visits which has all the data
you have your account your means your
standard deviation your minimum value
25 or in this group 50 75 and your
maximum value so this will look familiar
as a data science setup with your
describe for a quick look at your data
frame data so let's start manipulating
this data frame moving stuff around and
we'll start with transposing and it is
simply capital t for transpose
and when we run that it flips the
columns and the indexes so now the
indexes are all column names and the
columns are all indexes animal age
visits priority
so if we had come in here with our data
shaped wrong up above where we had a 4x6
we can quickly just swap it if we had it
backwards not a big deal and we can also
sort our data something that you can't
do which is more difficult to do with a
lot of other packages and the data frame
is really easy to do take our data frame
df2 and we're going to sort underscore
values
by equals age and so when we run this
you'll see the default is ascending so
we have 0.52 2.53 and everything else is
organized so if you look at your indexes
they've been moved around because each
index it moves a whole row not just the
one piece of data is not being sorted so
very quick way to sort by age are
different data in the data frame and in
addition to sorting it we can also slice
the data frame so i can do df2 and this
should look familiar from earlier we'll
just do one
to three so we're going to pull out oops
it does help if i use a df instead of
just d and we're going to pull up just
between one and three so we have no zero
which is a we have b which is two or b
which is one and c which is two so one
two and then it does not include three
which is the standard in python and we
can even do something like this we can
combine them which is always fun because
remember this returns a data frame so if
i take df2 dot
sort
values and we'll do by
equals age
this is just kind of fun and then i'm
going to slice it
there we go double check my typing and
run it
and now you should see fa because fa are
now 1 and 2 on there so you can very
quickly create a whole string on here
which narrows it you know that you can
sort it then slice it and do all kinds
of fun things with your data frame we'll
just go back to the original one run
there we go and if we can slice it by
row we can also query the data frame so
we can do df2 and this is a little
different because i'm going to create an
array within an array and in this case
we're going to look at oh let's do
age
comma visits
so look at the different format in here
we have one to three
so we've done this by slicing by an
integer value and then on here i've done
df2 age comma visits in an array and
when i run this
you can see that we get just these two
columns on here we get age and visits so
it's a quick way to select just two
columns or select number of columns
you're working with
and if you stop there we did the slicing
almost identical to slice is i location
which uses the integer location one
comma three
there's a push in pandas to move to this
particular setup
instead of doing just a regular slice
and that's because this can be confusing
when we slice one to three and then we
select age and visits
so there is a push to go ahead and move
to an eye location which does the same
thing you can see here bc it's the same
as up above there's also copy command so
we can do df3 equals df2 copy we're just
going to create a straight copy of it
and of course if we do df3
it'll be the same as the df2 on there so
df3 equals df2.copy
and then let's do df3 dot is null so
we're looking for null values
and this will return a nice map and
you'll see that everything is false
except when you go up here under the cat
or h they had a null there and so if we
go they have a couple up here also
underneath of let's see the dog okay
there's a bunch of nulls in here there's
d up here so let's look at d down here
and you'll see false true there it is
there's our null value
so we can create a quick chart of null
values you can use this to do other
things we can leverage that null value
to maybe take an average or something
and fill those null spaces with data and
we can also modify the location so
here's our df3 location
and notice this is location not
ilocation ilocation has i for integer
location uses the
in this case the variables on the left
and what we can do on here and we'll go
and just set this equal to
one
five
and then let's um i'll pick a spot
let's go back up here where we had let's
do f
a just let's see what are we looking at
oh here we go let's do f and h
and up here f is set to age of 2.0 and
we find out that that's incorrect data
so we go ahead and switch to df3
equal and then we're going to print out
our df3
and if we go to f and age it is now 1.5
so we're just changing the value in the
df3 and this is changing the actual data
frame remember a lot of our stuff we do
a slice
and like it returns another data frame
this changes the actual data frame and
that value in the data frame
so we've covered uh location and eye
location is null making a copy here's
our eye location which is equivalent of
a slice and also selecting columns
so now we want to dive just take a
little detour here and let's look at df3
means
and this is kind of nice because you can
do this you can either do this by as you
can select a single column here by the
way you can just add the column
selection right here like we did before
so we could have age
look up the mean that just creates a
series if i run that there's our age
but if i take that out instead of
selecting it we can do the whole setup
and it has age and visits so why doesn't
it have priority or animal
well those are not integers so it's
really hard
they're non-numerical values so what is
the average i guess you could do a
histogram which probably will look at
that later on but the only two things we
can really look at is age and visits and
we have
the average or the mean on the age is
3.375
and the mean on visits is 1.9
and let's do df3
visits we'll go and steal the visits
again
and remember all those different
functions we looked at for a series well
we can do those here we can do the sum
so if we run that we'll see that these
sum up to 19. we could also look up
minimum if you remember that from before
the minimum is 1
max
so all that functionality is here
i'll just go back to summing it up and
adding it all together so real quick
we've shown you how to take the series
operations and put them into the data
frame and then we can actually this is
interesting one we can just do df3 sum
run and you'll see the different
summations on there
it just combines them i like the way it
just combines the strings on there for
priority and animal we've looked at is
null we've also looked at copying along
with the different slices which we
talked about earlier so let's talk about
strings let's dive into the string setup
on there and let's go ahead and create a
string series string equals pd series
and we just put it right in there we
have a c d a a b a c a popped in a null
value
cow and al i don't know why they picked
cal and al in the background someone
must like those animals and of course we
can just do string if we run that you'll
see
leave the r out we'll get an error but
if we put it in there you'll see that we
have a simple series 0 a 1 c 2 d and it
automatically indexes it 0 to 8.
and then we can go string dot lower so
when we're talking about our data frame
in this case our data series string in
this case we use the string
function str and we're going to make it
lower and if we go ahead and put the
brackets on there and you'll see that
we've gone from capital a capital c so
on to abc and baca
cow al they were all lower case already
and of course if you want to go lower
you can also do upper we'll go ahead and
run that and you can see we now have acd
aaa baca everything is capitalized
except for the null value which is still
null all right so we looked at a few
basic string you can see that string
functions upper and lower we're going to
jump into a very important topic i'm
even going to give it its own
header on here because it's such an
important topic what do you do with
missing values
panda has some great tools for that so
we'll dive into those
we'll call we'll work with df4 and if
you remember the df copy from above
we're just going to make a copy of df3
and let's just take a quick look at the
data we're working with
oops df3 forgot the three on there there
we go
so here we have our cats snakes and dogs
hopefully not all in the same container
because that would be just probably mean
to all of them so we made a copy we're
going to be working with df4 and the
reason we made a copy is we want to go
ahead and fill the data and we just
simply do fill in a and then we're going
to give it the value we want to put in
there we'll give it the value 4. so i
can run in here and you'll see now that
df4
now has where the n a was is filled with
the value of four same thing down here
a lot of times we'll compute the mean
first so i might do a mean
age
equals df4 and then we want to go ahead
and do age
and dot mean
and then i'll do something like this df4
i only want to select the age and i want
to fill that
with the mean
age
and i run in there and you'll see that
our df4h now has the means in there just
a quick way of showing you how you can
combine these let me go back to our
original one there we go and run that
and keeping with good practices df5
equals df3 dot copy
and we'll print our df5 which should be
the original one
and then on the df5 we can now drop our
missing data
i'm going to simply drop in a
and we're going to use how equals any so
i'm going to drop any row that has
missing data in it and you'll see we had
d here with missing data and h
and then let's go ahead and see what df5
looks like when we do that
there we go and there it is d is gone
and so is h so we create a new data
frame off of this missing those values
now if you have a lot of data dropping
values is a good way to take care of it
because you don't miss some data if you
have not a whole lot of data you're
working with like the iris data set or
something like that or something small
you want to start trying to find a way
to fill that data in so you don't lose
your computational power of the data you
got
so just a quick look at processing null
values
or missing values you can fill them
usually with the means some people use
medium or the mode there's different
ways you can fill it one way is means
and we can also just drop those rows
those are the two main things we do with
missing data
here we go uh we're going to cover next
this is i so love data frames for this
file operations
it saved me so much time because they
have so many different tools for
bringing data in and saving data so
we're looking at the data frame file
operations it's really streamlined i
don't know how many times they'll go on
to
different data downloads and they'll
have panda download standard on there
just because it's so widely used so
let's start with the most common file is
a csv so we have df3 to csv or animal
and let me just show you what the folder
is going into
right now i have some untitled and a few
things in here but nothing labeled
animal so we go ahead and run this
and this is now saved the animal to
my hard drive and you can now see the
animal folder up here and if i let's do
edit with a notepad oh let's open up
with just a regular notepad there we go
or wordpad if i open that up you can see
it's comma separated our titles they
don't have an index on the categories on
the top and the index comma then all the
different data is separated by commas
standard csv file on there and if we're
going to send it to csv and notice the
format is dot 2 underscore csv
and it's just the name of the file we're
sending it to you can also put the
complete path by default it's going to
go whatever the active directory this
program is running on that's why those
other folders are in there so we have
our df3 to csv and then if we're going
to put it in there we want to also get
it back out and we'll call this one df
underscore animal equals pd read
underscore csv
i always have to remember is two
underscore csv and read underscore csv i
always want to do like a capital in
there and not the underscore we're going
in here again it's the active directory
so if i now do print out my df animal
and let's just do the ahead we only want
to look at the first three lines so if i
go ahead and run this
we'll see the first three lines and they
should match up here what we saved to
our csv
so very easy to save and import from our
csv files on here
and it turns out df
3 also has a 2 xl they actually have a
lot of different formats but you know
old school
excel was real popular for so long still
is we can go ahead and save it as animal
dot xlsx we're going to call the sheet
named sheet1
and then i can also do df we'll call it
animal2
animal2 and this one's going to come
from in the same format on here there we
go so we still have our animal xlsx
the sheet one that's where it's coming
from index columns equals none so we're
not going to we're going to suppress the
indexing on the columns n a values and
it'll just assign that zero one up on
your indexes so if it says index columns
equals none that's what it does and then
we've added null values because there's
no values in here and we want to just
make sure that they're marked as n a
and we'll go ahead and just print out
the animal animal
2 there we go and let's run that let's
make this let's just do the whole thing
so we'll go ahead and run that and it
probably doesn't help that i completely
forgot the read
so animal 2 equals pd.read
excel there we go excel so now we go
ahead and run it
and what we expect is happening here we
have the same data frame on here and if
i flick back to my folder you can now
see that we have the animal one of these
is in excel and one of these is a csv on
here and so there's our two file types
on there and they have other formats
these are just the two most common ones
used and i don't know how many times
i've had stuff from excel i need to pull
out if you've ever played with excel
it's a nightmare in the back end because
of the way they do the indexing
so this just makes it quick and easy to
pull in an excel spreadsheet today we're
going to study the matte plot library
and the python code so let's start with
what is matte plot library map plot
library is an open source drawing
library which supports rich drawing
types it is used to draw 2d and 3d
graphics
and there are so many packages in the
matplot library we're going to cover the
basics and there are so many packages
that sit on top of the maplight library
that we can't even cover them all today
but we'll hit the main one so you have a
good understanding of what the matplot
library is and what the basics can do
you can understand your data easily by
visualizing it with the help of matplot
library you can generate plots
histograms bar charts and many other
charts with just a few lines of code and
here we have some basic types of plots
you can see here that we'll go into we
have the bar chart the histogram boy i
use a lot of histograms in my stuff
scatter plot line chart pie chart and
area graph
let's start plotting them and to do this
i'm going to be using jupiter notebook
you can use any of your python
interfaces for programming or scripting
and running it of course we here really
like the jupiter notebook for doing
basic a lot of basic stuff because it's
so visual and in our jupiter notebook
which opens up in this case i'm using
google chrome you can go up here to new
and we'll create a new python 3 and set
that up
if you're not familiar with jupyter
notebook we do have a tutorial that
covers some of the basics of that you'll
look at any of our tutorials i usually
cover a number of them showing how to
set up jupiter and anaconda i myself use
jupiter through anaconda in fact let's
go ahead and open that up and just take
a look at this see what that looks like
you can see your anaconda navigator if
you install it it will automatically
install the jupiter notebook and that
also installs a lot of other things i
know some people like the qt console for
doing python or spyder i've never used
them i actually use notepad plus plus as
one of my editors and then i use the
jupiter notebook a lot because it's so
easy to have a visual while i'm
programming an even simple script in
python i'll take it from the jupyter
notebook and then do a save as you can
always go under file and you can
download as a python program so that
will download it as an actual python
versus the ipython that this saves it as
so let's go ahead and dive in and see we
got going here and let's go ahead and
put matplot library tutorial and i'm
going to turn this cell into a mark down
so it doesn't actually run it
you can see it has a nice little title
there that's all jupiter notebook
and then from matplot library
let's import
pi lab
back one and then let's go ahead and
just print we'll go pi lab
and the version let's go ahead and run
this so we're going to import our pi lab
module from the matplot library and we
find out that we're in version 1.15.1
always important to note the version
you're in probably i was reading an
article that said the number one thing
that python programmers struggle with is
remembering what version they're working
in and making sure that they're going
from one platform to the other with the
same version and if we're going to graph
things i think we need some data to
graph so we're going to import numpy as
np now if you're not familiar with numpy
definitely go back and check out our
numpy tutorial there's so many different
things you can do with it dealing with
reshaping the data and creating the data
we're just going to use it to create
some data for us
and there is a lot of ways to create
data but we're going to use the np.line
space so we're going to create a numpy
array and the way you read this is we're
going to create numbers between 0 and 10
and we're going to create 25 of these
numbers so we're just going to divide
that equally up between 0 and 10. and if
we have x coordinates we should probably
have some y coordinates and we'll do
something simple like x times x
plus 2. and let's just take a look we're
going to print x
and print
y
let me go ahead and run this
and let's see we got going on here so we
have our x coordinates which is 0 0.4
0.83 etc and you can look at this as an
xy plot so we have 0 we have 2. we have
0.416 we have
2.17 and just as a quick reminder we're
going to do print np array x comma y dot
reshape 25 comma 2. and the reason i
want to do this is i want to show you
something here
a lot of times a program returns
x comma y and it's an array of x comma y
x comma y x comma y
and so when you're working with the pie
plot
you have to separate it out and reshape
it so if i start off with pairs like
this i can reshape them if i know
there's 25 pairs in there i can switch
the 2 and the 25 and this is kind of
goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape so
i'm going to reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25
and if i run that you'll see i end up
with the same output as the x y the two
different arrays in here
and this is important that we want x and
y separate
again that's all numpy stuff but it's
important to understand that this is a
format that matplot library works with
it works with an array of x's and they
should match your array of y's so each
one has 25 different entities in it
and then for our basic plotting of this
data it only takes one command to draw
graph of this data and so we use our
from up here where we imported pi lab we
take our pi lab and the key under there
is plot for plotting a line and then we
want our x coordinates and our y
coordinates and we'll throw in r and the
r simply means red so we're going to
draw the line in red let me go and run
that
you can actually switch this around if
you wanted to do different there's b
for blue we have a lot of fun yellow
hard to see yellow there we go but we'll
go ahead and stick with red
run
and when you're doing presentations with
these try to be consistent you know if
the business and the shareholders send
you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
use red for losses in your graph
try to be consistent use green for
profit for money you don't have to
necessarily use green but it's whatever
they're using whatever the company is
using try to mirror that that way people
aren't going to be confused if you
switch your data around every time one
graph has red for loss and one graph has
blue for loss it gets really confusing
so make sure you're consistent in your
graphs and your coloring and something
to know because we're going to cover
this in a minute this is your canvas
size so we have a canvas here and what
we're going to do next is we're going to
look at sub graphs okay so let's take
our pi lab and create a sub plot
and one of the things also to know when
we're working with the
matplot library i'm not setting when i
do this this is my drawing canvas the pi
lab so once i've imported the pi lab i'm
drawing my images on there very
important to know and with the subplot
we're going to give it some different
values
and we're going to represent by rows
columns and indexes and let's do one two
one so it's going to be the first row
second column and the index is like you
can stack your graphs and things like
that we don't worry too much about
indexes but rows and columns we want to
go ahead and use row one and column two
and if we're going to have one object we
should probably have two but before we
do that we have to plot data onto the
subplot so the order is very important
and we're going to stick with our x
comma y
and let's do this we're going to add in
a third parameter here remember we did
red we're going to add shorthand dash
dash for dashed lines so this plots the
data into row one column two
and if we're going to do that let's do
up another one pilab dot subplot and if
we're gonna do row one let's do
column two and index two
and this time we're gonna add g for
green and this denotes a style and if
we're going to set up our pylab
subplot there we go
lab we've got to go ahead and plot that
pi
lab plot
and instead of x y we want y comma x
oops i messed up this is in the wrong
spot there we go we'll move that down
here real quick because that goes in the
plot part so the subplot tells it the
row column and index and the pi plot
tells it what data in this case we
switched them and the color and then the
style shorthand now let's go ahead and
run that
and you'll see it takes this canvas
splits it in two and now we have two
different graphs and we have the red one
with dashed lines and we have the green
one which is has little stars going up
and if we take this and let's just um
just for fun let's change this and run
that with an index of one it puts them
both on the same index and also gives me
a warning because it's a strange way of
doing two subplots there's depreciated
there's another way to do it but most
people just ignore that warning because
it's not going to go away any time soon
now that's using the same setup what
happens if we do
instead of
this let's change the column on here and
find out what happens
and if we do the column
it didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep our
column as 2 and let's change the row on
the second one to two
and run that
and you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together and causes some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where i made some changes i said row two
and look what happens when i change to
column two so i now have row two column
two index two i squished it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does and there's all kinds
of different things you really have to
just play with these numbers till you
get a handle on them because
you know you have to repeat it 164 times
according to cambridge university if
it's completely new to you and you can
see right here where we go three
run there we go but you can see it takes
a little bit sometimes to play with
these and get the numbers right
hopefully hit the wrong one that's why
let's go three there three there run
there we go now it's overlapping so i
have this doubled over here on the right
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
this with the where we have column and
row two and the two different indexes so
they appear nice and neatly side by side
and then as we just saw as we were
flashing through them we can put them on
top of each other
and let me just highlight that and copy
it down here
paste it down there and here we have one
two one and then we'll do one two one
also for this one and that puts the two
subplots directly on top of each other
gives us that warning and you can see we
now have two different sets of data
graphed on top of each other and you can
also see how it did the indexes since
one of them is from 0 to 10 that's the
green one on the x axis and the other
one is from 0 to 10 on the y-axis so it
took the greatest value of either one
and then used those as a shared value
so let's
next look at operator description and
we'll go ahead and turn this cell into a
markdown and run that so it looks nice
so fig and you remember i talked about
the canvas earlier i briefly mentioned
it we're going to look a little bit more
at the canvas later on but that's what
the figure is fid we're going to add
axes so we're going to initialize a
subplot add the subplot
in rows and columns and all kinds of
different things with this you can do
let's look at that code and see exactly
what's going on and i want you to notice
that there's fig which is the actual
canvas in the matplot library and ax is
commonly used to refer to the subplots
so we're creating subplots you'll see ax
equals plt subplot
earlier we did the pi lab so let's go
ahead and import pi plot from matplot
library and we're going to do it as plt
you'll see that a lot that's really the
standard in the industry is to call it
plt just like pandas is pd and numpy
array is np certainly you can import it
as whatever you want but i would stick
to the standards and we're going to do
the same graph as we did above
with the
pi lab but with the plt so if it looks
familiar there's reason we're doing this
because we want to show you how the
figure part works and working with the
canvas goes but we're going to do the
same plot as we did before and we'll
call it fig and we're going to set that
equal to plot figure so there's our
figure or canvas on there and let's
create a variable called axes and we're
going to set that equal to fig dot add
axes
and in this we're going to control the
left right the width the height of the
canvas from zero to one
so we can go ahead and i'm just going to
put some stuff in there i got point five
point one point eight point eight so
when you're looking at this this is a
zero to one or you could say fifty
percent ten percent eighty eighty
percent but it's a control it's going to
control your left and your right along
with the width and the height so the
width and the height we're gonna use
eighty percent and we're going to have
like a little indent on the left and the
right and this should look familiar from
above x use dot plot
x comma y
and then let's give it a color how about
red since we're recreating the same
graph let's keep it uniform oops and it
helps if i use a axis instead of ax es i
don't know where that came from but this
looks identical to the one we had up
above so here's our axis plot x comma y
of red
same graph same setup but this time
we've added a variable equal to the
figure dot add axes so our plot figures
our canvas our axes is what we're
working in and then our axis.plot x
comma y
and again we can draw sub graphs let me
put that down here
[Music]
just like we did before and a little
different notation here we're going to
fig comma
axes equal
plt.subplots
and in here it's going to be the number
of rows
we're going to do one row
and columns equals two so if you
remember before this that we did we had
one row with two different graphs on it
we're going to do the same thing but
know how we did this here's our figure
our canvas and our axes we're going to
create actually two different axes we're
going to create row 1 column 2. and so
axis is an array of information so we
can simply do
let's do x in axes
this will now look familiar x dot plot
we're going to do x comma y we'll go
ahead and make a red keep everything
looking the same remember nice uniform
graphs everything looks the same and if
we go ahead and run this
you'll see we get two nice side-by-side
graphs so just as we had before the same
look the same setup
and just for fun let's change in columns
to three we'll run that and now you see
we'll have three on there and let's see
if we make it a little bit more
interesting we'll do in rows equals to
two and you can see down here we're
going to get an attribute error because
it's trying to scrunch everything
together
so it does have a limit how much stuff
you can put in one small space that's
important to know you can fix that by
changing the canvas size which we'll
look at in just a minute and there's
other ways to change it on here but here
we go we can do in rows 2 and columns
equals 1. you can see two nice images
right above each other we'll go back to
the original one row two columns side by
side left to right and
we can also
draw a picture
or graph
inside another graph
and that's kind of a fun thing to do
it's important to note that we can layer
our stuff on top of each other which
makes for a really nice presentation
so let's start by uh fig we'll create
another figure so we're going to start
over again with our canvas
we set that equal to plt.figure
so there's our new canvas and let's do
axes we'll call it axes one and two axis
one equals fig dot add axes remember
this from earlier
and
this here similar numbers we used before
saying how big this axis is this figure
in the axis is so this is going to be
the big
axis and let's do axes 2 equals
another figure add axes and then
0.2.5.4.3
and if we're going to do this they need
data on them so let's go ahead and plot
some data on our axes so axis1 dot plot
and we'll make this simply x comma y
comma make it red
and then let's go axes2 dot plot and
let's reverse them y comma x comma green
there we go doing what i told you not to
do you shouldn't be swapping axes around
and plotting your data in five different
directions because it's confusing let's
go ahead and run this and see what this
looks like and then let's talk a little
bit about this we talked about the
0.2.5.4.3
and let me just grab the annotation for
that that's left right width and height
so we have in here that this is going to
be left right so here's our left is
point one in point five and we you know
what let's just play with this a little
bit what happens when i change this to
point one moves it way over to the left
so there's our point one so we can make
this point four run that there we go so
you can see how you can move it around
the branches on here 0.2
0.5 is the
left so that's our right so see what
happens when we do point oh let's make
this point one
that actually is they had it down at
left right i thought this was wrong it's
actually how far from the bottom let me
switch that on here bottom there we go
so we had here on this we can go ahead
and put that back to 0.5 and run that
and this is 0.3 let's make this 0.3 also
and that is the width and then of course
there's the height we can make that
really tiny actually let's do 0.2
and let's run that and you can see it
changes the height on there we make it
even smaller 0.2 by 0.2 and as you can
see you can get stuck playing with this
to make it look just right it can
sometimes take a little bit
certainly once you have the settings if
you're doing a presentation you try to
keep it uniform unless it doesn't make
sense for the graph you're working on
try to keep the same colors the same
position and the same look and feel
and i mentioned earlier we can adjust
the canvas sides so this is from earlier
i just copied it down below we're going
to replot the same data we've been
looking at and what we can do is we can
change the figure size to 16 by nine let
me run that and show you what that looks
like so it fills the whole screen and
then if you are normally when you're
working on the screen you don't worry
too much about this but we can set the
dpi to 300
run that
there it goes this is your dots per inch
and if you are doing an output of this
and you're printing a hard copy you want
the higher quality i would suggest
nothing under 300 if it's a professional
print you might get a little less than
that but whenever i'm doing professional
graphics and printing them out on
something 300 dots per inch is kind of
the minimal on there you can go a lot
higher too but keep in mind the higher
you get the more memory it takes and the
more lag time and the more resources you
use so usually 300 is a good
solid number to use your dots per inch
and you can see it drills a nice it
draws a nice large canvas here which is
16 by 9 and then the dpi is 300 on here
so it's a little higher quality and just
out of curiosity i wonder how long it
takes to draw something double that size
600 and you can see here where at 600
dpi it's going to take a while there it
goes just because it's utilizing a lot
more graphics on there and let me just
go back to the 300 now we'll actually do
let's do a 100 you're not going to see a
difference on this because it is web
based graphics are pretty low
and up here you saw i did this with the
plot figure this works the same if i do
figure axes subplot figure size and then
we'll go ahead and do axes
dot plot
x comma y comma we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this and you
should get almost the same thing here
here's our
axis on the subplot on here with the
fixed size and the dpi let me take this
all out let me just remove all that real
quick run it again there we go now we're
back to our original figure and let's
look at some of the other things you can
do with this
one thing we do is we can set a title
for the axis so axis set title you'll
see right here since i put this on the
axis it's the main title for the whole
graph
and if you're going to have a title you
should also label so we can label our x
label and we can set our y label in this
case we're just going to call it x and y
keep it nice and uniform and if we run
this you'll see that we've added a nice
x label and y label whoops where'd they
go and it turns out in this environment
that you have to put it before the title
so let me go ahead and put it before the
title and there's our xy let me run that
and of course we can also do upper size
a little bit so you can see what's going
on a little better so here we have x
label x if you come down here you'll see
our x label and our y label we can of
course change this to x
label you can change this to y
be whatever you want on here of course
and our title graph there we go run so
here we have our title graph our y label
and our x label all set up on our nice
little plot and then before we move on
to the next section let's do one more
thing on here we have a thing called the
legend and we're going to do we're going
to set our ax legend label 1 label 2 up
here it's a format for it but let's go
down here and actually use it i'm going
to do two different plots we're going to
have axes plot x by x times x squared
and x cubed and if i run this you'll see
it puts two nice graphs on the setup on
there but it's nice to have a legend
telling you what's going on so for the
legend we can actually do axes since we
have the two plots legend and on here
we've created an array
and we have y equals x squared y equals
x cubed you can actually put this as
whatever you want those are just strings
and then location two and let's go ahead
and run this and see what that looks
like and you can see it puts a nice
legend on the upper left hand corner
location two we can do location three
and run it and it drops it down to the
bottom location one i can't remember
where that's at there we go upper right
so each one of these is a number that
refers to the different locations on the
screen zero kinda have to play with them
or look them up to remember where
they're at but they do work it just kind
of moves around depending on where you
want your legend out on there so on this
section we cover the title of the graph
the y labels and legends this is we're
getting into some starting to look
really fancy here so we now have
something we can actually put out you'll
see the title the graph looks a little
fuzzy so i might in a web setup put the
dpi up a couple notches maybe put it at
200 100 might work fine just so you know
something to notice on here when you're
playing with these different things we
had our subplots dpi equals oh let's do
200 to see what that looks like
so you can see now it's a lot clearer
it's also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
dpi dots per inch
so the next section is let's look at
some graph features we're going to look
at line color transparency size and a
few more things on here and oops i
forgot the main title so we have our
figure in our axis equals our plot and
subplots and i'm going to do a dpi
equals 150 so the graph comes out nice
and large and easy for you to see
and let's go ahead and do three plots on
here we'll do x by x plus once which is
going to be a straight line plot
x plus x plus 2
and axis dot plot
x x
plus 3. this looks like we're doing
nearest neighbor setup we're showing how
it uh located data putting your lines on
there between the nearest neighbors
there we go so it draws a nice little
graph with three lines on it one of the
things we can do is we can control the
alpha on this oops and you can actually
see the when they did these lines it
automatically pulls in different colors
for your setup so there's some automatic
automatic things going on in there and a
lot of times we do that comma r where
we're going to do color equals red
another notation on here let's go ahead
and run this now we have a bright red
line down there and with the matte plot
library you're not limited to red you
can also use the one of many different
color references as you see here with
the pound sign one one five five dd
which just is just blue and we can do
the same thing with another color on
here which turns out to be green i can
just as easily do this green
blue oops there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what i want to do is i want to
make this we're going to say what's
called the alpha on this and we're going
to set this equal to 0.5
so this is halfway see-through when i
run this and it's almost going to look
pink because you can see through it and
let's change this just a little bit just
to make this kind of fun let's square it
there we go run it so now we have this
nice square that comes up and you can
see when it crosses it because i plotted
these two lines after it and they have
no alpha the red is behind those lines
or in this case pink because we did the
alpha halfway through so let's go ahead
and do this alpha equals 0.5 and oh you
know what instead of squaring it let's
take it to the 0.5 power that'll be kind
of interesting to see what that does
we'll just go to keep it squared there
we go
and run that and let's go back and look
at this where it crosses over and the
first thing you see right here is on the
blue is kind of light blue now you can
see how the two colors add together you
get almost a purple on there so i can
clearly see where the red crosses the
blue line and then the green just blanks
it over because i didn't do any
opaqueness no alpha on there
so this is great if you have lots of
data that crosses over and you need to
be able to track those lines better and
we'll go ahead and do this 0.5 and we'll
run that oops i did
equals 0.5 let me go ahead and run that
and so you can see right here now you
can easily see the red line how it
crosses the green and the blue down here
and if we want to we can do this as the
default is one solid so we can change
this all to point eight let me just do
that
oops 58 eight there we go run
oops i must have hit a wrong button
there let me try that again i actually
get rid of a bracket and let's go ahead
and run that
and we come down here and look at this
you can still see where it passes behind
them but the green dominates and the
blue dominates because we're now at
eighty percent instead of fifty percent
when you can do less that's kind of fun
although at some point the lanes kind of
fade
so point five is usually the best
setting on there we have a nice pastel
here at point three and you can easily
see where they cross over and just like
you can play with the colors we can play
with line width and you know let's do
let's try dpi 100 and see what that
looks like on my screen equals 100 and
we'll go ahead and just take our ax plot
let's do four of these lines just you
can see how they look next to each other
real quick here there we go
if i run this they should all appear the
same it automatically does different
colors on there so let's do color equals
blue
i forgot my quotation marks there we go
and we'll go ahead and just make these
all blue just for purposes of being nice
and uniform and then what i want to do
is i want to do the line
width
width equals
0.25
and let's just copy and paste that down
here
let's do equals one
about 1.5 and let's do one just make
this equal to two let's see what that
looks like and we do that you can see it
goes from a very thin line a 0.5 a 1 our
1.5 and 2 which is twice the width of
the 1. and if we're going to do
different sizes we had different colors
we had our alpha scheme let's take this
whole thing here
let's paste it down here and do another
one
but instead of line width let's look at
styles and something to know here you
can actually abbreviate this with lw so
line width can also be point let's just
do everything point two and let's set up
a line style we'll do the first one
dashes let me just paste that down here
so i'm not doing a lot of extra typing
there we go
take this out so we have our dashed
we can do a dash dot let's do the dash
dot here and a colon here there we go
and there's a lot of different options
we'll look at a few more as we go down
for different ways of highlighting data
but when you look at this we have
everything is a line width of two and
now we have a straight line we have a
dashed line or a dot dash and a dot dot
dot line
and then another thing we can add on
here is we're going to do here's our ax
plot and we did x let's do x plus
4 so it goes right on the top then do
color black line width 1.5 so it's a
smaller line and we're going to take the
line and we're going to set dashes so
look i've changed some of the notation
here for my line and my ax plot so i can
set my line comma equal to x plot and
then i can change the line settings this
way and when i run this let me run that
on here you'll see the 5 10 15 10
creates a series of dashes
that are buried in link
link in this case they alternate between
a short dash and a long dash
we can play with these numbers curiosity
always has me what happens when you play
with the numbers just to see what they
look like let's do this let's paste this
down here i'll do two of these just
because they're kind of fun to play with
and let's change this from 10 to
3 and we're going to change this one
from 15
to
4. and let's run that and you can see
the differences in the lines oops very a
little bit confusing on there because i
forgot to change the lines are all on
top of each other so let me change that
really quick here and let's run that and
now you can see here's our original
dashed line alternating when i change
these numbers on the second one the very
end value to 3 you can see now we have
the dashes of five let's see i'm going
to guess this is a dash is a five skip
ten dashes of fifteen skip three and
then it goes back to the beginning dash
is five dashes skip ten
dashes skip three and of course the last
one we just switched up a little bit it
looks a lot more uniform because i'm
using two sets of ten or if i did
something like this and change it to 30
it really becomes pronounced as far as
the distances between them and instead
of 4 let's go oh let's put 30 here also
30 by 30 there we go really pronounced
on that one and let's look at one more
important group for plotting our data
and in this we're going to here's our
plot we started with with the x plus one
x plus two x plus three and did it in
blue on this one's three or four
different blue lines
and this property we want to add the
actual plots so you can see where the
plots are on the graph and for that we
might have marker equals o and if we run
this you'll see it puts a dot for each
of these and there's 25 dots because we
have 25 x values so we actually have
zero and each of the different values of
x y are then plotted here with the dots
and we don't want to just limit
ourselves to dots
you can also do
plus sign that's another option dots is
most common i'll actually like the dots
the best if we do the plus sign you see
it puts a nice crosshairs or plus sign
on there and we can do a marker there's
a number of different markers you can
use
and i think this one was it s is another
one
which is a nice square and that's
actually a good one s for square o for
period okay that's just kind of weird so
you can see that probably on these
markers another one is uh number one so
if we run that you'll see we now have
these little hatch marks
and let's take oh let's just go with the
o on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some stuff we're gonna do here on
just a second let's do
marker
size equals two and
change that to five and run that and you
can see here it's a nice little tiny dot
versus uh the size dot here this is
interesting because it said two i
thought it would be bigger
but if you do 0.5 it gets even smaller
and let's just do 10 to see what that
looks like run that looks huge so marker
size a lot of these are dependent on the
dpi and the setups there's things that
switch around as far as the way the size
shows up you got to be a little careful
when you change one setting it can
change all the other markers and then
let's take our square on here
and we'll do we have marker size so we
also have marker face
we'll set that equal to red of course i
mean change the so it's up one notch
we'll run that whoops must have mistyped
something on here and i did it's marker
face color equals red and so when i run
that you can now see i have the squares
on there with the marker face color of
course we can mix and match these
come down here and we'll make this
instead of let's make this plus seven
and we'll make this
size 15
marker face color
equals
and we'll do what green just because
there we go run very hard to actually
see what's going on there still 25 dots
they kind of overlap as you can see they
print them over each other of course if
we really wanted to make it look
horrible we could just make that really
huge
generally though you want something a
little bit smaller and cuter we'll just
try doing it this way there we go that's
too small to even see the face so four
you can start to see the face on there
around four and maybe an eight eight
might be a good number for this there we
go eight again that all just depends on
what you're trying to show and display
so we've covered a lot of stuff here as
far as our lines we've covered
opaque with our alpha setting on there
give us some nice pastels you can see
how they overlap and how they cross over
we covered the line with different size
on there different formats for the line
itself and these are all you can combine
all these so you can have our line width
equals two line style equals dash you
can bring this down here also to the
markers and then we added markers in
just entered a circle a
plus sign the square a little tick which
uses a one then we had a marker size and
a marker color face and we combine those
you see we get a nice different series
of representations we also briefly
mentioned color where you didn't have to
use like in here we used color black
someplace up here and i have to find it
we use the actual number for the color
as opposed to i changed them to red and
blue so you get very precise on the
color if you have a very specific color
set that you need to match your website
or whatever you're working on
all those are tools in the matplot
library so we have
one more piece to formatting the graph
so we want to show you and then we have
two big sections we're going to go over
the different graphs that they have
along with a challenge problem so let's
go to the last section we're going to
look at is limits we're going to limit
our data
so this first primer is going to paste
in there we're going to create our
subplots one two so one row two columns
we're going to do a figure size of 10
comma five this should all look familiar
now since we've done a number of them
and we're going to go ahead and plot and
this is an interesting notation you
should notice here our axis zero so one
we've used instead of you can just
iterate through them but they're just an
array so it's an array of zero is still
the axes of the first axes out of two
and we're going to plot x
x squared
x x cubed lined with two so we're going
to go ahead and just plot two graphs
right on top of each other without doing
multiple plots on here and we'll set the
grid equal to true one here let's go
ahead and run that and you can see here
our two plots with the x value going
across
and i'm going to do something similar
and by the way as you can just if you
look at it you can see the grid on there
that's all that is
easier to spot the data going across
we're going to take the same
data for axes one so we have our plot of
x x squared x and x cubed line with two
and this time we're going to take our
axes one and do y limit
it's actually set underscore y limit
this is the y axis so it's going to be
an array of two two values and we'll do
0 comma
60 i'm just making these numbers up the
guys in the back actually made them up
i'm just using their numbers
we're going to set the x limit
and we'll set the x limit as don't
forget our brackets there
two comma five
so it's the same data going in and but
we're setting a limit on it let's go
ahead and run that and let's see what it
comes out of and here we have the y
limit zero to sixty so we're looking at
just the lower part of this curve here
up to here and we have the x limit two
to five so that starts right here at two
and you can see very different graphs
this is kind of nice because you could
actually put one of these on top of the
other if you wanted to draw focus to one
part of a graph remember how we did that
earlier one inside the other but just a
quick note you can easily limit your
graph and re kind of reshape the way it
looks quite easily and we can also add
that grid down there if you want a grid
we'll run that and add the grid in there
oops i guess you have to do the grid
beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
may double check your order when you're
printing these things out it also helps
if i change it to one so in this case
might not be the order i wonder if we'll
go back here as one there we go so it
doesn't matter the order and grid but
you can set the grid for easy viewing
here nice setup on there but you can see
how we can limit the data
so let's start looking at some other 2d
graphs and make this cell a markdown so
we run it as a nice pretty title to it
and let's go ahead and create some data
with an np array we'll do
0 to 5 on here there we go and let's
look at four common graphs we'll put
them side by side so we'll do a figure
our axes equals plot subplots one four
columns and then figure size hopefully
it'll fit nicely on here it seems to do
a pretty good on here and i'll go and
just run that since we're in there run
you'll see i have my four blank plots on
here
and we'll start with axes of zero let's
set title
and we want this to be a scatter plot
a scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axes of
zero
dot scatter easy to remember scatter a
bunch of plots on there we'll do our
in we can do x or n there we go and
let's go ahead and do axes set title
scatter already did that we're just
going to do scatter
that's how you do it on there notice how
you create a scatter plot with simply
with the scatter control and we'll do
let's do the variable x
x
plus let's throw some randomness in here
usually scatter plots are i have a lot
of random numbers connected to them
that's why they do them on there and so
the bigger the x gets the bigger the
randomness so 0.25 times the randomness
and what we should end up doing here is
with the scatter plot and you can see as
you go up it just kind of has some
random numbers and moves up and down the
line
but plus just the points so if you
remember from back up here where we did
marker
this is plotting basically just the
marker so it's a scatter plot
probably less used is a step plot so for
exes one we'll go ahead and do a step
plot so you can see what that looks like
and this time we'll use our n value
instead of x we generated that n value
up here and so for this we have n
n times 2 r n squared n times 2 n
squared line width equals 2 and if we
run that it creates a nice step up
let's see so we've got a scatter plot
we've got a step
plot let's do a bar plot
and we'll use the same formula in n
squared alignment centered because you
can have them left or right with 0.5 and
alpha if you remember correctly that's
how opaque it is
let's see what that looks like on there
so we have some nice you can see here a
nice bar plot it should look very
similar to the step plot but colored in
and we can change the width let's see
what happens we do 0.9
run
and if we take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
alpha we can take the alpha out too and
run that so now you have the solid
colors and if we take out the center
and run that
everything you really can't see the
shift on here because that's actually
the default on this but these are common
settings for the bar graph let me just
put them back in there there we go
alignment center and alpha now i can't
say i've used the step craft very much
there's certain other certain i guess
domains of expertise require a step
graph but the scatter plot and the bar
graph very common especially the bar
graph and we'll look at histograms here
in just a minute so i use histograms a
lot especially in data science but this
is nice if you have very concrete
objects somebody how many people wearing
yellow hats that kind of thing but if
we're going to do that let's go ahead
and do the last one which i see a lot
more in the sciences certainly using the
data science but more like for mapping i
saw publication on
solar flares and they were discussing
the energy and so filling in the graph
gives it a very different look so we're
going to do the fill between
and it's just like you think it'd be
it's fill between but with a underscore
between them and we'll do x and x
squared and x and x cubed and we'll do
color green and alpha again in case you
had other data you want to plot on there
you can see it forms a nice squared
coming up here and also if you look at
the bottom one is your squared value the
upper line is your cubed value and then
it fills in everything in between
if you remember from calculus this would
be if you had like a car a motor an
efficiency they would talk about the
efficiency going up and the loss and
you're looking for the space or the area
between the two lines so it gives you a
nice visual of that now let's look at a
few more basic two dimensionals so we
have our figure figure size on here
we're going to do a radar chart to be
honest i've never used a radar chart in
business or in data science i have to
find a reason to use one now so the
first line for doing a radar chart we
have to add axes and the figure and with
this this actually creates our
oh let's let's run it so you can see
what it creates it creates a nice looks
like you're on a submarine and you're
tracking the hunt for red october or
something like that and it needs all of
these the polar is the fact that we're
doing polar coordinates
zero zero point six point six has to do
with the size if you take out any of
these things and run them you get just a
box if you take out the other half you
pretty much get nothing in there and if
you change these numbers and change them
a little bit you can see it gets bigger
they had 0.6 on here i'll go ahead and
leave it as one because that's just kind
of fun that's all about the size on here
the height and the width
and then let's create some data t equals
np line space and this is 0 to 2 times
np times pi so if you remember that is
the
distance across and we're going to
generate 100 points
so this is just the thing of data we're
putting together then we can simply do
an ax dot plot and in this case let's do
t comma t
which would be a diagonal line on a
regular chart and we'll give it a nice
color equals blue
and line width equals three let's see
what that looks like and we can see here
a spiral coming out remember this would
be just a diagonal line on a regular
chart what happens if we take this and
instead of t times 0.5 there we go
and you can see it slightly alters the
way it spirals out we can do t times two
spirals that a little quicker so it's
kind of just a fun i've like i said i've
never used a
radar chart it's a column but you can
always think of radar submarine kind of
looks like one of those or in an
airplane
and none of this would be complete if we
didn't discuss histograms oh my gosh do
i use a histogram so much
and we'll use our numpy that we have set
as np to generate oh it looks like we
have a hundred thousand variables we're
going to set equal to n and of course we
create our figure and our axes from
subplots one two figure size 12 14. so
we're going to look at two different
variations of the histogram and we'll
set a title default histogram set our
title there and then this is simply
hist for histogram and we'll just go
ahead and put in our n in there and let
me run this and see what that looks like
and let's talk about what is going on
here so we generated an array here of
data 1000 random arrays it looks like
they're mostly between -4 and 4
and then it adds up each one it says 0
you have 35 000 that are zero so that's
what's most common on here and we have
20 000 that are somewhere in this range
right here between the minus two and
well it looks like one minus two and
somewhere between zero and 1 there's 30
000 numbers so all this is saying is
this is how common these variables are
and this gives you this point in so many
directions when you're looking at data
science to go ahead and run your
histogram so you should always have your
histogram and you can always put limits
and all the other different things on
your array just like you did on the
other graphs on there and then we're
going to do a cumulative detailed
histogram
and all it is is a histogram let me just
do that
and we set cumulative equal to true
and bins equal 50. and i really want to
highlight the the cumulative equals true
is important but we can now choose how
many bins we have in the first one it
kind of selected them for us in this
case let me go ahead and run this and
you'll see it has a prints the data out
for us and here's our whoops
must have missed oh there we go it
doesn't help that i put it over the old
one there we go okay
so now you have your default histogram
and then we have a cumulative histogram
and we should have 50 steps in there and
let's just find out if that's true not
so much by counting them i'm not going
to count them if you want to you can
count them let's just change it to 10
and see what happens and we see here we
have now 10 counts of that and we could
set that for 5
and run that
and then we have our 5 on there and we
go ahead and take the cumulative equals
true out just so you can see what that
looks like and let me run that on here
too
that looks just like it did before i
think there's what one two three four
five six seven eight they have eight
different bins on here is what the
default came out of
put that back in there run
and so now it should look almost
identical and it does and then we can
put the cumulative back in see what that
looks like with the cumulative
and run that
and we can see how that shifts
everything over and has a slightly
different luck
wait it shifts at all to the right no it
doesn't actually shift it to the right
it's cumulative so it's the total of the
different occurrences and so what that
means is like if you consider this like
for the year of rainfall we have like
day one you had a little bit of rain day
two we have more rain and so if you look
at the number this is a hundred thousand
thirty five thousand so it's
accumulative detail the histogram of the
currents as it grows and rainfall is a
good one because that would be a
cumulative histogram of how much rain
occurred throughout the year and we're
going to look at two more graphs we've
already looked at a bunch of them we
looked at our radar graph we've looked
at scatter step bar fill in
basic plots we've looked at different
ways of showing the data and we can
increase the size of the line the look
the color the alpha setting
so let's look at contour maps let's put
that in there there we go draw a contour
map and before we draw a contour map
we need to go ahead and create data for
it and if you have contours your data is
all going to have three different values
so let's go ahead and create the data
here we have our you'd import your
matplot library your numpy so we have
our numbers array
we'll import matplot.cm
and that's your color maps so you have
all these different color maps you can
look at there's like hundreds of color
maps so if you don't want to do your own
color you can even do your own color map
they're pretty diverse and of course our
plt we're going to our pi plot and to
generate our different data we're going
to create a delta
0.025 and we'll start with x and we're
going to create an array between -3 and
3 and delta increments of 0.025
and we'll have our y we'll do something
similar and then we'll create our x y
into a mesh grid again these are all
numpy commands so if you're not familiar
with these you'll want to go back and
review our numpy tutorial and we'll do
an exponential on here minus x squared
minus y squared for z1 we'll do a z2 so
we have two different areas and z equals
z1 minus z2 times two
so we've created a number of values here
and let me go ahead and run this and
let's plug that in so you can see where
those values are going so once we've set
these we're going to create our figure
and our x from our plt subplots we're
going to create the variable cs and this
is going to be our contour so right here
cs is our contour surface and we're
feeding it x y and z if you remember x y
we created as our x and y components
using our mesh grid and you know what
let's do this just because it's kind of
good to see this let's go ahead and
print
x
and let's print
y and i always like to do this when i'm
working with something that's either is
really complicated in this case is what
we're looking at or you don't understand
yet so we've created a mesh grid we have
x y and when we're done with this we end
up with here's our x
and this set of values and our y so
these are x and y coordinates and then
we've also created z based on our x and
y so we have x capital x capital y and
capital z is our three components x and
y being the coordinates while z is going
to be our actual height since we're
doing a contour map so we created our
contour map from our x y and z
coordinates we want to go ahead and put
in a c label maybe we want to go ahead
and do a title on here
we'll put that in our set title and this
is a
contour there we go contour map
and let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like
and you'll see we generated a nice
little contour map there's different
settings you can play with on this but
you can picture this being you're on a
mountain climb and here we have a line
that's represent zero maybe that's sea
level and then moving on up you have
your contours of 0.5 and then minus 1
and different setups little hills i
guess if it's minus that's like a pit so
i guess you're going down into a pit at
minus 5 and -1 when on the other side
you can see you're going up in levels so
here's a mountaintop and here's like a
basin of some kind and in data science
this could represent a lot of things
this could also be representing two
different values and maybe profits and
loss i don't know if i'd ever really do
that as a contour map but i'm sure you
can be creative and find something fun
to do with a contour map and then we're
going to look at one last map which is
the 3d map and those are can be really
important as a final product because
they can show so much additional
information that you can't fit on
two-dimensional graphs
and we're going to cover the
scikit-learn tutorial which has a lot of
features and all kinds of api in it to
explore data and do your data science
with effect is probably one of the top
data science packages out there so what
is the scikit-learn it's simple and
efficient tool for data mining and data
analysis it's built on numpy scipy and
matplot library so it interfaces very
well with these other modules and it's
an open source commercially usable bsd
license bsd originally stood for
berkeley software distribution license
but it means it's open source with very
few restrictions as far as what you can
do with it another reason to really like
the scikit learn setup so you don't have
to pay for it as a commercial license
versus many other copyrighted platforms
out there what we can achieve using the
scikit-learn we use class the two main
things are classification and regression
models classification identifying which
category an object belongs to for one
application very commonly used as spam
detection so is it a spam or is it not a
spam yes no in banking it might be is
this a good loan bad loan today we'll be
looking at wine is it going to be a good
wine or a bad wine and regression is
predicting an attribute associated with
an object one example is stock prices
prediction what is going to be the next
value if the stock today sold for
23.5 cents a share what do you think
it's going to sell for tomorrow and the
next day and the next day so that would
be a regression model same thing with
weather weather forecasting any of these
are regression models where we're
looking at one specific prediction on
one attribute today we'll be doing
classification like i said we're gonna
be looking at whether a wine is good or
bad but certainly the regression model
which is in many cases more useful
because you're looking for an actual
value is also a little harder to follow
sometimes so classification is a really
good place to start we can also do
clustering and model selection
clustering is taking an automatic
grouping of similar objects into sets
customer segmentation is an example so
we have these customers like this
they'll probably also like this or if
you like this particular kind of
features on your objects maybe you like
these other objects so it's a referral
is a good one especially on amazon.com
or any of your shopping networks model
selection comparing validating and
choosing parameters and models now this
is actually a little bit deeper as far
as a site kit learn we're looking at
different models for predicting the
right course or the best course or
what's the best solution today like i
said we're looking at wine so it's going
to be how do you get the best wine out
of this so we can compare different
models and we'll look a little bit at
that and improve the model's accuracy
via different parameters and fine tuning
now this is only part one so we're not
gonna do too much tuning on the models
we're looking at but i'll point them out
as we go two other features
dimensionality reduction and
pre-processing dimensionality reduction
is we're reducing the number of random
variables to consider this increases the
model efficiency we won't touch that in
today's tutorial but be aware if you
have you know thousands of columns of
data coming in thousands of features
some of those are going to be duplicated
or some of them you can combine to form
a new column and by reducing all those
different features into a smaller amount
you can have a you can increase the
efficiency of your model it can process
faster and in some cases you'll be less
biased because if you're weighing it on
the same feature over and over again
it's going to be biased to that feature
and pre-processing these are both
pre-processing but pre-processing is
feature extraction and normalization so
we're going to be transforming input
data such as text for use with machine
learning algorithms we'll be doing a
simple scaling in this one for our
pre-processing and i'll point that out
when we get to that and we can discuss
pre-processing at that point with that
let's go ahead and roll up our sleeves
and dive in and see what we got here now
i like to use the jupiter notebook and i
use it out of the anaconda navigator so
if you install the anaconda navigator by
default it will come with the jupiter
notebook or you can install the jupiter
notebook by itself this code will work
in any of your python setups i believe
i'm running an environment of 3.7 set up
on there i'd have to go in here in
environments and look it up for the
python setup it's one of the three x's
and we go and launch this and this will
open it up in a web browser so it's kind
of nice it keeps everything separate and
in this anaconda you can actually have
different environments different
versions of python different modules
installed in each environment so it's a
very powerful tool if you're doing a lot
of development and jupiter notebook is
just a wonderful visual display
certainly you can use i know spyder is
another one which is installed with the
anaconda i actually use a simple notepad
plus plus when i'm doing some of my
python script any of your ides will work
fine jupiter notebook is iron python
because it's designed for the interface
but it's good to be aware of these
different tools
and when i launch the jupyter notebook
it'll open up like i said a web page in
here and we'll go over here to new and
create a new python setup like i said i
believe this is python37 but any of the
three this the scikit-learn works with
any of the three x's there's even two
seven versions so it's been around a
long time so it's very big on the
development side and then the
guys in the back guys and gals developed
they went ahead and put this together
for me and let's go ahead and import our
different packages now if you've been
reading some of our other tutorials
you'll recognize pandas as pd pandas
library is pretty widely used it's a
data frame setup so it's just like
columns and rows in a spreadsheet with a
lot of different features for looking
stuff up seaborne sits on top of map
plot libraries this is for our graphing
and we'll see that how quick it is to
throw a graph out there to view in the
jupiter notebook for demos and showing
people what's going on and then we're
going to use the random forest the svc
or support vector classifier and also
the neural network so we're going to
look at this we're actually going to go
through and look at three different
classifiers that are most common some of
the most common classifiers and let's
show how those work in the scikit-learn
setup and how they're different and then
if you're going to do your setup on here
you'll want to go ahead and import some
metrics so the
sklearn.metrics on here and we use the
confusion metrics and the classification
report out of that and then we're going
to use from the sklearn pre-processing
the standard scalar and label encoder
standard scalar is probably the most
commonly used pre-processing there's a
lot of different pre-processing packages
in the sklearn and then model selection
for splitting our data up it's one of
the many ways we can split data into
different sections and the last line
here is our percentage map plot library
in line some of the seaboard and matplot
library will go ahead and display
perfectly inline without this and some
won't it's good to always include this
when you're in the jupiter notebook this
is jupiter notebook so if you're in ide
when you run this it will actually open
up a new window and display the graphics
that way so you only need this if you're
running it in a editor like this one
with the specifically jupiter notebook
i'm not even familiar with other editors
that are like this but i'm sure they're
out there i'm sure there's a firefox
version or something jupiter notebook
just happens to be the most widely used
out there and we can go ahead and hit
the run button and this now has saved
all this underneath the packages so my
packages are now all loaded i've run
them whether you run it on top we run it
to the left and all the packages are up
there so we now have them all available
to us for our project we're working on
and i'm just gonna make a little side
note on that when you're playing with
these and you delete something out and
add something in even if i went back and
deleted this cell and just hit the
scissors up here these are still loaded
in this kernel so until i go under
kernel and restart or restart and clear
or restart and run all i'll still have
access to pandas
important to know because i've done that
before i've loaded up maybe not a module
here but i've loaded up my own code and
then changed my mind and wondering why
is it keep putting out the wrong output
and then i realize it's still loaded in
the kernel and you have to restart the
kernel just a quick side note for
working with a jupiter notebook and one
of the troubleshooting things that comes
up and we're going to go and load up our
data set we're using the pandas so if
you haven't yet go look at our pandas
tutorial a simple read the csv with the
separation on here let me go ahead and
run that and that's now loaded into the
variable wine and let's take a quick
look at the actual file i always like to
look at the actual data i'm working with
in this case we have wine quality dash
red i'll just open that up i have it in
my open office set up separated by
semicolons that's important to notice
and we open that up you'll see we have
go all the way down here it looks like
1600 lines of data minus the first one
so 15
1599 lines and we have a number of
features going across the last one is
quality and right off the bat we see the
quality
is uh has different numbers in it five
six seven it's not really i'm not sure
how high of a level it goes but i don't
see anything over a seven so it's kind
of five through seven is what i see here
five six and seven four five six and
seven looking to see if there's any
other values in there looking through
the demo to begin with i didn't realize
the setup on this so you can see there's
a different quality values in there
alcohol sulfates ph density total
sulfur dioxide and so on those are all
the features we're going to be looking
at
and since this is a pandas we'll just do
wine
head and that prints our first five
rolls rows of data that's of course a
pandas command and we can see that looks
very similar to what we were looking at
before we have everything across here
it's automatically assigned an index on
the left that's what pandas does if you
don't give it an index and for the
column names it has assigned the first
row so we have our first row of data
pulled off the our comma separated
variable file in this case uh semicolon
separated and it shows the different
features going across and we have what
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven features twelve
including quality but that's the one we
want to work on and understand and then
because we're in uh panda's data frame
we can also do wine dot info and let's
go ahead and run that this tells us a
lot about our variables we're working
with you'll see here that there is 1
1599 that's what i said from the
spreadsheet so that looks correct
non-null float 64. this is very
important information especially the
non-null so there's no null values in
here that can really trip us up in
pre-processing and there's a number of
ways to process non-null values one is
just to delete that data out of there so
if you have enough data in there you
might just delete your non-null values
another one is to fill that information
in with like the average or the most
common values or other such means but
we're not gonna have to worry about that
but we'll look at another way because we
can also do wine is null and sum it up
and this will give us a similar won't
tell us that these are float values but
it will give us a summation of there we
go let me run that it'll give us a
summation on here how many null values
in each one so if you wanted to you know
from here you would be able to say okay
this is a null value but it doesn't tell
you how many are null values this one
would clearly tell you that you have
maybe five null values here two null
values here and you might just if you
had only seven null values and all that
different data you'd probably just
delete them out where if ninety percent
of the data was null values you might
rethink either a different data
collection set up
or find a different way to deal with the
null values we'll talk about that just a
little bit in the models too because the
models themselves have some built-in
features especially the forest model
which we're going to look at at this
point we need to make a choice and to
keep it simple we're going to do a
little pre-processing of the data and
we're going to create some bins and bins
we're going to do is 2 comma 6.5 comma
8. what this means is that we're going
to take those values if you remember up
here let me scroll back up here we had
our quality the quality comes out
between two and eight basically or one
and eight we have five five five six you
can see just in the just in the first
five lines of variation in quality we're
going to separate that into just two
bins of quality and so we've decided to
create two bins and we have bad and good
it's going to be the labels on those two
bins we have a spread of 6.5 and an
exact index of eight the exact index is
because we're doing zero to eight on
there the six point five we can change
we could actually make this smaller or
greater but we're only looking for the
really good wine we're not looking for
the zero one two three four five
six we're looking for wines with seven
or eight on them so high quality you
know like this is what i want to put on
my dinner table at night
i might taste the good wine not the semi
good wine or mediocre wine and then this
is a panda so pd remember stands for
pandas panda's cut means we're cutting
out the wine quality and we're replacing
it and then we have our bins equals bins
that's the command bins is the actual
command and then our variable bins 2
comma 6.58 so two different bins and our
labels bad and good and we can also do
let me just do it this way wine quality
since that's what we're working on and
let's look at unique another pandas
command and we'll run this and i get
this lovely error why did i get an error
well because i replaced wine quality and
i did this cut here which changes things
on here so i literally altered one of
the variables is saved in the memory so
we'll go up here to the kernel restart
and run all that starts it from the very
beginning and we can see here that that
fixes the error because i'm not cutting
something that's already been cut we
have our wine quality unique and the
wine quality unique is a bad or good so
we have two qualities objects bad is
less than good meaning bad's going to be
zero and good's going to be one and to
make that happen we need to actually
encode it so we'll use the label quality
equals label encoder and the label
encoder let me just go back there since
this is part of sklearn that was one of
the things we imported was a label
encoder you can see that right here from
the sklearn dot processing import
standard scalar which we're going to use
in a minute and label encoder and that's
what tells it to use that equals zero
and good equals one and we'll go ahead
and run that and then we need to apply
it to the data and when we do that we
take our wine quality that we had before
and we're going to set that equal to
label quality which is our encoder and
let's look at this line right here we
have dot fit transform and you'll see
this in the pre-processing these are the
most common used is fit transform and
fit transform because they're so often
that you're also transforming the data
when you fit it they just combine them
into one command and we're just going to
take the wine quality feed it back into
there and put that back in our wine
quality setup and run that and now when
we do
the wine
and the head of the first five values
and we go ahead and run this you can see
right here underneath quality zero zero
zero i have to go down a little further
to look at the better wines
let's see if we have some that are ones
yeah there we go there's some ones down
here so when we look at 10 of them you
can see all the way down to zero or one
that's our quality and again we're
looking at high quality we're looking at
the seven and the eights or six point
five and up and uh let's go ahead and
grab our or was it here we go wine
quality let's take a look at what else
more information about the wine quality
itself and we can do a simple pandas
thing value
counts hopefully i type that in there
correctly and we can see that we only
have 217
of our wines which are going to be the
higher quality so 217 and the rest of
them fall into the bad bucket and the
zero which is uh 1382 so again we're
just looking for the top percentage of
these the top what is that it's probably
about a little a little under 20 percent
on there so we're looking for our top
wines our seven and eights and let's use
our let's plot this on a graph so we
take a look at this and the sns if you
remember correctly that is let me just
go back to the top that's our seabourn
seaborn sits on top of matplot library
it has a lot of added features plus all
the features of the matplot library and
also makes it quick and easy to put out
a graph we'll do a simple bar graph and
they actually call it count plot and
then we want to just do count plot the
wine quality so let's put our wine
quality in there and let's go ahead and
run this and see what that looks like
and nice inline remember this is why we
did the inline so make sure it appears
in here and you can see the blue space
or the first space represents low
quality wine and our second bar is a
high quality line and you can see that
we're just looking at the top quality
wine here most of the wine we want to
just give it away to the neighbors no
maybe if you don't like your neighbors
maybe give them the good quality wine
and i don't know what you do with the
bad quality wine i guess use it for
cooking there we go but you can see here
it forms a nice little graph for us with
the seaboard on there and you can see
our setup on that so now we've looked at
we've done some pre-processing we've
described our data a little bit we have
a picture of how much of the wine what
we expect it to be high quality low
quality checked out the fact that
there's none we don't have any null
values to contend with or any odd values
some of the other things you sometimes
look at these is if you have like some
values that are just way off the chart
so the measurement might be off or
miscalibrated equipment if you're in the
scientific field so the next step we
want to go ahead and do is we want to go
ahead and separate our data set or
reformat our data set and we usually use
capital x
and that denotes the features we're
working with and we usually use a
lowercase y that denotes what uh in this
case quality what we're looking for and
we can take this and go wine it's going
to be our full thing of wine dropping
what are we dropping we're dropping the
quality so these are all the features
minus quality now make sure we have our
axes equals one if you left it out it
would still come out correctly just
because of the way it processes on the
defaults and then our y if we're going
to remove quality for our x that's just
going to be one and it is just the
quality that we're looking at for y so
we put that in there and we'll go ahead
and run this so now we've separated the
features that we want to use to predict
the quality of the wine and the quality
itself the next step is if you're going
to create a data set in a model we got
to know how good our model is so we're
going to split the data train and test
splitting data and this is one of the
packages we imported from sklearn and
the actual package was train test split
and we're going to do x y test size 0.2
random state 42. and this returns four
variables and most common you'll see is
capital x train so we're going to train
our set with capital x test that's the
data we're going to keep on the side to
test it with y train y remember stands
for the quality or the answer we're
looking for so when we train it we're
going to use x train and y train and
then y test to see how good our x test
does and the train test split let me
just go back up to the top that was part
of the sklearn model selection import
train test split there is a lot of ways
to split data up this is when you're
first starting you do your first model
you probably start with the basics on
here you have one test for training one
for test our test size is point two or
twenty percent and random state just
means we just start with a it's like a
random seed number so it's not too
important back there we're randomly
selecting which ones we're going to use
since this is the most common way this
is what we're going to use today there
is and it's not even an sklearn package
yet so someone's still putting it in
there one of the new things they do is
they split the data into thirds and then
they'll run the model on each of they
combine each of those thirds into two
thirds for training and one for testing
and so you actually go through all the
data and you come up with three
different test results from it which is
pretty cool that's a pretty cool way of
doing it you could actually do that with
this by just splitting this into thirds
and then or you have a test size one
test set third and then split the
training set also into thirds and also
do that and get three different data
sets this works fine for most projects
especially when you're starting out it
works great so we have our x train our x
test our y train and our y test and then
we need to go ahead and do the scaler
and let's talk about this because this
is really important some models do not
need to have scaling going on most
models do and so we create our scalar
variable we'll call it sc standard
scalar
and if you remember correctly we
imported that here wrong with the label
encoder the standard scalar setup so
there's our scalar and this is going to
convert the values instead of having
some values that go from zero if you
remember up here we had some values are
54 60 40 59 102. so our total sulfur
dioxide would have these huge values
coming into our model and some models
would look at that and they'd become
very biased to sulfur dioxide it'd have
the hugest impact and then a value that
had
0.076.098 or chlorides would have very
little impact because it's such a small
number so we take the scalar we kind of
level the playing field and depending on
our scalar it sets it up between 0 and 1
a lot of times is what it does let's go
ahead and take a look at that and we'll
go ahead and start with our x train and
our x train equals sc fit transform we
talked about that earlier that's an
sklearn setup it's going to both fit and
transform our x train into our x train
variable and if we have an x train we
also need to do that to our test and
this is important because you need to
note that you don't want to refit the
data we want to use the same fit we used
on the training is on the testing
otherwise you get different results and
so we'll do just oops not fit
transform we're only going to transform
the test side of the data so here's our
x test that we want to transform and
let's go ahead and run that and just so
we have an idea let's go ahead and take
and just print out our x train oh let's
do uh first 10 variables very similar to
the way you do with the head on a data
frame you can see here our variables are
now much more uniform and they've scaled
them to the same scale so they're
between certain numbers and with the
basic scalar you can fine tune it i just
let it do its defaults on this and
that's fine for what we're doing in most
cases you don't really need to mess with
it too much it does look like it goes
between like minus probably minus 2 to 2
or something like that that's just
looking at the train variable i'll go
ahead and cut that one out of there so
before we actually build the models and
start discussing the sk-learn models
we're going to use we covered a lot of
ground here most of when you're working
with these models you put a lot of work
into pre-prepping the data so we looked
at the data notice that it's separated
loaded it up we went in there we found
out there's no null values that's hard
to say no no no values we have there's
none there's none nobody i can't say it
and of course we sum it up if you had a
lot of null values this would be really
important coming in here so is there a
null summary we looked at pre-processing
the data as far as the quality and we're
looking at the bins so this would be
something you might start playing with
maybe you don't want super fine wine you
don't want the seven and eights maybe
you want to split this differently so
certainly you can play with the bins and
get different values and make the bins
smaller or lean more towards the lower
quality so you then have like medium to
high quality and we went ahead and gave
it labels again this is all pandas we're
doing in here setting up with unique
labels and group names bad good bad is
less than good that could be so
important you don't know how many times
people go through these models and they
have them reversed or something and then
they go back they're like why is this
data not looking correct so it's
important to remember what you're doing
up here and double check it and we used
our label encoder so that was
to set that up as quality01 good in this
case we have bad good zero one and we
just double check that to make sure
that's what came up in the quality there
and we threw it into a graph because
people like to see graphs i don't know
about you but you start looking all
these numbers and all this text and you
get down here and you say oh yes you
know here this is how much of the wine
we're going to label as subpar not good
this is how much we're going to label as
good and then we go down here to finally
separating out our data so it's ready to
go into the models and the models take x
and a y in this case x is all of our
features minus the one we're looking for
and then y is the features we're looking
for so in this case we dropped quality
and in the y case we added quality and
then because we need to have a training
set and a test set so we can see how
good our models do we went ahead and
split the models up x train x test y
train y test and that's using the train
test split which is part of the sklearn
package and we did as far as our testing
size point two or twenty percent the
default is twenty five percent so if you
leave that out it'll do default setup
and we did a random state equals forty
two if you leave that out it'll use a
random state i believe it's default one
i'd have to look that back up and then
finally we scaled the data this is so
important to scale the data going back
up to here if you have something that's
coming out as a hundred is going to
really outweigh something that's 0.071
that's not in all the models different
models handle it differently and as we
look at the different models i'll talk a
little bit about that we're going to
look at three models today three the top
models used for this and see how they
compare and how the numbers come out
between them so we're going to look at
three different setups let me change my
cell here to mark down there we go and
we're going to start with the random
forest classifier so the three sets
we're looking at is the random forest
classifier support vector classifier and
then a neural network now we start with
the random forest classifier because it
has the least amount of
parts moving parts to fine-tune and
let's go ahead and put this in here so
we're going to call it rfc for random
force classifier and if you remember we
imported that so let me go back up here
to the top real quick and we did an
import of the random fourth classifier
from sk learn ensemble and then we'll
all we also let me just point this out
here's our svm where we imported our
support vector classifier so svm is
support vector model support vector
classifier and then we also have our
neural network and we're going to from
there the multi-layered
perceptron classifier kind of a mouthful
for the p perceptron don't worry too
much about that name it's just it's a
neural network there's a lot of
different options on there and setups
which is where they came up with the
perceptron but so we have our three
different models we're going to go
through on here and then we're going to
weigh them here's our metrics we're
going to use a confusion metrics also
from the sk learn package to see how
good our model does
with our split so let's go back down
there and take a look at that
and we have our rfs equals random forest
classifier and we have n estimators
equals 200. this is the only value you
play with with a random forest
classifier how many forests do you need
or how many trees in the forest so how
many models are in here that makes it
pretty good as a startup model because
we're only playing with one number and
it's pretty clear what it is and you can
lower this number or raise it usually
start up with a higher number and then
bring it down to see if it keeps the
same value so you have less you know the
smaller the model the better the fit and
it's easier to send out to somebody else
if you're going to distribute it now the
random forest classifier
everything i read says it's used for
kind of a medium-sized data set so you
can run it in on big data you can run it
on smaller data obviously but tends to
work best in the mid-range and we'll go
ahead and take our rfc
and i just copied this from the other
side dot fit x train comma y train so
we're sending it our features and then
the quality in the y train what we want
to predict in there and we just do a
simple fit now remember this is sk learn
so everything is fit or transform
another one is predict which we'll do in
just a second here let's do that now
predict
rfc equals and it's our rfc model
predict and what are we predicting on
well we trained it with our train values
so now we need our test our x test so
this has done it this is going to do
this is the three lines of code we need
to create our random force variable fit
our training data to it so we're
programming it to fit in this case it's
got 200 different trees it's going to
build and then we're going to predict on
here let me go ahead and just run that
and we can actually do something like oh
let's do predict rf
c just real quick we'll look at the
first 20 variables of it let's go ahead
and run that and in our first 20
variables we have three winds that make
the cut and the other 17 don't so the
other 17 are bad quality and three of
them are good quality in our predicted
values and if you remember correctly
we'll go ahead and take this out of here
this is based on our test so these are
the first 20 values in our test and this
has as you can see all the different
features listed in there and they've
been scaled so when you look at these
they're a little bit confusing to look
at and hard to read but we have there's
a minus 01 so this is 0.36 minus 01 so
0.164 minus 0.09
or no it's still minus 1. so minus 0.9
all between 0 and 1 on here i think i
was confused earlier and i said 0
between 2 negative 2. but between -1 and
1 which is what it should be in the
scale and we'll go ahead and just cut
that out of there run this we have our
setup on here so now we've run the
prediction and we have predicted values
well one you could publish them but what
do we do with them what we want to do
with them is we want to see how where
our model model performed that's the
whole reason for splitting it between a
training and testing model and for that
remember we imported the classification
report
that was again from the sk learn there's
our confusion matrix and classification
report and the classification report
actually sits on the confusion matrix so
it uses that information and our
classification report we want to know
how good are y tests that's the actual
values versus our predicted rfc so we'll
go ahead and print this report out and
let's take a look and we can see here we
have a precision out of the zero we had
about .92 that were labeled as bad that
were actually bad and out of precision
for the quality wines we're running
about 78 percent so you kind of give us
an overall 90 percent and you can see
our f1 score our support setup on there
our recall you could also do the
confusion matrix on here which gives you
a little bit more information but for
this this is going to be good enough for
right now we're just going to look at
how good this model was because we want
to compare the random fourth classifier
with the other two models and you know
what let's go ahead and put in the
confusion matrix just so you can see
that on there with y test and prediction
rfc so in the confusion matrix we can
see here that we had
266 correct and seven wrong these are
the missed labels for bad wine and we
had a lot of missed labels for good wine
so our quality labels aren't that good
we're good at predicting bad wine not so
good at predicting whether it's a good
quality wine important to note on there
so that is our basic random forest
classifier and let me go ahead upsell
and change cell type to markdown and run
that so we have a nice label let's look
at our svm classifier our support vector
model and this should look familiar we
have our clf we're going to create
what's we'll call it just like we call
this an rfc and then we'll have our clf
dot fit and this should be identical to
up above x train comma y train and uh
just like we did before let's go ahead
and do the prediction and here is our
clf predict and it's going to equal the
clf dot predict and we want to go ahead
and use x underscore test and right
about now you can realize that you can
create these different models and
actually just create a loop to go
through your different models and put
the data in and that's how they designed
it they designed it to have that ability
let's go ahead and run this and then
let's go ahead and do our classification
report and i'm just going to copy this
right off of here
they say you shouldn't copy and paste
your code and the reason is is when you
go in here and edit it
you unbearably will miss something we
only have two lines so i think i'm safe
to do it today and let's go ahead and
run this
and let's take a look how the svm
classifier came out so up here we had a
90 percent and down here we're running
about an 86
so it's not doing as good now remember
we randomly split the data so if i run
this a bunch of times you'll see some
changes down here so these numbers this
size of data if i read it 100 times it
would probably be within plus or minus
three or four on here in fact if i ran
this 100 times you'd probably see these
come out almost the same as far as how
well they do in classification and then
on the confusion matrix let's take a
look at this one this had 22 by 25 this
one has 35 by 12. so it's it's doing not
quite as good that shows up here 71
percent versus 78 percent and then if
we're going to do a svm classifier we
also want to show you one more and
before i do that kind of tease you a
little bit here before we jump into
neural networks the big save all deep
learning because everything else must be
shallow learning that's a joke let's
just talk a little bit about the svm
versus the random forest classifier the
svm tends to work better on smaller
numbers
it also works really good on
a lot of times you convert things into
numbers and bins and things like that
the random forest tends to do better
with those at least that's my brief
experience with it where if you have
just a lot of raw data coming in the svm
is usually the fastest and easiest to
apply model on there so they've each
have their own benefits you'll find
though again that when you run these
like 100 times difference between these
two on a data set like this is going to
just go away there's randomness involved
depending on which data we took and how
they classify them the big one is the
neural networks and this is what makes
the neural networks nice is they can do
they can look into huge amounts of data
so for a project like this you probably
don't need a neural network on this but
it's important to see how they work
differently and how they come up
differently so you can work with huge
amounts of data you can also many
respects they work really good with text
analysis especially if it's time
sensitive more and more you have an
order of text and they've just come out
with different ways of feeding that data
in where the series in the order of the
words is really important same thing
with uh starting to predict in the stock
market if you have tons of data coming
in from different sources the neural
network can really process that in a
powerful way to pull up things that
aren't seen before when i say lots of
data coming in i'm not talking about
just the high lows that you can run an
svm on real easily i'm talking about the
data that comes in where you have maybe
you pulled off the twitter feeds and
have word counts going on and you've
pulled off the
the different news feeds that business
are looking at and the different
releases when they release the different
reports so you have all this different
data coming in and the neural network
does really good with that pictures
picture processing now is really moving
heavily into the neural network if you
have a pixel 2 or pixel 3 phone put out
by google it has a neural network for
doing it's kind of goofy but you can put
little star wars androids dancing around
your pictures and things like that
that's all done with the neural network
so it has a lot of different uses but
it's also requires a lot of data and is
a little heavy-handed for something like
this and this should now look familiar
because we've done it twice before we
have our multi-layered perceptron
classifier we'll call it an mlpc and
it's this is what we imported mlpc
classifier there's a lot of settings in
here the first one is the hidden layers
you have to have the hidden layers in
there we're going to do three layers of
11 each so that's how many nodes are in
each layer as it comes in and that was
based on the fact we have 11 features
coming in then i went ahead and just did
three layers probably get by with a lot
less on this but yeah i didn't want to
sit and play with it all afternoon again
this is one of those things you play
with a lot because the more hidden
layers you have the more resources
you're using you can also run into
problems with overfitting with too many
layers and you also have to run higher
iterations the max iteration we have is
set to 500 the default's 200 because i
use three layers of 11 each which is by
the way kind of a default i use i
realized that usually you have about
three layers going down and the number
of features going across you'll see
that's pretty common for the first
classifier when you're working in neural
networks but it also means you have to
do higher iterations so we up the
iterations to 500 so that means it's
going through the data 500 times to
program those different layers and
carefully adjust them and we do have a
full tutorials you can go look up on
neural networks and understand the
neural network settings a lot more and
of course we have you're looking over
here where we had our previous model
where we fit it same thing here mlpc fit
x train y train and then we're going to
create our prediction so let's do our
predict and mlpc and it's going to equal
the mlpc and we'll just take the same
thing here predict x test let's just put
that down here dot predict test and if i
run that we've now programmed it we now
have our prediction here same as before
and we'll go ahead and do the copy print
again always be careful with the copy
paste now because you always run the the
chance of missing one of these variables
so if you're doing a lot of coding you
might want to skip that copy and paste
and just type it in and let's go ahead
and run this and see what that looks
like and we came up with an 88
we're going to compare that with the 86
from our tree our svm classifier and our
90 from the random forest classifier and
keep in mind random forest classifiers
they do good on mid-sized data the svm
on smaller amounts of data although to
be honest i don't think that's
necessarily the split between the two
and these things will actually come
together if you random a number of times
and we can see down here the noun of
good wines mislabeled with the
setup on there it's on par with our
random forest so it had 22.25 shouldn't
be a surprise it's identical it just
didn't do as good with the bad wines
labeling what's a bad one and what's not
see yeah because they had 266 and 7. we
had down here 260 and 13. so mislabeled
a couple of bad wines as good wines so
we've explored three of these basic
classifiers these are probably the three
most widely used right now i might even
throw in the random tree
if we open up their website we go under
supervised learning there's a linear
model we didn't do that almost most of
data usually just start with a linear
model because it's going to process the
quickest and use the least amount of
resources but you can see they have
linear quadratic they have kernel ridge
there's our support vector stochastic
gradient nearest neighbors nearest
neighbors is another common one that's
used a lot very similar to the svm
gaussian process cross decomposition
naive bayes this is more of an
intellectual one that i don't see used a
lot but it's like the basis of a lot of
other things decision tree there's
another one that's used a lot ensemble
methods not as much multi-class and
multi-label algorithms feature selection
neural networks that's the other one we
use down here and of course the forest
so you can see there's a in sk learn
there are so many different options and
they've just developed them over the
years we covered three of the most
commonly used ones in here and went over
a little bit over why they're different
neural network just because it's fun to
work in deep learning and not in shallow
learning as i told you that doesn't mean
that the svm is actually shallow it does
a lot of it covers a lot of things and
same thing with the decision for the
random forest classifier and we notice
that there's a number of other different
classifier options in there these are
just the three most common ones and i'd
probably throw the nearest neighbor in
there and the decision tree which is
usually part of the decision for us
depending on what the back end you're
using and since as human beings if i was
in the shareholder's office i wouldn't
want to leave them with a confusion
matrix they need that information for
making decisions but we want to give
them just one particular score and so i
would go ahead and we have our sklearn
metrics we're going to import the
accuracy score and i'm just going to do
this on the
random forest since that was our best
model and we have our cm accuracy score
and i forgot to print it remember in
jupyter notebook we can just do the last
variable we leave out there will print
and so our cm accurate score we get is
and that matches up here we should
already see that up here in precision so
you can either quote that but a lot of
times people like to see it highlighted
at the very end this is our precision on
this model and then the final stage is
we would like to use this for future so
let's go ahead and take our wine if you
remember correctly we'll do one head of
10. we'll run that remember our original
data set we've gone through so many
steps now we're going to go back to the
original data and we can see here we
have our top 10 our top 10 on the list
only two of them make it as having high
enough quality wine for us to be
interested in them and then let's go
ahead and create some data here we'll
call it x new equals and this is
important this data has to be we just
kind of randomly selected some data
looks an awful lot like some of the
other numbers on here which is what it
should look like and so we have our x
new equals 7.3.58
and so on and then it is so important
this is where people forget this step x
new
equals sc remember sc that was our
standard scalar variable we created if
we go right back up here before we did
anything else we created an sc we fit it
and we transformed it and then we need
to do what transform the data we're
going to feed in
so we're going to go back down here and
we're going to transform our x new and
then we're going to go ahead and use the
where are we at here we go our random
forest and if you remember all it is is
our rfc predict model right there let's
go ahead and just grab that down here
and so our y
new equals here's our rfc predict and we
do our x new in and then it's kind of
nice to know what it actually puts out
so according to this it should print out
what our prediction is for this wine and
oh it's a bad wine okay so we didn't
pick out a good wine for our ex new and
that should be expected most of wine if
you remember correctly only a small
percentage of the wine met our quality
requirements so we can look at this and
say oh we'll have to try another wine
out which is fine by me because i like
to try out new wines and i certainly
have a collection of old wine bottles
and very few of them match but you can
see here we've gone through the whole
process just a quick re rehash we had
our imports we touched a lot on the sk
learn our random forest our svm and our
mlp classifier so we had our support
vector classifier we had our random
forests and we have our neural network
three of the top used classifiers in the
sk learn system and we also have our
confusion metric matrix and our
classification report which we used our
standard scalar for scaling it and our
label encoder and of course we needed to
go ahead and split our data up in our
implot line train and we explored the
data in here for null values we set up
our quality into bins
we took a look at the data and what we
actually have and put a nice little plot
to show our quality what we're looking
at and then we went through our three
different models and it's always
interesting because you spend so much
time getting to these models and then
you kind of go through the models and
play with them until you get the best
training on there without becoming
biased that's always a challenge is to
not over train your data to the point
where you're training it to fit the test
value and finally we went ahead and
actually used it and applied it to
a new wine which unfortunately didn't
make the cut it's going to be the one
that we drink a glass out of and save
the rest from cooking certainly there
are many reasons to be able to go online
and scrape different websites they
arrange everything from pulling out
different links
to pulling data off of websites as a
data scientist you might need to get
some information off a website that
doesn't have a direct api to pull that
information and in python we have a
wonderful tool when you talk python and
you talk web scraping we're talking
beautiful suit which is a package you
add into your python that you're running
and we can come over here to the website
www.crummy.com
software slash beautiful soup you can
actually read a little bit about it
currently beautiful soup 4 is the
current version if you don't remember
the full website for it you can always
do what i do which is go over and do a
search for beautiful soup official site
it almost always comes up right at the
top and you click on there and it'll
take you to the crummy.com software site
for beautiful soup now we're going to
use our whatever python interface you
want ide i'm going to use jupiter lab
which is built on jupiter notebook
through anaconda so when i open up my
anaconda navigator you'll see that i
have my different tools available again
you might be using a different editor
and that's okay you might be in pycharm
or something like that we don't need to
do this and
jupiter lab is jupiter notebook with
added tabs and some added features it's
basically in beta testing so it's got a
few little glitches when you're saving
things and moving between projects but
for the most part it's a great upgrade
to the jupiter notebook and you can use
them together so you don't have to i
mean it's built on jupiter notebooks
anything you do in jupiter notebook you
can open up in jupiter lab and the first
thing we need to do is we need to go
ahead in this case i'm going under my
environments since it partitions the
environments out and i'm going to open
up a terminal window we have to install
some packages in here to work with now
there's a lot of choices on this i
because of the simplicity we'll be using
conda install now you can use pip
install for the same thing and we're
going to install our beautiful soup four
and you have to type out the whole thing
beautiful soup for and you can use a pip
install if you're using a different
environment and i am using python
version
3.6 although according to beautiful soup
they also work on three seven all the
way from two seven through olive 3x now
according to the beautiful soup website
the beautiful soup 4 works on anything
you can install anything from python 2 7
all the way through any of the python 3
versions this just happens to be python
36 because i do there's a lot of other
packages that don't work on 3.7 yet and
we'll go ahead and run this install on
here and let it go through its
environmental setup and of course with
conda it goes in there and finds all the
dependencies pip doesn't do as much as
far as finding dependencies but you know
exactly what's on there with pip so if
you're doing a huge distribution you
probably want to use your pip install so
you can track what's going on there with
the
conda i like to just let it take over
since this isn't a major distributed
package going out another quick note
between pip and conda is that if you
start on a project in one of these
environments and you're using pip in
there stick with pip if you're using
conda stick with conda they track the
packages and you can run into some
issues where they're not tracking the
same packages and something gets
overwritten so it's important to stay
very consistent with your install on
your environments and we'll also need to
go ahead and install our numpy
environment and our pandas on here so go
ahead and do that if you haven't added
those packages in go ahead and install
those into your environment that you're
working in and of course pandas is just
simply uh install pandas and let's just
install a couple more packages in this
case let's get our install our map plot
library because we're going to plot at
the end since we're going to be
collecting data and for this project
that will be all the packages we'll need
so we can go and close out of our
installer or whatever setup you have and
we'll go back to home and we'll just
launch our jupyter lab and that will
open up in our browser window now if you
are coming from jupiter notebooks and
first time in lab we can go ahead and
just create our first notebook python3
you can also do it under a file launcher
and you'll see new notebook it
automatically opens up and we just click
right on there it'll pop open on the
left and i'll right click this and we'll
rename this we'll rename it just
beautiful and it is a i
n b file on there so that should look
familiar because that's the jupiter
notebook file this is a new one now i
have mults in the past i usually hid
this on the other computer all my notes
for the lesson today but this is my
notes going down and we'll go ahead and
just start going through this and see
what it looks like to do a data poll
from front to end and see how that works
as a data scientist pulling that
information in from the website and the
first thing i want to do is i want to go
ahead and close this side window that
way it looks get the nice full screen
and we can also up the size a little bit
one of the wonderful things about
working in a browser window just do that
control plus thing the packages we
talked about is pandas so we imported
our pandas if you haven't already that's
our data frame if you haven't done our
pandas tutorial definitely worthy of the
time to go through there and understand
pandas it's such a powerful tool this
basically turns your data into a
spreadsheet data frame our numpy is our
number array so it kind of works with
pandas very closely as far as
manipulating data in arrays matplot we
want to go ahead and bring that in our
plt so that we can plot the data at the
end and this line right here that says
matplot library inline is for the
jupiter notebook specifically it tells
it to print that on this page a lot of
the newer versions don't actually
require to have that line they'll still
print it on the page but you should
still include that if you're in the
jupiter lab setup and then we have our
url library.request we're going to
import url open for opening up the
website and then we have our bs4 that's
your beautiful soup 4. we're going to
import beautiful soup and then our last
one is our re that is for manipulating
our regular expressions so when we get
to that part of importing our data we
have to do a lot of reformatting so it's
something we can use and the re is one
of those tools we'll go ahead and run
this and just bring all that in so this
is all imported all these packages are
now into our web scraping program we're
going to run now if we're going to dive
in and pull data which you have a nice
website to pull from and let's go ahead
and we'll use the
upper timing.com results for the 2018
martin luther king race and if we take
this you can actually just take this
where did we get this from well you can
go in here and find the website you're
going to scrape from and you'll see
right here it says you just copy that
link right in there that http and this
is the website that we're looking at you
can see right here all the information
that we're looking at let's say we
wanted to run some statistics on this it
sure would be nice to be able to pull it
off of here and if they don't have a
direct api that means we need to pull it
from their website some of these will
have a download although if you've ever
done we have a download click and maybe
you're paging through a hundred websites
uh in one case i was uh pulling all the
different united states bills that are
passed to track who voted on them for a
project and you can imagine that there's
you know hundreds and hundreds of those
thousands of these documents that they
voted on who voted on it it goes through
the senate goes back to the congress so
i opened up a website pull all the links
off of there that match a certain
criteria and we'll look at that in just
a minute how we go through the html and
then i had to reformat them or i could
hand download each one one at a time
which would just be a nightmare so it's
nice to automate it in this case we're
going to be pulling up this chart we
want to figure out how to pull this
chart off of this website and so we go
back into our jupiter notebook i've got
my url just our name for it and it's
just a string that's all this is nothing
fancy there you'll notice that on the
slashes we now have forward forward
slash you can do a single forward and
hdp is a double forward this is just how
you have to switch it to match setup in
there and then it's going to go ahead
and use the html equals url open url and
that's from our url library request so
it's opening a link to that website or
at least pointing to it and if we run
this this just sets it up so this is all
set up and then once we've done our
setup let's go ahead and create an
object called soup this will be and if
you remember up here here's our
beautiful soup that we imported from the
bs4 and this is the package that we're
working with and so we're going to do
our beautiful soup on here and on this
we need to go ahead and send it our html
so it knows what it's opening and then
the second part is we have to tell it
how the format is coming in and the most
common one for your html polls is an
lxml
setup and so almost all of them you'll
end up using the lxml there's a few
other options and because this is so
common in the newer versions a lot of
times they just leave it out just
because it's already on the default
we'll go ahead and leave it in here just
to remind us that it's there we'll go
ahead and run that and on the newer
versions uh they actually default it to
the xml setup in the html we'll just
leave it out and call it html so it's
just going to pull from this url and
when we run that on here we've now
created an object soup that has pulled
the website into it so soup contains the
information along with information on
that website and what's going on so
let's just go over what we did real
quick before we start digging into the
actual soup before we start scooping out
stuff we imported our different
modules that we're going to use with our
package specifically the beautiful soup
we did install the beautiful soup if you
remember correctly you have to call it
beautiful soup 4 specifically so it
knows what you're bringing in and this
line right here is very key from bs4
because that's how it installs the
module we're importing our beautiful
soup and then we found our url in this
case we're going to go pull information
from the martin luther king dream run
and then we set our html to our url open
url and you can see right here we
imported that so here's our url dot
request import url open so we're
requesting a connection and once we send
that connection into the beautiful soup
it creates an object called soup and
then this one of course we chose soup
just because it goes with beautiful soup
i guess we could have chosen beautiful
and now we can start extracting
information from our website because we
pulled it down onto our computer under
soup now we can start by looking at the
title of the website soup dot title and
if we print title dot text you'll see
this a lot in beautiful suit because
title contains all kinds of information
and if we want just the text from that
title you add the dot text on the end
and you can see right here we have our
2018 mlk dream run 5k race results if
you look at the tab that's the actual
title up here 2018 mlk dream run 5k race
that's what the title is on the website
and then you might be curious what's in
title what's the whole title that it's
storing up there well let's go ahead and
print it out here's print title and
print title.txt and we run that you can
see it has the html tags title on it and
then the forward slash title to end it
and so we're really just pulling off
this piece of the html code and then we
look at the text inside that particular
part of the html and earlier i mentioned
links what if you want to get all the
links off this page oh that would be fun
uh we could do soup dot and we'll do
find underscore all put this in bracket
and then quotation marks we're going to
put a a is the
key find and you'll start seeing a div
and all the different options you have
for finding these entities in a website
and then let's go ahead and just print
our links and you can see here that it
now shows all the different links in
here that are marked by eggs we did a
find all a and then we can also because
this is a little bit hard to pull off
the h reference so we can also add in
our find all fine-tune that in this case
the h reference equals true we'll
actually filter that out and then
finally we might do a four link in links
and we can simply do something like this
for each link we want to actually find
the h reference because we know there's
an h reference in it and if i run this
you can see it just comes through and
prints them out one at a time some of
these are really useful so you might be
looking for something that has https in
it and you know that's a link running to
something else or you might be looking
for the mail to tags you know that's all
the mail addresses but either way you
can easily find all the links in your
html document that you're paging through
and of course
any packages that have evolved over time
you can also do link dot get h reference
which should do the same thing as our
other format and you can see it
certainly does we get the same printout
up here in this particular case we
really want to get the data off the page
uh so let's go ahead and do that let's
see what that looks like and in data
let's call it all rows there we go
equals and then we have our soup dot
find underscore all there's our brackets
and then if we're looking for each row
in a database you'll remember your html
code we're looking for the tag tr so we
want to find all tr and we can take this
and let's go ahead and just take all our
rows and do a print all rows and about
this time you're going to guess that
we're going to get a huge amount of
information just dumped onto our page
and sure enough we do if you look at
this it just kind of goes on forever but
this is an array each row is considered
an array so because of that we can do
something simply as putting brackets and
just print the first let's do the first
five rows so from beginning to five and
you can see here's our first five rows
on here i sometimes like to just do
let's just do row zero and we see that
row zero is finishers finishers 191 and
just out of curiosity what's if that's
zero what's row one male okay so we're
starting to see titles going across here
so if we come up here and we do rows we
did what up to 10. let's just take a
look and see what 10 does again and just
take a look at that information that
comes across place
bib name gender age city state chip chip
pace gender and so on so it comes all
the way down here we kind of have an
ending right here and then we have one
and then we actually it looks like we
start to have information so we have our
one or one 1191 max randolph that must
be the name male 29 and so on and start
seeing how the information starts
getting displayed going down so the next
thing we want to do with this i'll go
back up here and just edit the space
we're in so it starts to make a little
bit more sense keep it all together and
so we want to do for each row in all
rows we're looking at what information
are we looking at well we have our th up
here that's a header our td down here
which looks like the individual
information and we really are looking
for
the actual data so we're looking for td
tags in the rows and we can do that
because when you remember when it stores
the row it also stores the tags
underneath that so all rows have all the
different tags in it and you can see
right here as we print each one of those
out and so we look at each row we can
create another variable we'll call it
row list and we'll set this equal to in
this case row because we've already
pulled all the rows out of soup so now
we want to find for each row and in
there we want to find our td and if we
go ahead and just print i'm going to do
it if you notice i changed the indent so
i'm just going to print row list what
this does is the last value to go into
row list our last row is going to print
now and of course make sure you have an
underscore instead of a period when
you're typing so row.find underscore all
td and if we print the last row you can
see i have all the data coming across
here we have our 191 our 1216 zuma ochoa
i hope i said that right female i
believe that's age 40 and so on and then
we can take our row list and there's a
lot of things we can do with the row
list what we'll do for let's do object
or let's just do cell in row list and so
we're going to look at each cell because
this is if you look at this they have
commas separated between the different
objects and then we're going to go ahead
and print cell dot text let's just take
a look and see what that looks like and
we can see here for each row we get 191
there's our 191 there's our 12 16 12 16
our
individual who's in the race and so
forth all the way down for those
different settings let's go ahead and
create a new variable up here uh we'll
call this all let's just call it data
we'll keep it simple uh so here's our
data and then we have our row we take
our row we break it up into individual
cells so we'll call this data row and
we'll set this empty to an empty row and
we're going to take our
cells tab this we know that each cell
generates a text and so what we want to
do is i want to take my data row let's
just replace that let's take our data
row and let's append our cell dot text
so i'm going to add the each row is
going to be a row of the different text
on here and then once i create each row
i want my data which is going to be
everything to append each row and here's
our data row and then if we go ahead and
come down here and let's just print data
now if we were lurking with large data
we'd be very careful about just throwing
all our data on the page but you can see
here we throw the date on the page and
we get finishers 199 male 78 female 113
one and so on and if you look at this
this is the headers on the file we have
finishers
male females just like some general
statistics on the first one and then we
have actually
an empty data set and then we have our
data that continues which actually the
actual information we're looking for so
we have one 1191 max randolph mill 29
washington dc run time uh one of 78 and
so on on here so we could really quickly
get rid of that number of different ways
to do that one of them is just to do
we're going to set we do data two on uh
we should get rid of everything but we
want to keep randolph so make sure
randolph is in there oh we lost randolph
let's try one on there we go there's max
randolph on there uh so we can just
simply do redo our date on here and we
can do data probably want to do it in
all rows from one on but i'm just going
to do my data equals data one on down
here and there's reasons to split it
this way in data science sometimes you
don't want to touch the original data in
case you need it in case we do need the
first row so we'll put it down here and
uh maybe we'll just call this titles
titles equals data of zero and so we
could do something here where we print
we'll print up our titles and we'll
print our data in this case instead of
one on let's go minus
two let's look at the last two rows of
data so here we have our titles and for
some reason just put in finishers of 191
as expecting a little bit more up there
and we have our last couple people and
they look like the data on these looks
just fine on here turns out this is just
some generic statistics up here so we'll
get rid of titles completely doesn't
really do us any good but we know that
data comes in here and we can look at
our data and look at the very end of the
data too the minus two to the end and we
can see it pulls the data in pretty good
we don't have anything too funky in here
we're looking at it looks pretty clean
now you got to be a little careful
because at some point we might have to
come back here and clean up the data if
we get an error for running data
analysis we might find out there's some
unusual characters or something is
missed in the data itself and you also
notice that everything is a string so
when we're bringing it in we might have
to do some conversions to test it out
and convert them to whatever kind of
data format we're working with so at
this time we want to go ahead and bring
in our pandas um and let's go ahead and
call this idea for data frame we'll set
it equal to and if you remember
correctly we imported pandas as pd and
that's standard you'll see that in most
code examples where they call the import
pandas as pd
and it is capital d
capital f for data frame and we're just
going to bring in our data that's what
we called it on here and let's uh take
this and we'll print now when you're
working with data frames you're usually
talking large amounts of data and so you
almost never want to print the whole
data frame out we're going to go ahead
and do that anyway just so we can see
what that looks like and you can see in
here brings in our data frame coming in
here we just have a mess of information
this is our data let's go ahead and
print df and see what that looks like in
the data frame and this is nice because
it organizes it into a very easy to read
table and we have they set the label 0 1
2 3 4 5 six and so on and then we have
each row uh we have mel
none going across when we get all the
way down here we'll see max randall
about number three and the first thing
this does is this flags me that i
brought in a bunch of information up
here that we really didn't want it's
from 3 on that we want and we can clean
this up in one of two ways we can try to
clean it up under the data or we can
clean it up under the data frame
depending on what it is we're trying to
do and so to fix this um i want to go
ahead and just change it up here in the
actual data pull in we don't need that
information so i'll rerun it reload our
data from for on and then when i run
this we see we have max randolph is
right at the top of the list like he
should be and we have all the data going
down now with the data frame remember i
said we don't usually print the whole
data frame we'll go ahead and do df.head
and this prints the first five rows and
you can see that we have 13 columns
here's max randall all the way to theo
kinman and i usually also print df
tail and the reason i like to do these
particular two setups i'm going to
change it just to two rows because you
can do that you can put as many rows as
you want is this good to look at the
first part and the end because those are
usually where you have extra data
brought in something's messed up and you
can also see that we have 190 rows in
here and it comes in with our zuma lisha
and they're both on here on the list so
now we have a nice data frame columns
and rows we can easily look at it we can
see the setup on here and we can look at
the names and everything now at some
point you might be looking at these
individual columns and find different
information that needs to be re-edited
if you can you try to do it with the
whole column under pandas you can up in
the upper part of the code where you
went from cell to cell or row to row you
can look at individual cells maybe find
a marker in that cell that's something
specific like remove all colons or
semicolons or something and there are
brackets so there's a lot of options in
there but you'll find that this one
actually comes in pretty clean on here
all the way down and the next thing we
really want to do is we want to look at
the headers i don't know about you but
doesn't make any sense to me when i have
column one i don't know what 1191 is or
1080 need name kaiser runner i'm
guessing that's column two is names
third one looks like male or female
probably age but i don't want to guess i
want this to bring in my column so i
know exactly what i'm looking at so how
can we make beautiful soup do that for
us well let's take our column headers
we're going to set that equal to our
soup find underscore all and then we're
going to look for our headers our th
files and since we're in jupiter lab in
this case jupiter notebook i can just
type out column headers if it's the last
variable i have listed it will
automatically print it so it's kind of a
shorthand and we can see right here we
have place i'm guessing that's bib name
gender age city state chip time chip
pace and so on so we have all our
headers right there i shouldn't have to
type them all in and we'll go ahead and
do it before we'll go ahead and do a
header list equals our empty array and
then we can do for a column in column
headers and we can take our header list
and just a pin and what do we want we
want the text from the column so we'll
just do column.text and then if we come
down here and we print our header list
let's see what that looks like if we did
it right we should get a nice list of
all the different column headings we
want so we have place bib name and so on
and then pandas just because pandas is
so cool we can simply do df columns
equals our header from our header list
we simply said df column set to df
headers and then if i print
df.head we'll take a look at that and
we'll see right here it has nicely
placed our values on here place bib name
gender age and so on so very quickly
we've created this nice data frame we
have the data displayed in nice rows and
columns and easy to read and then as a
data scientist the first thing we want
to know is the info what is in these
columns and rows and headers and you see
right here they all come up with
non-null object there's a big flag so if
i want to do anything with this these
are all coming through as strings or an
object i usually mean strings in this
case that they're a string variable and
we have you can quickly read through
this 191 entries date columns total 14
columns there's a total of 14 columns in
the data and it shows you all the
different names and what type of column
they are and it's probably good also to
look at the shape of the data df.shape
we'll go ahead and just run that you see
it's 191 by 14 14 columns 191 entries
this is more like a we look at a numpy
array 191 by 14 for the shape and
remember this is a variable so if i put
it on if it's a last variable or last
value in the set of cells jupiter
automatically prints it out so if you're
in a different ide you want to go ahead
and use the print statement on here
then one of the things you'd want to
also go through we'll create a second
one df2 equals df dot drop in a now the
axis is automatically equal to zero so a
lot of times you'll see something like
axes equal zero comma how equals any
axis equals zero is default that means
we're looking at going down the rows you
could look at the column going across
let's remove the how any that's just
going to confuse you the axis is is
whether you're going down the columns or
if you're looking at a row by row by row
by row or you could be looking at it by
column by column by column this would
drop any column and it would drop off
the n a in any column and how
equals and we want any i always confuse
all in any because they both start with
a all means that all of them have to be
non-value where any means that any of
them can be there to drop it so this
would drop any column with a null value
in it but we want 0 and it'll drop any
value with a null value and then because
0 is always the default we'll just leave
it out and then it's curious as to what
the shape is now did we lose anything
was there any null values in our df2
that we dropped from the df and we'll go
ahead and run that and we see 191 and
14. so we didn't really drop anything
but it's always good to check there's
other ways you can also do are there
let's see any n a's you can detect n a's
in here no values infinite values that's
another one you got to watch out for
we're working with data that we're going
to do something with here in a minute so
you got to be a little careful also in
the convergence are you going to convert
something where people typed in weird
characters to describe the data a
certain way so now we've got to this
point where we have all our different
columns we have our different data and
at this point maybe you're asking or
maybe the shareholder the company is
asking hey can we look at the
based on the chip time here's our chip
time can we plot that versus gender how
does gender versus chip time compare and
so we can do that we can take that and
the first thing we look at is we say hey
well chip time came in as a string and
that's going to be an issue now there's
a number of ways you can change this one
of them is we could go all the way back
up here where we created the data and
find a way to tag it and say hey
whenever this cell text maybe instead of
appending this i notice that anytime
there's two colons in it that's probably
a time signature and let's convert all
the time signatures to date time filled
or whatever a lot of times you don't get
that you don't get that option and
that's always a question in bringing in
data whether you convert the data coming
in at the beginning or do you wait till
you have it open it up and then convert
it when you go to use it we're going to
go ahead and convert it after we got it
into our data frame so we have our df2
here we've dropped all of our n a's we
dropped our we have a shape
in fact let's do this since there's no
difference between df and df2 well we'll
just go ahead and use df2 so let's go
ahead and take our df2 and we want to
take those that specific field and
convert it into some kind of numerical
value we can use and let's add another
column a lot of times this is something
you want to do is where you want to go
ahead and keep all the original columns
and just add a new column in there and
this new column is going to be based on
the if remember correctly we had chip
time that's what we're going to look at
okay we want chip time versus gender if
we go into our pandas we find out we
have
pandas 2 delta and this is actually time
delta and then we just want to take our
df2 and we're going to use the chip time
column so this is going to say hey let's
look at let's convert everything in df2
chip time into a time delta format
that's the data type we're going to put
it as let me go ahead and just run this
and if we go in here and we do info df2
and we'll keep our we're going to look
at this particular column but we want to
keep it as a data frame so this is a
list of all the columns we want to look
at we'll just do dot info on here and
run that and we do an info on that you
can see is now a
time delta 64 nanoseconds uh well we
really don't want nanoseconds we
actually probably want to do it in
minutes uh so let's take a look at that
and let's take this whole thing tf2
let's just set the df2 we have our df2
this is a column we're working with here
and we can use the as type property in
pandas and so we can set this equal to
df2 we'll take our same column in here
and we'll set it as type time delta
seconds so it's still a delta time here
so if i run this you'll see that it
still comes up as where is it hopefully
it turns it into a float so we're now at
a float 64 so it's the number of seconds
in that delta time and then finally we
want to go ahead and turn that from
seconds to say minutes and you know
there's 60 seconds in minutes and so now
we divide by 60 we still have a float we
have our info it shows us it's a float
and then we can go ahead and just do a
print df2 and let's just keep it small
we don't want to look at all our data we
just want to do the head of it and we
run this and you can see right here
where we go to be the last one here's
our chip time in minutes and a lot of
times just to make life easy for viewing
since we're only looking at this
particular element we can do chip time
in minutes and now we just see that oops
we take off we'll go ahead and take off
our info done with that and we'll run
this and you can see we have our minutes
16.8 minutes 17.51 minutes and so on
it's a float number now keep in mind
this is 0.8 that's not 16 minutes and 80
seconds that they can always throw you
if you're going through so many numbers
you forget it's important to remember
that and we're also going to look at the
other one we're looking at is what
gender you want to look at gender to
chip time in minutes and so we can see
here under the head we get male male
male and a number of different setups
and let's switch this to tail real quick
and just look at the end of it and here
we have female female male female female
so we have two different genders and we
have our chip time in minutes and if you
remember we brought in our plt if you
haven't used the plot library the
matplot library you have a drawing place
you're putting stuff on so we have our
plt we're going to do a bar graph and we
just want to simply use our df2 gender
and df2
chip time in minutes so that's going to
plot the two bars and to make it pretty
we'll go ahead and give it the x label
gender the y label chip time minutes and
that simply is remember it always plots
x in the plots y we have our gender our
chip time give it a nice title uh
comparison of average minutes run by
male and female uh and if we go ahead
and run this with the correct titles in
here and everything matches you'll get a
nice graph we can see here the
comparison of average minutes run by
male and female here's our chip time in
minutes the men seem to be slackers in
this particular case and it's actually
there's a number of studies that show
that women team tend to have as far as
doing cross-country there's a lot of
women who have a longer endurance than
men so it's not too surprising but we
can see here the average chip time
around 70 and for women over 100 minutes
and then another really cool thing we
can do is we can describe the data so
df2.describe this again is a pandas
function just like info is we're going
to include uh np number the numpy number
and if we run that you'll see here it
comes up and says chip time in minutes
account it gives you the average or the
mean standard deviation the minimum the
maximum um all the different descriptive
information you're going to want from
your data set on there and just because
there's all kinds of fun ways let's do a
box plot to display your information uh
we can do a box plot where the column
equals chip time in minutes and let's go
ahead and run that keep mistaking my
chip time in minutes you can see it puts
out a nice box plot showing you the
information we have our different values
and floaters this is always interesting
because this is a nice way of seeing
where we have these uh floaters one up
here and there's two up above and of
course here they're a nice spread on the
box plot and we can also modify this a
little bit and we can add in by equals
gender and then we'll give it we'll just
give it a blank title i don't know why
we're going to get a blank title uh
we'll just add a y plot y label on there
for run time and if we run this you can
see here box plot grouped by gender chip
time in minutes and now we have our
female and male two different areas and
you can see how they vary you have your
two different your outlier up here and
you can also see how there's such an
overlap between the two different values
so if i was looking at this i'd be like
wow you know i really could not draw a
conclusive thing on this saying that
women's run time was more in general
because they overlapped too much that
would be one of the conclusions i'd have
to come up with then here and then we
get to maybe the partners come in from
the company and say hey we'd like to
know the age versus chip time in minutes
that'd be something worth knowing on the
statistics on this and the first thought
is we can simply plot it and we can do
this we can actually plot the scatter
plot chip time versus df2 of h those are
xy coordinates but if you remember from
df2 when we did the info let's go way
back up here we're looking at a data
object as far as our chip time on this
and our h now we converted the chip time
but we also need to convert the age and
if we do it right here we just plot it
and it'll actually let us plot it it
shouldn't it should give us an error but
it does let us plot it you'll see the
ages come up a mess over here because
they're converting it to weird float
numbers and all kinds of things so what
we want to do is we want to take our age
and we'll just call this h underscore i
so we're going to take our age and we're
going to create another column for df2
age underscore i and the i is just going
to stand for integers our own choice of
values there is a number of ways to do
this but we're going to do uh pandas 2
merrick is the best way in pandas and
the reason we're doing this is that
numeric creates a float value uh so
right off the bat we want all our stuff
converted it converts it to the least
common denominator so if they're all
integers already you'll get integers as
you can see from here it's doing some
kind of conversion that converts it to a
float value the other thing that numeric
does is if there is a null value or they
put in like a blank line or a dash to
represent no information it'll convert
it to a
null so it goes from like a string to a
null versus just having some kind of
made up number that python somehow
created for the graph we have below and
then we want to add our df2h because
that's what we're converting to numeric
and then we want to coerce it and
there's a couple different options on
this like you can have it where it just
doesn't process it in pandas but coerce
means that if it gets a weird value that
is a null value now and since we're
dealing with errors this is what happens
when you get an error converting it we
want to coerce it there we go and put
the end bracket on there and then
finally we want to go and round this off
so i'll put brackets around all the way
around it and this rounds off everything
in this series so we've done here is
i've taken df2h which is a d type object
which in this case is mostly strings
with a couple blank ones in there and
we're going to convert it to a numeric
which will automatically go to float and
then we're going to take wherever
there's an error wherever it says hey
this doesn't convert and usually that's
a blank screen like i said i've worked
with so many databases where they
someone puts down none someone types in
space sometimes in a dashed i mean none
and you get this really weird conversion
coming up this covers all of that in
pandas so it's really a nice way of just
coercing it and saying hey if we don't
have a number in there let's make it a
null value and then we're going to round
it off and then finally let's go ahead
and take our df2 here's our df2 and
let's drop those null values drop in a
and we want how how equals any so that
means if there's any null values in the
data set now you can this might get you
in trouble because you might have no
values in a different column and so you
might lose
data that way at this point we could
also do like certain parts of like drop
just certain columns with null values
there's all kinds of other options in
here what we're just going to do how
we're going to just drop any and we want
to do it in line equals true so that
means it's going to reassign it to df2
so df2 now has a rounded out so it's
rounded to the integer we didn't do any
places the age and it's going to be age
i and then we've dropped all our null
values that way we're not going to get
any errors when we try to plot a null
value and it also makes sure that data
by deleting out the rows because that's
what this does it automatically does
axis0 which is your rows axes one is
your column by doing this it
automatically removes all the rows with
null values so it just cleans out the
rolls and then when we go ahead and plot
this we see we have a nice clean data
and we have age all the way up to 70. uh
so we have our chip time set and then
our age going across and it makes a nice
plot that you can easily show
for display and for the
and you can easily show that to your
shareholders or whatever group you're
working on it makes a really nice and
quick easy display and now anjali is
going to explain how you can become a
python developer following that richard
will cover 50 hand-picked interview
questions that you might face in your
job interviews a very warm welcome to
this video on how to get a job as a
python developer the job of python
developer is one of the most sought
after in the market right now and for
that very reason it might not be that
simple to land this shop so in today's
video i'll give you 12 tips on how you
can land this job so let's begin tip
number one build your own github
repository so go on github create a
repository and add all your files all
your python codes on there so it doesn't
matter if it's a big project or some
small piece of code where you just took
some input and made some manipulations
displayed it every work counts learn a
bit of github version control so not
only do you upload your file once but
you can make modifications to them
rework on them make it better upload it
again showing your progress now this
github repository basically becomes your
resume as a python developer the
recruiters can look directly on here
instead of you sending them zip files or
even jupiter notebooks everything is now
available online and they can access it
from anywhere through any machine so
this really shows that you're not just
writing code for yourself but you want
to share this with other people and
that's very important tip number two
make sure that your code is readable so
when you're putting your code out in
github as i mentioned previously you're
writing this code not just for yourself
so if people want to learn from your
code they want to view your code it's
necessary that they understand this code
and of course there are a few guidelines
to follow which makes your code more
readable the most important one being
you follow the pep 8 style guideline in
case of python so the pep 8 style
guidelines basically some conventions
that you use and that mainly talks about
indentation so in case of pep 8 you have
a 4 space indentation tabs and spaces
that's maximum line length which in case
of pep 8 is 79 characters per line the
line breaks that you need to put blank
lines for example every major class or
every major function needs to be
separated by two lines two blank lines
the source file encoding string codes
white spaces in expression trailing
commas naming conventions and so on so
again very basic thing if you're having
a variable make sure the variable name
shows what the variable stores what it
is used for and it's not just some big
name such as bad one where two and so on
tip number three create a good
documentation again this helps with the
readability and the understandability of
the code so one of the main things with
creating a good documentation is having
a readme file in your github repository
the readme file should contain details
regarding your project what your project
does the various libraries used in your
project and so on so this is a great
help to anyone who is trying to learn
from your code or implement them in a
different way now here we have a
screenshot of the readme file created by
raymond hettinger it's present in his
github repository now who is raymond
hettinger well that brings us to our
fourth point raymond hettinger like
another guy kenneth reed these are some
of the very popular personalities on
github they have a very unique style and
a very neat and organized style of
coding and one of the great ways to
develop your own coding skill is to look
at other people's code now when you're
looking at other people's code it's
important to remember that you look at
code which is of your own skill level so
if you are an intermediate coder make
sure you look at someone's github
repository who again codes on the
intermediate level so that you're able
to connect with that code you could
probably write the same code but he or
she writes it in a better manner now
these are some of the people who have
great github repositories you can
definitely learn a lot from them tip
number five read books on python coding
so you might know already quite a bit of
python in fact if you're looking for a
python developer job there's a good
chance that you are an advanced coder
but nothing beats books here are some of
the very popular and well-renowned books
for python fluent python automate the
boring stuffs with python and so on now
fluent python is a great book to start
with what it does it just not what it
does is it gets your python concepts
really strong so now you'll have not
only great skills but also the perfect
way to portray these skills tip number
six grow your python skill set of course
you can never stop learning keep
learning and some of the very important
things when you go for a python
developer job is to make sure that you
know how to work with some of these
python libraries in fact make sure that
while you can cover most of these
libraries there are certain ones that
you have completely mastered some of the
very popular libraries with python are
numpy scipy matplotlib tensorflow and so
on so learn these master them create
projects around them and finally put
these all up on github for everyone to
view tip number seven it's never enough
to just know a language you must know
how to apply it and with python some of
its most important and popular
applications are in the field of ai
machine learning and data science so
master ai and machine learning with
python learn the various algorithms that
these fields use and implement projects
on them as you can see here we have two
of the algorithms with machine learning
that's linear regression k means
clustering neural networks is an
algorithm used with deep learning so
make sure you have some of these
applications up there in your repository
this displays your skill not only in
python but also in other fields and both
of these going hand in hand just
increases your value tip number eight
take freelancing projects to start off
with so so far i mentioned how you write
your own code you create your own
projects now that's not enough take up
projects by companies now these may be
non-paid they may be really low paid
does not matter as long as you have
something to show off so you have a
project under your belt that really pays
off now some of the websites you can go
to for freelancing works our freelancer
upwork twago truelancer.com and so on so
this really shows to the recruiter that
this person did not just learn python
but he or she is always looking at how
to implement them how to use them tip
number nine make open source
contributions so you have your own
github repository that's great but now
look into others repositories see if
there's some value that you can add and
if you can definitely go for it this
shows not only your skill but also that
you're a team player you want to add
value to work that is already existing
and that is a skill that's again really
valued in organizations so some of the
popular ones include pip env which is
the python development workflow for
humans there's also chattistics where
you can convert your messenger and hang
out chat logs into data frames then you
can solve your traveling salesman
problems using self-organizing maps and
there's also a python to bpf converter
so these are great places to make your
contributions in fact we have the links
for some of these in the description
below so please check them out tip
number 10 start a blog and talk about
what you have learned so having your own
personal blog will add a lot of
credibility to your profile in your blog
you can definitely mention where you
started off from that is at a beginner
level what all did you know how you took
on your journey to where you are now
what materials you used to collect
information and what projects you took
on how you went about this mention any
papers you wrote and so on all this
again becomes another profile for you
the recruiters can have a quick look at
your personal blog and have a good idea
of what kind of a learner you are what
kind of a coder you are and if you have
done everything right this could create
a great impression on the recruiters and
if you have done everything right this
will create a great mark on the
recruiters so here's a screenshot on ned
bachelder's blog on python it'll give
you a good idea as to how to create a
blog and how to go about it so please
check that out so here's a list of all
his blog posts he has 227 blogs just for
python and he writes on various topics
for example here we have a screenshot of
is python interpreted or compiled in
fact you can even include some of your
personal views on python on the learning
process or the learning curve of python
and so on tip number 11 follow a daily
schedule for practice so just because
you think you have mastered the language
do not put it aside and let it collect
dust take out some time every day write
code whether small or big make sure that
every aspect of python is at your
fingertips and finally tip number 12
keep your resume and profile updated on
job portals such as linkedin indeed
glassdoor and careerbuilder look out for
python developer job roles on these
sites and google jobs simply hire dice
and more a recently updated resume
always captures the eye of the recruiter
so these are some of the tips you can
follow to back that python developer's
job if you're new to python and require
some help in gaining the skills to
attain that job of a python developer
you have come to the right place just go
to our website
simplylearn.com and in here we have just
the course for you in fact we have a
number of courses for python but you can
start off here with python training
course this course covers everything a
to z for python and it's pretty much all
you require to get that job so before
you take up the course you can
definitely go through everything that it
covers the objectives who should take up
this course the prerequisites what
projects are covered under the course
and also the subheadings of the various
topics covered certainly the questions
we're going to ask in here are very
general with a few specifics towards
data science since that's the main
direction that python's going in and
you'd want to expand your questions for
your interview depending on the domain
that you're using the python in
specifically let's dive in and get
started with some python interview
questions number one what is the
difference between shallow copy and deep
copy and you can see with shallow copy
we have object one which has child one
child two child three and so on and
object two which has child one child two
child three a deep copy creates a
different object and populates it with
the child objects of the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is not reflected in the copy copy.deep
copy creates a deep copy shallow copy
creates a different object and populates
it with the references of the child
objects within the original object
therefore changes in the original object
is reflected in the copy copy.copy
creates a shallow copy and you can look
at this if we make a change to child one
it's only a pointer so if you make it in
object one and change to child one and
object one it will also make that change
in object two number two how is
multi-threading achieved in python oh
this is a good one with multi-processing
and multi-threading this question is
actually asking you do you know the
difference between multi-processing and
multi-threading and how multi-threading
works multi-threading usually implies
that multiple threads are executed
concurrently the python global
interpreter lock doesn't allow more than
one thread to hold the python
interpreter at that particular point of
time so multi-threading in python is
achieved through context switching it's
very different than multi-processing
which actually opens up multiple
processes across multiple threads so
multi-threading discuss the django
architecture so the django architecture
and the first thing to know is that the
django is a web service way to build
your web pages basically and so we look
at the architecture you can see here we
have a nice model drawn out where the
user initiates the jangle which
initiates the url which initiates the
view what they're going to view and you
have your model and your template so the
model of data whatever data model you're
pulling goes into the template and then
goes back up the pipeline to the user
and the important thing to note is
there's a template the front end of the
web page this is what they're going to
see there's a model the back end where
the data is stored so you can keep the
template and the looks and everything
looks the same but you can swap out the
underlying information that goes into
that template then you have your view
which interacts with the model and
template and maps it to the url and then
the django serves the page to the user
so your django grabs it and says okay
thank you for the url and here you go
user what advantage does numpy array
have over a nested list
so numpy's a module you import almost
always see
numpy import numpy as np numpy is
written in c such that all its
complexities are backed into a simple to
use module lists on the other hand are
dynamically typed therefore python must
check the data type of each element
every time it uses it this make number
arrays much faster than lists i would
also add in that numpy has a lot of
additional functionality that you don't
have in lists there's a lot of things
you can automate in the numpy quick flip
over to our jupyter notebook any ide
will work if you're going to do a set of
use of interview questions taking a
quick look at code is always important
we have our import numpy as np we're
going to import time here's our list
list sub for iron range of 100 and what
we're doing is we're going to time it so
we're going to create a list then we're
going to create a numpy zeros array and
you can see here look how quick you can
create this numpy zeros array here we
are appending one zero at a time for a
regular python list and here we are with
numpy they're all zeros and they're all
of type integer i believe it's either
float or integer on this i'd have to
actually do a type on it and then so if
we take in and we create a tl1 time
equals time and then we do for i in
range of 100 for j in range of 100 l of
i j equals l of i j plus 5. so we're
just doing a simple calculation on our
array and sub arrays this is an array of
rays and we'll do the same thing with
tl2 tl2 time dot time tl1 equal so here
we have our final time on that and then
we'll do this with an array array op and
this is what i really love a equals a
plus 10 and then you can just print it
right out so you can see right here with
the numpy array we're doing the same
thing if i run this our time is
significantly different here we have
0.09 and 0.003 uh so you can see that
the time drops significantly when you're
running this on a numpy array versus a
list array also important to note these
times aren't going to be they'll change
each time i run it depending on what i
have running in the background so there
we go number five what is pickling and
unpickling amazes me how many times i
pickle and unpickle something converting
a python object hierarchy to a byte
stream is called pickling pickling is
also referred to as serialization
unpickling converting a byte stream to a
python object hierarchy is also called
unpickling unpickling is also referred
to as
deserialization so if you just created a
neural network model you can now save
that model to your hard drive pickle it
and then you can unpickle it to bring it
back into another software program or to
use at a later time how was memory
managed in python number six python has
a private heap space where it stores all
the objects the python memory manager
manages various aspects of this heap
like sharing caching segmentation and
allocation the user has no control over
the heap only the python interpreter has
the access you have a nice little
diagram here here's your program there's
your interpreter we have our heap memory
management on the garbage collector
going off of there number seven are
arguments in python pass by value or by
reference
arguments are passed in python by
reference this means that any change
made within a function is reflected on
the original object so you can see here
def function of l l of 0 equals 3 l
equals 1 2 3 4 function l print l and
you're going to get 3 2 3 4 because we
passed l in there so it's a pointer here
we have def function l l equals 3 2 3 4
l equals 1 2 3 4 function of l print l
because in this function i have assigned
instead of operating on a piece of l the
list i've consigned a whole new value to
that list or l it then at that point
will create a new object so if i make
changes to the object it's going to
change it in the outside the definition
if i use a variable and i cited a
completely new value like l equals 3234
that will not show up when you're
outside the function number eight how
would you generate random numbers in
python to generate random numbers in
python you must first import the random
module the random function generates a
random float value between zero and one
the random range function generates a
random number within a given range and
you can see here one is the lower end
tens the upper end and step two so it'd
be one three five and so on as far as
the options in the random generation
number nine what does the double forward
slash operator do in python the forward
slash operator performs division and
returns the quotient in float for
example 5 over 2 returns 2.5 to do a
double forward slash operator on the
other hand returns the quotient an
integer for example 5 double slash
returns 2. 5 divided by 2 and you drop
the 0.5 number 10 what does the is
operator do the is operator compares the
id of the two objects and you can see in
here where list one equals brackets
round one two three list one equals list
two equals true and you have the double
equals in python of course and you can
do list one is list two where list two
equals one two three is false list two
is not the brackets one two three it
equals it but it's not the brackets and
if we do list three equals list one then
list one is list three equals true
number eleven what is the purpose of
pass statement the pass statement is
used when there's a syntactic but not an
operational requirement for example the
program below prints a string ignoring
the spaces and so here we have variable
equals simply learn we've added two
spaces in it for i and variable so it
goes through each eye if i equals space
do nothing else print i and then we'll
have the end equals bracket bracket and
they'll print out simply learn now of
course you would probably write this if
i does not equal blank space print but
this would be another way you could do
that if you need a placeholder for that
first logical set or that first area you
can also do a function like this you
could do function whatever your def
function name brackets colon pass so it
goes into the function and does nothing
but it's a placeholder number 12 how
will you check all the characters in a
string are alphanumeric python has an
inbuilt method is all number which
returns true if all characters in the
string are alphanumeric and so you can
see here abcd123
is all number output equals true and the
second line a b c d the at symbol 1 2 3
the pound symbol is all nume output
equals false so really just want to know
about is all new all numerical
alphanumerical number 12 how will you
check if all characters in a string are
alphanumeric so here we go
if you know is all number which returns
that the characters in the string are
alphanumeric one can also use regex
instead and so we have boolean rematch
what's important about this is to note
your capital a dash to capital z a lower
codes to dash to z 0 to 9 means that
that array includes all of those the way
they have it written out plus a dollar
sign and then we have what we're
comparing it to the string we're
comparing to the abcd123
and so we can do an re.match and if it
matches if all these things if all the
different entities in that array matches
the first one we'll get an output true
and if not an output false number 13 how
will you merge elements in a sequence
sequence there are three types of
sequences in python there's lists tuples
and strings python acoustics makes this
easy if we have a list one and list two
and list one is uh square brackets one
comma two comma three list two is four
five and six we can simply do list one
plus list two and our output is one two
three four five six if we have tuples
your tuple is the curved brackets
designates it and again just add them
together same thing with strings we have
simply learn s1 plus s2 equals simply
learn number 14 how will you remove all
leading white space in a string python
provides the inbuilt function l strip to
remove all leading access from a string
and you can see here spacebase base
python.l strip leading strip python and
you can also do strip which release
leading and ending of course there's
also the ending set number 15 how will
you replace all occurrences of a stub
string with a new string the replace
function can be used with strings for
replacing a substring with a given
string syntax dot replace old comma new
comma count replace returns a new string
without modifying the original string
hey john how are you john question mark
replace john with capital j-o-h-n one
and then you can see right here hey john
how are you and since we designated with
the one just says we're only going to
replace one of these 16 what is the
difference between dell and remove
brackets on lists dell for delete dell
removes all elements of a list within a
given range syntax dell list start to
end remove remove brackets removes the
first occurrence of a particular
character syntax list remove element and
we see a nice example over here if we
delete the list one to three it will
delete the first in this case b one two
it doesn't do three remember that one
two so we'll delete b and c and you end
up with a d where if we do remove b from
the list and we have an a b b d it's
only gonna remove the first b number 17
how to display the contents of text file
in reverse order open the file using the
open function store the contents of the
file into a list reverse the contents of
the list run a for loop to iterate
through the list number 18 differential
between append and extend append adds an
element to the end of the list you can
see right here we have a list one two
three four and we append four we end up
with an output one two three four and
extend adds an element from an interval
to the end of the list and we have here
list equals one two three list dot
extend four five six output is one two
three four five six so if you wanna
append an array to the end of another
array you want to use the extend number
19 what's the output of the below code
justify your answer this is a great
interview question because these are the
kind of things that come up when you're
proofing code def add to list value and
list so we have value in and a listing
or list equals an empty in this case an
empty list list data pin value return
list list one equals add to list one
list two equals add to list one two
three empty bracket list three equals
add to list a and then we want to print
them list one equals and you can see the
formatting we have our placeholder list
one list two and list three so when it
prints list one we get one comma a and
what you want to notice here is that
list one and list three are equal why
are they equal well when we passed the
information to the add to list we passed
value without passing the list equals
brackets without passing a second value
what this means is that list as we have
it if you don't have a list it'll start
off with empty list which we append the
one to the second one list two we
appended a value to an empty list so
it's only going to be one two three
doesn't matter what the list was before
we've already assigned an empty list and
then list three here's the tricky one
we're adding a to the list but because
we didn't designate the list list is a
shared value in other words it doesn't
reset it and we end up with list one
equals list three one comma a default
this is created only once during the
function and not during its call number
20 what is the difference between a list
and a tuple lists are mutable while
tuples are immutable and you can see an
example down here where i have list
equals one two three square brackets
denote it's a list list of two equals
four and i printed out i now have one
two four if i do the same thing with the
tuple i get an error because you can't
change the tuple one two three into one
two four you have to completely reassign
tuple to a new value what is docs string
in python doc strings are used in
providing documentation to various
python modules classes functions and
methods and so you can see here we have
def for a function add a b and this is a
doc string we have the
triple brackets on there you can add
carriage return in that so that you can
go multiple lines and it says this
function adds two numbers and then sum a
b return sum and so we have down here
two different ways of accessing this
function output accessing docstring
method one this function adds two
numbers accessing docstring method two
help on function add in model main this
function adds two numbers and so you can
see the code down here has two very
different in values the second one is
basically a help menu there's our help
menu number 22 how to use print without
the new line the solution to this
depends on the python version you are
using in python version 2 you can do
print hi and then you add a comma
afterwards print how are you and you
have hi how are you in version three
print hi comma end equals and it'll add
a space on the end there you can put
different characters in there but you
just want to put a space to put a space
on the end print how are you and now we
get hi how are you number 23 how do you
use the split function in python the
split function splits a string into a
number of strings based on a specific
delimiter so we have string split
delimiter comma max the maximum number
of splits the character based on which
the string is to split by default is
space so here we have an example we have
a variable red blue green orange and we
want to split it by commas and we only
want to do the first two so if we print
the list now you'll find it has red blue
and only spread it split it the first
two times and it gets to the third one
and just groups them all together green
and orange if you leave the two off
you'll split the whole thing number 24
is python object oriented or functional
programming python follows
object-oriented paradigm and you should
really know in depth what they mean by
object-oriented paradigm if you're doing
any interview for scripting languages
python allows the creation of objects
and is manipulation through specific
methods it supports most of the features
of oops which has inheritance on a
polymorphism so you have an object and
you can inherit all the traits of that
object and then add new traits in or
alter some of those traits that's what
object oriented means python follows
functional programming paradigm
functions may be used as first class
object python supports lambda functions
which are characteristic of functional
paradigm so you can set a variable to a
function as opposed to setting it to an
object number 25 write a function
prototype that takes variable number of
arguments here we have def function name
list so we could have in this case
whatever the list is def function the
asterisk denotes so we're going to take
multiple arguments of a variable and we
can do for i and var print i so if you
send function of one you'll end up with
a one function one two five six they'll
actually print those out one at a time
the first one just prints out a one
because it only sent one variable the
second one will print one another line
twenty five another line six number
twenty six what is asterisks args and
asterix quarks
args used in function prototype to
accept varying number of arguments it's
an iterable object def function arcs and
you can imagine it's just a basic list
so if i send add the numbers a comma b
or a comma b comma c it doesn't really
matter it will have that number of
objects in it whatever i send to it and
there's other uses for it but that's
very basic korg's i can actually tell it
what i want to send so using a function
prototype and to accept varying number
of keyworded arguments it's in both our
iterable objects so you can go through
them one at a time and the def function
chords you can now set like color equals
red units equal to so you'll see that
especially in machine learning there's a
lot of like they'll have inline equals
true that kind of thing number 27 in
python functions are first class objects
what do you understand from this
this means i could return a function
could be one from another function i
could create a function and treat it
just like an object i can assign it to a
variable i can pass them as arguments to
other functions number 28 what is the
output of print name underscore
underscore name and justify your answer
the double underscore name double
underscore is a special variable that
holds the name of the current module
program execution starts from main or a
code with zero indentation
double underscore name dumbbell
underscore name has a value double
underscore main double underscore in the
above case if the file is imported from
another module then double underscore
name underscore double underscore holds
the name of this module number 29
what is a numpy array and we briefly
touched numpy array compared to a list
early in processing speed now let's go
ahead and look at some of the more
specifics a numpy array is a grid of
values all of the same type so if
they're either all float all integer all
string and is indexed by a tuple of
non-negative integers the number of
dimensions is the rank of the array and
the shape of an array is a tuple of
integers giving the size of the ray
along each dimension number 30 what is
the difference between matrices and
arrays a matrix comes from linear
algebra and is a two-dimensional
representation of data it comes with a
powerful set of mathematical operations
that allow you to manipulate the data in
interesting ways now arrays an array is
a sequence of objects of similar data
type an array within another array forms
a matrix like we said here
two-dimensional so if you have an array
of three by four that would be a matrix
number 31 how to get indexes of n
maximum values in a numpy array of
course the first thing to do is to
import your numpy as np you don't
necessarily have to use mp but that is
the most standard use of numpy we create
our array equals an np.array of one two
three four five and then if we want to
get our indexes of n at maximum values
in a numpy array we can do
one way to do it is to take our array
sort it then do minus in colon that
means we're going to do once you've
sorted it you can do minus in n would
equal then the number of entities so
it's not the actual letter n colon and
really this is about understanding this
notation that we can sort it so it goes
from lowest to biggest and then we can
get the top values for n indexes and
then we have our final set of brackets
with the minus 1 on there number 32 how
would you obtain the resulting set from
the train set and the test set from
below and let's go ahead and look at the
two different variables we have train
set equals an array of one two three
test set equals a numpy of ray of arrays
we have 0 1 2 1 2 3. what's important
here is that one it's a numpy so that
leaves a out and then we're stuck with
three other options and i'm going to say
the d is out none of these and let's
look at uh np.concatenate
versus
np.v stack concatenate would put one set
after the other so you would end up with
probably give you an error because one
set is one two three and then we're
going to concatenate array012
and one array one two three the array of
arrays onto the end of that what we
really want to do is stack and by the
way you can actually switch there's
variables you can put into concatenate
obviously they can change this so you
could use the concatenate with a lot of
fudging around but really we're looking
for is v stack v stands for vertical
versus the h deck which is horizontal
and if we do a v stack we can simply do
train set comma test set and stack them
together and so we have c resulting set
equals np.v stack train stack test set
both option a and b would do horizontal
stacking but we would like to have the
vertical stacking option she does this
again you could add the axes in and use
the concatenate to stack it the correct
way number 33 how would you import a
decision tree classifier in sk learn we
have sklearn dot decision tree import
decision tree classifier from sk learn
ensemble import decision tree classifier
and we look at these and they're all
import decision tree classifier that
actually last part happens to be correct
and it's really just a vocabulary
knowing where is the decision tree
classifier stored what module is that a
part of and it is of course part of the
sklearn.tree
number c number 34. you have uploaded
the dataset in csv format on google
spreadsheet and shared it publicly how
can you access this in python what's
important here is to know that we can
read stuff with pandas so we don't show
it here but you can there's actually a
number of ways to do this what's
important here is to know a couple
things one we have our link generated
from the google docs and spreadsheets
and then we can do a string io dot
string io request get link dot content
so there's our source and then finally
we know that pandas can read a csv
there's obviously many ways to read a
csv but data equals pd.read underscore
csv source number 35 what is the
difference between the two data series
given below below we have df name and df
location colon comma brackets around
asterisks around name comma where and
then we have df equals pd data frame
aabb xx uu comma 21 16 5033 columns
equal name and age so let's take a look
and see what they're looking at we have
just glancing at the questions they want
to know is it the original data frame or
is it the copy of the data frame and you
can see here that one is view of the
original data frame and two is a copy of
the original data frame two is a view of
the original data frame and one is a
copy of the original data frame both are
copies both are views and if you're
working with pandas you know that unless
you specifically in certain things tell
it to do it in line and a lot of
functions don't allow you that you're
always taking a slice and it is always a
copy so c both are copies of the
original data frame number 36 you get
the following error while trying to read
a file temp dot csv using pandas which
of the following could correct it so
here's our error traceback most recent
call last file input line 1 and module
unicode encode error ascii codex can't
encode character oh i hate it when that
one comes up and we have four different
entries we'll go ahead and just pretend
that d doesn't exist unless we really
can't fit it into one of the other
answers and the first one is pd read csv
has our file compression equals gzip
well g zip is just an unzipping and you
actually get a zip error on there the
second one is dialect equals string
again not an encoding or coding setup
and then we have encoding equals utf-8
well that would be the encoding error
switching it from the character code
there's utf-8 there is unicode that's
the most common two that goes between so
really this is about understanding the
difference between a utf-8 coding and a
unicode and the error that comes up
quite regularly with that number c
encoding should be utf-8 number 37 how
to set a line with any plot given below
so looking at this we have import
matplot library pi plot as plt and you
should know your way around this how to
do a plot in there plt.plot1234
plot equals show and so this is a little
bit of a vocabulary test the vocabulary
is it width equals three line width
equals three lw equals three or
something else and the vocabulary word
that we're looking for is lw equals
three which stands for line width in pi
plot library pi plot number 38 how would
you reset the index of a data frame to a
given list so this is a
vocabulary challenge and understanding
what re-indexing is re-indexing as we
have the different values here we have
the first one which is reset the index
well we're not really resetting the
index re-index number b means we are
double checking our indexes to the
column and to the main index and so the
values match correctly where reindex
like now brings in a new index outside
of our data frame to a given list so
this is coming from external and thus
the vocabulary word like is our key word
that is external and we have a data
friend to a given list number 39 how can
you copy objects in python the functions
used to copy objects in python we have
copy copy for shallow copying and copy
deep copying for deep copy number 40
what is the difference between range and
x range functions in python well this is
a good one we have matrixes and arrays
with a matrix the range returns a python
list object x range returns an x range
object and with arrays an x-ray returns
an x-range object x-range creates values
as you need them through yielding the
key here is that x-range returns the
values as you need them so it actually
processes it post like if you have for x
or for a variable in x range it is
processing them as you need them zero to
nine it doesn't create an array zero to
nine it just hands you zero then one two
three four one at a time number 41 how
can you check whether a pandas data
frame is empty or not the tribute
df.empty is used to check whether a
panda's data frame is empty or not and
so you can simply create a we have down
here import our pandas as pd we create
our pandas data frame equal to an empty
array and is df dot empty comes out as
true one of the catches you got to
remember with these vocabularies is with
empty along with some other pandas setup
whether you need the brackets or not at
the end number 42 write the code to sort
an array in numpy by the n minus one
column this can be achieved using arg
sort function let's take an array x then
to sort the n minus one column the code
will be x to x to colon in minus two dot
args sort so let's see what that code
looks like we import numpy as np we'll
create our array um our numpy array
which is uh one two three zero five two
two three four so we have three
different entities with three different
columns in there and we go x of x and so
we take x of
all the rows first entity or in this
case it's actually the second one
because it's zero one two dot arg sort
so that would be the second entity or
minus two would also be the same you
could also do instead of one you could
also do minus two there instead of the
one arg sort and then we get an output
of the array one two three zero five two
two three four number 43 how to create a
series from a list numpy array and
dictionary so we'll go ahead and input
import our numpy our pandas and have my
list and you can see here we have my
list equals list of a b c d e f g over
all the way through so my list now makes
a list of that for
array we have np dot a range to 26 my
dictionary will create a dictionary with
a zip my list my arguments so i'll just
use the numpy array we just created with
my array to go into
the dictionary and the solution is
simple with the
pd.series my list pd.series myarray
pd.seriesmydictionary so it's all about
knowing the dot capital s e r i e s
don't forget that capitalization number
44 how to get the items not common to
both series a and series b and you can
see here we have instead of series a and
b we have series one and two and we have
one two three four five four five six
seven eight the solution is we take a
panda series we have a series u equals a
panda series np union one dimension
series one series 2 so we can now make a
union of them we now have series 1 panda
series with an intersection and then we
can remove one from the other series u
is series u dot is in series 1. so if
the union is not in the intersection
then you know it's a unique value a
little bit of logic going on there
playing with three different terms to
get the answer we want 45 how to keep
only the top two most frequent values as
it is and replace everything else as
other in a series so again we're working
with pandas because we're talking series
and data frames that means we're working
with pandas so we're going to import
pandas as pd we'll go ahead and create
our panda series we're going to do that
by creating a numpy random random state
100 so 100 and the numpy one and then we
have our panda series you can see here
we're random integer numpy random to
random integer of 1 comma 5 by 12. and
so the solution for this is we go ahead
and we've created a pd dot remember the
capital s series solution we're going to
print the top two frequencies and that
is our series dot value counts and then
we take series values count dot index of
up to two so we're going to take
everything up to two and then we'll do
the series is in so if it's not in the
first two then it's going to equal other
and this would be something you'd want
to write down on paper if you're if it
looks confusing take a moment pause the
video
write this down and see if you can
figure out how the logic came together
and try to throw yourself a couple other
little logic puzzles like this number 46
how to find the positions of numbers
that are multiples of 3 from a series
and in here we're actually going to use
a numpy to solve it the first part
series lets you know it's going to be a
panda series and if we come down here we
have np.org where this is a vocabulary
question series with remember the
percentile 3 is a remainder so if the
remainder equals 0 then we're going to
generate that string where the object
divided by 3 equals 0 has no remainder
so then we know it's a multiple of 3.
number 47 how to compute the euclidean
distance between two series and this
one's really cool because we have our
panda series p and q and what i like
about this one is they give us two
solutions you can go with and really you
should kind of know both the first one
would be yes you know what the euclidean
distance is and that is we can take the
first series minus the second series
squared and then sum them up and then we
do the square root which is the same as
taking the power to 0.5 doing the power
to 0.5 is easier than doing the square
root so a lot of times you'll see that
as a switch but you could have also done
the square root and use the math in
there so there's solution one you should
know your euclidean distance and then
solution two is the numpy solution so we
have np dot lin-alg dot norm that's how
we're gonna compute our euclidean
distance
p minus q very elegant and very
straightforward and easy to compute
number 48 how to reverse the rows of
data frame so here we have our data
frame we're going to create a numpy
array by 25 reshape it five minus one
and this creates a 25 by 25 data frame
and so our solution is to do the dfi
location and this is just understanding
how steps work the steps you have your
colon colon minus one so we're taking
all the rows all the columns minus one
so our stepping minus one going the
reverse direction and then we're just
going to use across all the different
columns on there let me say that again
the first colon is going to be your row
starting row stopping row step minus one
that's all this is about is that step
minus one comma and then all the columns
forty-nine if you split your data into
train test splits is it possible to over
fit your model and the answer is yes is
definitely possible one common beginner
mistake is retuning a model or training
new models with different parameters
after seeing his performance on the test
set my favorite example of this is you
have your script put together and you
keep hitting the re-run button until you
get the answer you want not taking the
answer it first gave you or running it
over an array and recording all the
answers to see how they vary number 50
which python library is built on top of
map plot library and pandas
to ease data plotting the answer this is
seabourn seaborne is a data
visualization library in python that
provides a high level interface for
drawing statistical information
informative graphs i hope this helps you
in your interview with that we've
reached the end of this complete python
course i hope you enjoyed this video do
like and share it thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn